[CAPTIONS MADE POSSIBLE BY MLB
NETWORK]
[CAPTIONING PERFORMED BY THE
NATIONAL CAPTIONING INSTITUTE,
WHICH IS RESPONSIBLE FOR ITS
CAPTION CONTENT AND ACCURACY.
VISIT NCICAP.ORG]
STEPHEN: WHAT UP AND WELCOME TO
THE MLB GAME OF THE WEEK PREGAME
SHOW PRESENTED BY YOUTUBE
SHORTS.
HOUSTON, TEXAS.
MINUTE MAID PARK.
THE SITE OF THE MLB GAME OF THE
WEEK LIVE ON YOUTUBE.
SCOTT BRAUN, THE CALL IN ABOUT A
HALF-HOUR'S TIME.
WE HAVE TO GET SET FOR THE
PIVOTAL A.L. WEST MATCHUP.
HOUSTON EXTENDED THEIR LEAD IN
THE DIVISION TO 6 1/2 GAMES IN
FRONT OF THE VISITING SEATTLE
MARINERS.
LUCKILY THE TRADE DEADLINE HAS
PAST.
NONE OF THE PLAYERS WILL BE
TRADED FOR EACH OTHER.
ANDERSON AND AR KEYEDY.
MIKE LOWELL, I'M STEPHEN NELSON.
SAY YOU WALKED OUT OF THE
M
MARINER DUGOUT.
LAST NIGHT KICKING THE SHORTS
BECAUSE YOU'RE TWO OUTS AWAY
FROM CUTTING THAT DIVISION LEAD
BACK TO 4 1/2 GAMES.
YOU GOT A CHANCE AT THIS THING
NOW, ALEX BREGMAN HITS A BOMB.
CARLOS CORREA KICKS IT OFF.
MIKE: IT CAN BE GUTWRENCHING.
WHEN YOU PLAY THESE
INTERDIVISION GAMES IT'S TWO
SWINGS.
IT'S NOT LET'S SEE HOW THE TEAM
IN FRONT OF US IS DOING.
MY OLD HIGH SCHOOL COACH WOULD
SAY FOR THE ASTROS, GUYS, FOR
THE KNIFE'S IN.
NOW WE TURN IT.
THIS IS A CHANCE FOR THE ASTROS
TO STEP ON THEIR THROAT AND SAY,
YEAH, YOU COULD HAVE BEEN 4 1/2,
NOW YOU'RE 7 1/2.
NOW YOU'RE TALKING AS THOSE
GAMES GET SHORTER, 23, 24 GAMES
LEFT IN THE SEASON.
THAT GAP IS STARTING TO WIDEN IF
YOU'RE SEVEN GAMES BACK.
STEPHEN: HOUSTON CAN SWEEP THE
LEG AND THE SERIES WITH A WIN
TODAY IN GAME NUMBER THREE.
IT'S TOUGH FOR SEATTLE.
NOT ONLY DID THEY LOSE TO
HOUSTON BUT ON A NIGHT WHERE NEW
YORK AND BOSTON, OTHER TWO TEAMS
IN FRONT OF THEM IN THE WILD
CARD RACE, ALSO LOST.
I SHOULD HAVE SAID SPOILER ALERT
WITH THE BREGMAN HOME RUN AND
CORREA WALK-OFF.
IF YOU MISSED IT YOU DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT HAPPENED.
HERE ARE THE HIGHLIGHTS FROM
LAST NIGHT TO REFRESH YOUR
MEMORY.
>> HERE IS ALEX BREGMAN.
HE REPRESENTS THE TYING RUN.
>> AND BREGMAN HITS IT HIGH IN
THE AIR.
DEEP TO LEFT FIELD.
YOU CAN KISS IT GOODBYE.
OFF THE COMMUNITY LEADER SIGNS
AND WE'RE TIED!
>> THE RUNNER AT SECOND FOR THE
ASTROS IS GURRIEL.
CORREA IS 1-4 TODAY.
>> THERE'S BALL INTO RIGHT
FIELD.
HIT WELL.
THAT WILL BE OVER THE HEAD OF
HANIGER.
THAT WILL BE A GAME-WINNER!
ASTROS WIN IT!
STEPHEN: ROBERT, HENRY.
TODD CAL IS ON THE CALL FROM A
THRILLING FINISH TO LAST NIGHT'S
GAME FOR THE HOUSTON ASRESS.
THE A.L. STANDINGS IN BOTH THE
DIVISION IN THE WEST AND THE
WILD CARD.
YOU SEE THE STROS 6 1/2 UP ON
SEATTLE.
OAKLAND HAS A TOUGH STRETCH, AN
AWFUL TIME.
GOT SWEPT BY THE JAYS IN
TORONTO.
THEN LOST TO THE WHITE SOX.
THEY ARE NOW FALLING DOWN THE
STANDINGS.
STILL 3 1/2 GAMES BACK OF THE
WILD CARD, MIKY, BUT A TON --
MIKEY, BUT A TON OF TEAMS IN
FRONT OF THEM.
MIKE: IT MEANS THE GAMES MAY NOT
NOT MEAN MUCH AS THE GAMES.
YOU LOOK AT THE TEAMS THAT WILL
GET HOT.
WE HAVE THE BLUE JAYS AND EITHER
THE YANKEES OR RED SOX WILL HAVE
TO FALTER A LITTLE BIT.
MAN, YOU'RE ASKING TO HAVE TWO,
THREE TEAMS DOWN THE STRETCH
WHERE I THINK THE INTENSITY
INCREASES, THE CONCENTRATION
GETS A BIT BETTER, THE ROSTERS
ARE EXPANDING.
IF YOU'RE PRAYING A BAD TEAM
THEY MIGHT BE TESTING YOUNG GUYS
OUT.
THERE IS A CHANCE TO SEPARATE
YOURSELF IN THAT SENSE.
EACH OF THESE GAMES, I THINK
THESE LAST THREE WEEKS PLAY OUT,
THEY BECOME MORE AND MORE
IMPORTANT.
STEPHEN: ALL RIGHT.
MIKE, IT'S TIME TO UNBOX THE
MATCHUP AHEAD OF OUR MLB GAME OF
THE WEEK HERE ON YOUTUBE.
SEATTLE AND HOUSTON.
LET'S TALK ABOUT BOTH TEAMS
HERE.
LET'S BEGIN WITH THE MARINERS
BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
TALK ABOUT THEM THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR.
THE RUN DIFFERENTIAL.
THEY'RE LIKE, WELL, WHAT ABOUT
OUR FUN DIFFERENTIAL?
THE RUN DIFFERENTIAL IS NOT
SUSTAINABLE.
HERE THEY ARE IN THE THICK OF
IT.
DO YOU FEEL LIKE SEATTLE IS FOR
REAL FOR THE POSTSEASON THIS
YEAR?
MIKE: WELL, THE STANDINGS TELL
ME YES.
I TRIED TO DIG A LITTLE DEEPER.
I AM GOING TO FIND SOMETHING
THAT PROVES WHY THEY'RE IN IT.
AND I HAD A HARD TIME.
YOU KNOW, WHEN I LOOK -- THESE
ARE AMERICAN LEAGUE STATS
OFFENSIVELY.
SECOND TO LAST IN O.P.S.
12th IN RUNS.
LAST IN BATTING AVERAGE.
I'M LIKE, SO HOW ARE THEY DOING
IT?
OK.
LET'S GO TO THE PITCHING SIDE.
THE STARTER E.R.A. IS NINTH.
THEIR BULLPEN'S BEEN VERY GOOD.
FOURTH BEST.
SO I'M SAYING, IF THEY CAN KIND
OF KEEP THOSE TEAMS CLOSE, THEY
CAN BRIDGE IT TO THE BULLPEN AND
I THINK THAT KIND OF EVENS THE
MATCHUP.
THEY JUST DON'T SWING THE BATS
LIKE THE OTHER TEAMS IN THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE THAT ARE VYING
FOR THESE PLAYOFF SPOTS.
SO IT'S HARD, BUT CAN YOU SAY,
WELL, WHEN THEY LOSE THEY LOSE
BY A BUNCH AND WHEN THEY WIN
THEY WIN BY A LITTLE AND THAT'S
WHY THEIR RUN DIFFERENTIAL CAN
BE SKEWED A LITTLE?
I DON'T KNOW.
THE NUMBERS DON'T TELL ME.
THE BOTTOM LINE, NELLY, THEY'RE
WINNING GAMES.
I DON'T CARE HOW YOU WIN IT.
AT THIS POINT IN THE SEASON, I'M
NOT LOOKING TO, WHAT AM I GOING
TO MAP OUT FOR THE FUTURE?
WELL, THERE ARE THREE WEEKS LEFT
IN THE FUTURE.
OFF-SEASON, WE CAN LOOK TOWARDS
2022.
AS LONG AS THEY CAN CREEP AND
CLAW AND MAYBE THOSE A.L. EAST
GUYS, RED SOX AND YANKEES, THEY
BEAT UP EACH OTHER A LITTLE BIT.
THEY BOTH HAVE TO PLAY THE RAYS.
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY WHERE
SOMEONE CAN GET HOT AND A
WEEKEND CAN CHANGE THINGS.
IT'S A BIG SWING IN THE
DIVISION.
STEPHEN: I THINK THEY HAVE 10
GAMES LEFT AGAINST A COUPLE
TEAMS IN FRONT OF THEM IN THE
WILD CARD STANDINGS.
THE OPPORTUNITY IS THERE.
YOU TALK ABOUT THE FUTURE.
IT IS SEEMINGLY BRIGHT.
YOU CAN'T JUST, LIKE, BANK ON
THEM FOR SEATTLE.
THE FUTURE LOOKS BRIGHT, AND IT
ALSO SEEMS STABLE NOW WITH THE
RECENT NEWS IN THE FRONT OFFICE
AND THE DUGOUT.
SCOTT SERVICE EXTENDED AS
MANAGER.
DID A TREMENDOUS JOB.
AND THEN JERRY DEPOETO GETTING
EXTENDED.
SO NOW THESE TWO WORKING
T
TOGETHER, THAT COLLABORATION,
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD ON
THE SUCCESS THEY HAD THIS
SEASON.
MIKE: I THINK FROM AN
ORGANIZATIONAL STANDPOINT ON
WHERE YOU WANT TO GO, THIS IS A
GREAT MOVE.
YOU KNOW, IT'S GUYS THEY'RE
FAMILIAR WITH.
BASEBALL GUYS ON BOTH ENDS.
I BELIEVE IT'S GUYS THEY FEEL
LIKE THE RAPPORT IS NOT ONLY
WITH THE PLAYERS BUT THAT
COMMUNICATION WITH UPPER
MANAGEMENT.
I THINK THAT'S A BIG DEAL TODAY.
I THINK EVERYONE HAS TO FEEL
LIKE THEY ARE ON THE SAME PAGE.
WHEN I WAS COMING INTO THE
LEAGUE, I THINK SOMETIMES YOU
FELT LIKE BASEBALL OPPS GUYS DID
THEIR THING AND FIELD STAFF DID
THEIR THING.
THAT BRIDGE HAS TO BE GAPPED --
THAT GAP HAS TO BE BRIDGED A LOT
MORE THAN BEFORE BECAUSE I THINK
THERE ARE A LOT OF ANALYTICS AND
THINGS THAT NEED TO BE EXPLAINED
SO WHY MOVES AND WHY ROSTER
CONSTRUCTION IS A CERTAIN WAY.
I THINK IT DOES FLOW OVER
INTO -- INTO THE TEAM.
WHEN I LOOK AT GUYS AND I SEE
JARRED KELENIC, MITCH HANIGER.
THE SECOND BASEMAN THEY PICKED
UP.
THE KENDALL TRADE, I THINK
PEOPLE WERE SOUR ON THAT.
STEPHEN: ABRAHAM TORO.
MIKE: ABRAHAM TORO, THIS KID
LOOKS LIKE A PLAYER.
SO YOU START BUILDING THAT WITH
SUCCESS IN THE WIN-LOSS COLUMN
AND I THINK YOU CAN HAVE A REAL
POSITIVE SNOWBALL EFFECT IN THAT
SENSE.
STEPHEN: SOMETHING UNEFRP -- YOU
CAN EMPATHIZE WITH, RELATE TO
THE PLAYERS, YOU LOST A LOT AND
FIGURED OUT HOW TO WIN.
THAT'S SOMETHING THIS CLUBHOUSE
IS STARTING TO DO.
THAT'S SOMETHING HOUSTON HAS
DONE.
MIKE: SURE.
STEPHEN: IT WAS A LOSING
FRANCHISE.
THEN, WON A WORLD SERIES.
NOW, LOOK LIKE ANOTHER
POSTSEASON JUGGERNAUT.
LOOKED LIKE LAST YEAR.
KIND OF FLIPPED THAT SWITCH.
DO YOU VIEW THEM HAVING THAT
POTENTIAL THIS YEAR?
MIKE: 100%.
I LOOK AT THEIR LINEUP
CONSTRUCTION AND LOOK AT HOW
RELENTLESS THEY ARE.
THEY PUT THE BALL IN PLAY, HIT
WITH POWER.
I SEE TUCKER.
I SEE MICHAEL BRANTLEY.
I SEE YORDAN ALVAREZ.
THAT'S GREAT.
DO THEY STACK THEM BEHIND EACH
OTHER?
THEY HAVE GURRIEL, ALTUVE,
BREGMAN.
WOW!
THIS IS A NIGHT MAYOR MATCH --
NIGHTMARE MATCHUP FOR PITCHING
STAFFS AND BULLPENS.
YOU ARE NOT GOING LEFTY, PULL
'EM OUT, YOU CAN'T.
SO SOMEONE IS FACING A GUY IN A
MORE FAVORABLE POSITION.
WHEN I LOOK AT THE NUMBERS, IT'S
LIKE SEVEN DEEP WITH AN O.P.S.
OVER .800.
IT'S A RELENTLESS ATTACK WITH
POWER.
IT'S NOT JUST A BUNCH OF GUYS,
HEY, WE'LL FLIP A COUPLE
SINGLES.
THEY NEED THREE HITS TO DRIVE IN
A RUN.
YOU'RE A BLOOP AND BLAST AWAY
FROM ALWAYS BEING IN IT.
THEIR OFFENSE, WHEN I LOOK AT
THEIR SECOND IN RUNS, SECOND
O.P.S., FIRST ON-BASE
PERCENTAGE, THIRD IN SLUGGING,
THAT'S AN ELITE OFFENSE.
SO THEY ARE A LOT -- THERE ARE A
LOT OF THINGS THEY CAN DO WELL.
STEPHEN: AND THEY ARE ON THE
OTHER END OF THE RUN
DIFFERENTIAL SPECTRUM.
ONE ALEX BREGMAN WILL JOIN US IN
A LITTLE BIT.
PEOPLE ALWAYS MENTION THIS
HOUSTON LINEUP THAT DUSTY BAKER
KIND OF HAS AT HIS DISPOSAL.
WHAT ABOUT THE PITCHING STAFF?
I KNOW THE BULLPEN HAS LEFT A
LITTLE BIT TO BE DESIRED,
SPECIFICALLY THE BACK END.
THE STARTING ROTATION, NO JUSTIN
VERLANDER AND AFTER THE
DEPARTURE OF GERRIT COLE, THEY
HAD GUYS STEP UP AND STEP IN.
MIKE: I'M SURPRISED WHEN I LOOK
AT THEM, STARTER E.R.A. IS BEST
IN THE AMERICAN LEAGUE.
STEPHEN: NOBODY --
MIKE: THE CHICAGO WHITE SOX,
THEY'RE SO PERFECTLY PLANNED.
THEY'RE PERFECTLY FORMED TO GO
INTO THE POSTSEASON AND MAKE A
LONG RUN.
I JUST DON'T THINK IT'S YOUR
TYPICAL HOUSEHOLD NAMES.
McCULLERS IS ACTUALLY HAVING A
NICE YEAR.
GREINKE HAS BEEN BANGED UP.
I THINK IT SOUNDS LIKE IT'S MORE
OF A PRECAUTION.
THOSE ARE YOUR TWO ESTABLISHED
NAMES.
YOU ARE KEYEDY A CUP -- URQUIDY
A COUPLE YEARS AGO WAS IN THE
WORLD SERIES.
MAYBE NOT YOUR HOUSEHOLD NAME
BUT A BATTLE-TESTED GUY.
JAKE ODORIZZI, LUIS GARCIA.
THEY HAVE TALENT THERE.
MAYBE IT WILL TAKE A YEAR OR TWO
M
BEFORE WE KNOW THEM AS A NAME.
HEY, I DON'T WANT TO FACE THIS
GUY IN A DAY GAME FOLLOWING A
NIGHT GAME.
THEY'RE JUST NOT THERE FROM NAME
RECOGNITION PERSPECTIVE.
THE OFFENSE AND THE STARTS THEY
HAD KIND OF OVERSHADOW THOSE
GUYS.
THEIR STARTERS HAVE BEEN
FANTASTIC.
YOU CAN'T GET BETTER.
ARE THEY PRIMED FOR A
POSTSEASON?
YEAH, I THINK THE BALANCE ON
WHAT THEY DO ON THE MOUND AND
OFFENSIVELY POSES A LOT OF
PROBLEMS.
IT'S TOUCH FOR A TEAM TO BEAT
THAT TEAM FOUR TIMES.
STEPHEN: GUYS WHEN THEY GET TO
THAT OCTOBER STAGE, CARLOS
CORREA AND THE WALK-OFF HIT LAST
NIGHT KNOW THEY'LL DO SOMETHING
WHEN THE OCTOBER LIGHTS ARE ON.
LET'S THROW THIS POLL QUESTION
AT YOU.
YOU KNOW WHEN WE ARE TOGETHER ON
THE MLB GAME OF THE WEEK WE ASK
YOU, WHO DO YOU THINK WILL WIN?
SIMPLY PUT.
THIS IS OUR POLL QUESTION.
SEATTLE OR HOUSTON?
IS IT A SWEEP FOR THE ASTROS, OR
DOES SEATTLE SNAP THIS LITTLE
SKID AND START CHIPPING AWAY AT
THAT HOUSTON LEAD?
ALL RIGHT.
STEPPING ASIDE FOR A LITTLE
BREATHER.
WHEN WE COME BACK, SPECIAL
GUEST, ALEX BREGMAN.
WE TALKED ABOUT HIM.
NOW WE'LL TALK TO HIM, NEXT.
>> IN THE AIR TO LEFT FIELD.
BACK ON TO DIAZ, AND HE MAKES A
NICE DIVING CATCH.
DIAZ TO THE BACKHAND.
NOT A NATURAL OUTFIELDER BUT
MAKING A FINE PLAY IN LEFT FIELD
THERE ON THE SLICING DEEP FLY
BALL OFF THE BAT OF ABRAHAM
TORO.
>> THAT BALL POPPED IN THE AIR.
LONG RUN FOR BREGMAN.
HE'S THE ONLY ONE THAT CAN GET
THERE AND HE DOES IN FOUL
TERRITORY.
ALEX BREGMAN, A NICE PLAY TO END
THE INNING.
STRIKE THREE CALLED.
RUNNER ON THE GO.
THAT'S A STRIKE 'EM OUT, THROW
'EM OUT DOUBLE PLAY.
RUNNER ON THE GO.
THE THROW BY STUBBS.
ON THE MONEY!
>> HOW ABOUT THAT, GARRETT
STUBBS POPPING OUT, THROWING A
SEED.
>> YULI GURRIEL HITS ONE HIGH
AND DEEP DOWN THE LEFT-FIELD
LINE, AND THIS BALL IS GONE!
YULI GURRIEL LA PENA CUTS THE
LEAD IN HALF.
IT'S NOW A ONE-RUN GAME.
NOW, CARLOS CORREA SWINGS AND
SENDS ONE DEEP TO CENTER FIELD.
THAT BALL'S GONE!
BACK-TO-BACK JACKS.
YULI GURRIEL AND CARLOS CORREA.
AND JUST LIKE THAT, THE GAME IS
TIED AT 3-3.
>> TWO PITCHES, TWO BOMBS.
WOW!
STEPHEN: WELCOME BACK TO THE MLB
GAME OF THE WEEK PREGAME SHOW
PRESENTED BY YOUTUBE SHORTS.
ALL RIGHT.
GRAB YOUR CHIPS AND BREGY BOMB
SALSA BECAUSE IT'S BEEN GOOD
SINCE ALEX BREGMAN CAME OFF THE
I.L.
.357.
THE NUMBERS YOU SEE ON THE
SCREEN IS GOOD.
LET'S TALK MORE WITH ALEX
BREGMAN HIMSELF WHO IS JOINING
US NOW AHEAD OF THIS GAME.
ALEX, LOOK, I'M STANDING NEXT TO
MIKE LOWELL, A CHAMPION LIKE
YOU, M.V.P.
YOU GET THE FIRST QUESTION.
MIKE: THANK YOU.
I HAVE A BIAS TOWARDS GOOD THIRD
BASEMEN.
ALEX, YOU'VE BEEN ON FIRE.
HOW IS YOUR HEALTH?
HOW'S THE LEG?
ARE YOU 100%?
TALK TO US.
ALEX: YEAH, FEELING GREAT.
THANK YOU.
OUR STRENGTH COACHES AND
TRAINING STAFF HAVE DONE A
REALLY GOOD JOB OF HELPING ME
OUT WITH THE PREP ROUTINE AND
ALSO JUST KEEPING ME ON THE
FIELD AND HEALTHY FOR THESE --
FOR THIS FINAL STRETCH RUN.
IT'S BEEN FUN TO BE BACK WITH
THE GUYS AND JUST TRYING TO
CONTRIBUTE IN ANY WAY I CAN TO
HELP US WIN A GAME.
STEPHEN: YOU TALK ABOUT
CONTRIBUTING, IT'S ONE THING
JUST BEING BACK.
IT'S ANOTHER THING ANNOUNCING
YOU'RE BACK LIKE YOU DID LAST
NIGHT WITH THAT KIND OF MOMENT.
CAN YOU JUST WALK US THROUGH IT?
BECAUSE C' WALL HAS BEEN NASTY?
ALEX: HE'S ONE OF THE BEST
RELIEVERS IN THE GAME.
I PUT A GOOD SWING ON IT.
HE HAS REALLY GOOD PITCHES.
JUST -- YEAH, JUST TRIED TO
SQUARE SOMETHING UP, USE THE
MIDDLE OF THE FIELD AND
FORTUNATELY CAUGHT IT A LITTLE
BIT OUTFRONT.
MIKE: YOU GUYS WENT INTO
SEATTLE.
THEY TAKE 2-3.
COMING HERE INTO HOUSTON, IS
THIS A BIT OF A STATEMENT
SERIES, THEY'RE CHASING YOU, WE
WANT TO PUT A STAMP ON THIS
SERIES?
ALEX: I THINK THESE GAMES ARE
SUPER IMPORTANT FOR US.
NOT ONLY FOR THE DIVISION BUT
ALSO JUST TO START PLAYING
REALLY, REALLY GOOD BASEBALL
DOWN THE STRETCH.
AND THEY'RE EXTREMELY GOOD BALL
CLUB.
THEY HAVE GREAT PITCHING.
AND TO WIN THOSE TWO GAMES WAS
HUGE.
BUT TODAY'S ANOTHER BIG ONE.
LOOKING FORWARD TO HOPEFULLY
TRYING TO KEEP IT ROLLING.
STEPHEN: ALEX, YOU ARE WELL
AWARE THIS IS A SPECIAL DAY WITH
THE HALL OF FAME CEREMONIES
TAKING PLACE UP IN COOPERSTOWN
AND PEOPLE WATCH YOU, YOUR FANS
NOTICE YOU WEAR NUMBER TWO.
THINK IN PART BECAUSE THAT'S
WHERE YOU WERE SELECTED IN THE
DRAFT.
ALSO BECAUSE OF ONE DEREK JETER.
SO AS YOU SEE THE CAPTAIN GOING
INTO COOPERSTOWN, JUST WONDERING
WHAT'S ON YOUR HEART AND MIND AS
SOMEONE THAT GREW UP LOVING HIM.
ALEX: YEAH, IT'S SUPER COOL.
GROWING UP IN NEW MEXICO, MY MOM
IS FROM NEW YORK, ACTUALLY.
GROWING UP IN NEW MEXICO, SHE
WAS ALWAYS A BIG YANKEES FAN.
I ALWAYS ROOTED FOR JETER AND
LOVED THE WAY HE PLAYED THE
GAME.
JUST HOW HE POSTED EVERY DAY.
PLAYED HARD.
LEFT IT ALL OUT ON THE FIELD.
I'VE BEEN A BIG FAN OF HIS SINCE
I STARTED PLAYING BASEBALL.
IT'S SUPER AWESOME TODAY.
MIKE: YOU AND A LOT OF PEOPLE.
ALEX, LET'S SWITCH GEARS A
LITTLE BIT.
LET'S TALK ABOUT YOUR MANAGER.
THERE WAS A LITTLE BIT OF, I
DON'T KNOW, HESITATION FROM
BASEBALL GUYS HIRING DUSTY BAKER
BECAUSE HOUSTON WAS SUCH AN
ANALYTICS-BASED ORGANIZATION.
IS THERE SOMETHING ABOUT DUSTY
BAKER YOU LEARNED THIS YEAR THAT
MAYBE YOU DIDN'T KNOW BEFORE?
ALEX: OH, HE LOVES THIS TEAM.
HE SHOWS UP EVERY DAY AND WORKS
HIS TAIL OFF TO HELP US WIN
GAMES.
I THINK IT'S A PERFECT
COMBINATION OF THE ANALYTICS AND
ALSO THE BASEBALL.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO HAVE
BASEBALL GUYS.
AND DUSTY HAS BEEN AWESOME.
HAS BEEN HELPING US ALL.
WE LOVE GOING OUT THERE AND
PLAYING HARD FOR HIM.
STEPHEN: TO YOUR POINT ABOUT
LOVING THE GAME AND WORKING, THE
LAST TIME WE HAD AN ASTROS
YOUTUBE GAME I GOT TO TALK TO
KENDALL GRAVEMAN AND HE TOOK US
BACK TO YOUR DAYS IN THE S.E.C.
HE WAS FINISHING UP AT HAIL
STATE AND YOU WERE GETTING READY
IN BATON ROUGE.
YOU MADE AN ERROR TO POTENTIALLY
COST THE TIGERS THE GAME.
WHAT HE REMEMBERS HOURS AFTER
THE GAME WHEN THE LIGHTS WERE
STILL ON AT THE STADIUM AND YOU
WERE TAKING GROUNDERS FROM A
GRAD ASSISTANT.
DO YOU REMEMBER THAT STORY THAT
HE SHARED WITH US?
ALEX: YEAH.
I THINK A GROUND BALL WENT
THROUGH MY LEGS AND MISSISSIPPI
STATE BEAT US.
FACING HIM IN COLLEGE, HE WAS --
HE WAS REALLY, REALLY GOOD.
THEY HAD A REALLY GOOD TEAM,
ACTUALLY.
ADAM FRAZIER WAS ON THAT SQUAD.
I THINK RENFROW WAS ON THAT
SQUAD.
MISSISSIPPI STATE WON THE
COLLEGE WORLD SERIES.
US TIGERS GOT TO BOUNSCE BACK
THIS YEAR AND TAKE OVER THE
S.E.C. AGAIN.
[LAUGHTER]
ALEX: HE'S BEEN TALKING A LOT OF
TRASH.
MIKE: MY WENT TO L.S.U.
HE'S A HUGE FAN.
HE LIVED IN BATON ROUGE FOR 30
YEARS.
YOUR FOOTBALL TEAM TOOK IT ON
THE CHIN.
WILL WE MAKE IT UP THIS
SATURDAY?
AL: IF THEY DON'T --
AL: IF THEY DON'T MAKE IT UP I
DON'T KNOW.
MIKE: THEY DON'T CARE.
THE TIGERS GOT TO TAKE CARE OF
BUSINESS AT HOME.
AL: IT'S A MUST- -- ALEX: IT'S A
MUST-WIN.
I NEED SOME TIGERS IN MY
FOOTBALL TEAM.
I NEED LAMAR CHASE AND ODELL
BECKHAM TO DO WELL.
STEPHEN: DID GARRIT TEXT YOU?
ALEX: NO, HE DIDN'T.
HE WAS UPSET.
IT WAS CLASSY OF HIM.
I GOT PLENTY OF TEXTS THOUGH --
YEAH.
IT WASN'T A GOOD -- IT WASN'T A
GOOD LOSS.
STEPHEN: NO, IT WASN'T.
ALEX, WHEN WE HAVE SOMEBODY ON
THE YOUTUBE PREGAME SHOW, DO YOU
OR DID YOU HAVE A FAVORITE
YOUTUBE VIDEO OF ALL-TIME?
ALEX: UMM -- I'M NOT SURE.
YEAH, I ACTUALLY DO.
MY FAVORITE YOUTUBE -- MY
FAVORITE YOUTUBE VIDEO IS ERIC
THOMAS, THE HIP-HOP PREACHER.
HE HAS A VIDEO OF HOW BAD DO YOU
WANT TO -- HOW BAD DO YOU WANT
IT?
WATCHED IT EVERY DAY WHEN I WAS
IN COLLEGE.
IT'S PRETTY MOTIVATIONAL.
IF YOU HAVEN'T SEEN IT GO CHECK
IT OUT.
HE'S THE MAN.
MIKE: GOT SOMETHING TO DO.
STEPHEN: ANY FINAL THOUGHTS,
MIKEY?
MIKE: ROOTING FOR YOU GUYS.
THIS IS THE MOST BALANCED
OFFENSE IN THE AMERICAN LEAGUE.
DO YOU GUYS FEEL LIKE YOU
PRESENT MAJOR MATCHUP PROBLEMS?
IT'S POWER FROM THE LEFT SIDE,
POWER FROM THE RIGHT SIDE, IS
THAT SOMETHING YOU CAN TAKE INTO
THE POSTSEASON?
ALEX: YEAH, I DEFINITELY BELIEVE
IN THIS LINEUP.
I THINK ONE OF THE BIGGEST
THINGS IS THE POWER BUT ALSO THE
BAT-TO-BALL SKILL AND THE
ABILITY TO WALK AND NOT STRIKE
OUT.
I THINK THAT'S ONE THING THAT
PLAYS REALLY WELL IN THE
POSTSEASON IS MAKING CONTACT.
BECAUSE OF HOW ELITE THE
PITCHERS ARE.
I MEAN, WE GOT A LONG WAY TO GO
TO GET THERE, BUT I'M VERY
CONFIDENT IN THIS LINEUP DOWN
THE STRETCH.
JUST WANT EVERYBODY TO STAY
HEALTHY AND FEEL GOOD GOING IN.
STEPHEN: BREGGY, BEFORE WE SAY
GOODBYE, I WANT TO RELAY A
MESSAGE FROM RO-FLO.
DIE-HARD ASTROS FANS.
HE WANTS SALSA.
LANCE McCULLERS JR. TOLD ME IT'S
ACTUALLY TRULY GREAT.
SO RO-FLO WANTS YOU TO SEND HIM
SOME.
ALEX: YEAH.
A LOT OF PEOPLE -- A LOT OF
PEOPLE THOUGHT IT WASN'T GOING
TO BE GREAT BUT IT'S LEGIT.
I GOT SOME.
I'LL SEND SOME TO THE MLB
NETWORK STUDIO.
FOR EVERYBODY ELSE WHO'S
WATCHING, THEY CAN GO TO
BREGGBOMB.COM AND GET SOME.
STEPHEN: ALEX BREGMAN, BACK FOR
THE HOUSTON ASTROS.
HIT A BIG BOMB AGAINST THE
MARINERS.
LOOKING TO DO MORE ON THE
YOUTUBE GAME OF THE WEEK.
BREGGY, THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
ALEX: ALL RIGHT, GUYS, HAVE A
GOOD ONE.
THANK YOU.
STEPHEN: LET'S SHINE IT ON THE
"CREATOR SPOTLIGHT."
KOFIE YEBOAH.
SECRET BASE IS NOT SO MUCH A
SECRET BASE.
WILDLY POPULAR.
KOFIE HAD BEEN FLOATING IN
INTERNET ORBITS FOR A LONG, LONG
TIME.
I NEVER GOT A CHANCE TO TALK TO
HIM.
LET'S CHANGE THAT RIGHT NOW.
KOFIE, THANK YOU FOR DOING THIS.
THOSE WHO DON'T KNOW ABOUT
SECRET BASE, TELL US ABOUT YOUR
CHANNEL AND WHAT YOU'RE WORKING
ON.
KOFIE: FOR US, SECRET BASE IS A
CHANNEL OF SPORTS STORYTELLING.
WE DON'T REALLY DEAL WITH THE
DAY-TO-DAY LIKE SPORTS TALK KIND
OF THINGS.
WE LIKE TO TELL THE STORIES OF
OLD THROUGH OUR VIDEO SERIES.
WE HAVE BEEF HISTORY WHERE WE
TALK ABOUT FAMOUS ARGUING.
BOBBY BONILLA VS. THE METS.
WE HAVE HISTORIC SPORTS MOMENTS
AND TALK ABOUT ALL THE THINGS
THAT LED UP TO SAID MOMENT.
WE ALSO HAVE OTHER SERIES CALLED
YORKTOWN.
WE ROTATE THOSE THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR.
SO THAT'S WHAT WE DO AT SECRET
BASE.
I LOVE WORKING THERE.
IT'S JUST GREAT.
STEPHEN: WILDLY CREATIVE.
THAT'S AS SIMPLE AS I CAN PUT
IT.
IF YOU HAVEN'T CHECKED OUT THE
CHANNEL, PLEASE DO SO NOW.
KOFIE, YOU TALK ABOUT THE BEEF
HISTORY.
BOBBY BONILLA AND THE METS.
HOW ABOUT METS AND METS FANS,
YOU BEING ONE OF THEM?
[LAUGHTER]
ALL IN ALL THAT BEING SAID,
THEY'RE STILL HANGING AROUND FOR
A POSTSEASON SPOT.
DO YOU HAVE BELIEF OR ARE YOU
DEAD INSIDE?
KOFIE: I'VE BEEN DEAD INSIDE FOR
YEARS.
[LAUGHTER]
IT'S BEEN YEARS AND YEARS, YOU
KNOW, WHERE EVEN THOUGH NO
MATTER HOW -- I ROOT FOR THESE
TEAMS WHERE EVEN THOUGH ALL THIS
HOPE IS ETERNAL, IT'S LIKE IN
THE BACK OF THE MIND, IS THIS
ANOTHER -- GOING TO BE ANOTHER
LETDOWN?
WILL THIS BE ANOTHER
DISAPPOINTING SEASON?
BECAUSE THE THING IS IS WHEN YOU
ROOT FOR A TEAM LIKE THIS,
YOU'VE SEEN IT ALL.
RIGHT?
YOU'VE SEEN ALL THE HOPE.
NOW YOU'RE LIKE, I ROOT FOR THIS
TEAM, HOWEVER, AT THE SAME TIME
I AM NOT GOING TO PUT ALL OF MY
CHIPS IN, YOU KNOW, ALL THIS
STUFF.
IT IS WHAT IT IS.
LIKE, WE KNOW WE WERE IN FIRST
PLACE IN THE EAST FOR A LITTLE
BIT.
THEN, WE HAD THAT SLIDE.
I WAS LIKE, THERE IT GOES.
NOW THEY WON ON MY BIRTHDAY
WHICH WAS YESTERDAY WHICH IS
GOOD.
I WAS LIKE, OK.
WE'RE CLOSE.
THAT'S THE THING.
WE'RE NEVER LIKE -- IT'S LIKE
WE'RE TOO CLOSE, RIGHT?
IT'S, LIKE, CLOSE.
IT'S LIKE PUSHING THE BALL --
ROLLING THE ROCK UP THE HILL AND
THE ROCK IS LIKE MAGICALLY FALLS
DOWN EVERY YEAR.
EVERY SINGLE YEAR.
STEPHEN: OUR PRODUCER RIGHT NOW
IS A DIE-HARD MET FAN.
THIS IS SO TRUE.
ING O'.
YOU ARE -- OK.
YOU'RE IN NEW YORK.
THE METS ARE IN A DIFFERENT
BOROUGH.
IN THE OTHER ONE THE YANKEES AND
THEY'RE CELEBRATING DEREK JETER,
THEIR CAPTAIN, GOING INTO
COOPERSTOWN TODAY.
I KNOW.
OK.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE VIDEO.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE VIDEO YOU
JUST DID AT SECRET BASE.
YOU DID A DEEP REWIND ON THE
FAMOUS FLIP PLATE.
WE JUST HAD BUCK SHOW WALTER --
SHOWALTER WALK BY.
HE USED TO SAY JETER WAS LATE ON
THAT PLAY.
WHAT WAS YOUR TAKE ON REWINDING
THAT BACK?
KOFIE: I THINK THE THING ABOUT
THAT PLAY THAT'S MOST
INTERESTING IS THERE'S ALWAYS
THIS KIND OF DEBATE ON WAS IT
NECESSARY?
WAS IT EFFECTIVE?
RIGHT?
SO THERE'S ALWAYS -- YOU CAN
ALWAYS DO THIS ESTIMATION OF,
OK, IF JETER DOESN'T CUT THAT
BALL OFF, IS GIAMBI OUT?
OR IS GIAMBI ACTUALLY OUT?
THERE'S PEOPLE THAT ARGUE THAT.
THAT'S THE THING.
IT WAS AN IMPORTANT PLAY.
AND THE THING IS, IF JETER CUTS
THAT BALL OFF AND THEN GIAMBI IS
SAFE, I FEEL WE'D BE TALKING
ABOUT, DID JETER EVEN HAVE TO
CUT THAT BALL OFF?
IT'S A VERY INTERESTING PLAY,
LIKE, THROUGHOUT HISTORY THAT,
LIKE, YOU KNOW, IT KIND OF
CEMENTED HIS LEGACY OF, LIKE,
HE'S GOING TO BE ONE OF THOSE
ALL-TIME SPECIAL PLAYERS.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN SOMEONE CUT
THE BALL OFF THAT CLOSE TO THE
CATCHER.
IT'S LIKE THAT'S THE RIGHT PLAY
TO DO.
YOU KNOW.
STEPHEN: LAST ONE FROM ME.
IS THERE ANYTHING YOU'VE SEEN IN
BASEBALL THIS YEAR THAT YOU
THINK ONE DAY YOU WOULD WANT TO
DO A DEEP REWIND, A DEEP DIVE,
OR DO A STORYTELLING PIECE ON
FOR SECRET BASE, WHETHER IT'S A
PLAYER OR TEAM OR A MOMENT?
KOFIE: I HAVE NOT -- I AM NOT
SURE YET.
SINCE I DON'T WORK ON THE
REWINDERS OR BEEF HISTORY OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT, I THINK IT
WILL BE INTERESTING -- I'LL SAY
THIS.
WE ARE WORKING ON A FUMBLE
DIMENSION THAT'S REVOLVING
AROUND A CERTAIN PLAYER IN THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE WEST.
I WON'T TELL YOU WHO IT IS.
STEPHEN: IS IT --
KOFIE: PEOPLE CAN FIGURE IT OUT.
STEPHEN: DOES IT RHYME WITH
BROHEI?
THAT'S WHY THEY CALL IT SECRET
BASE.
HE'S KEEPING IT A SECRET.
AGAIN, KOFIE, HUGE FAN OF YOUR
WORK.
HAVE BEEN FOR A LONG TIME.
IT'S AMAZING TO WATCH YOU BLOW
UP THE WAY YOU HAVE.
AGAIN, FOR THOSE WHO HAVEN'T
SEEN KOFIE, CHECK HIM OUT.
AWESOME IT LINK UP.
HOPEFULLY WE CAN DO IT SOON.
KOFIE: ANYTIME.
STEPHEN: TYLER ANDERSON, ONE OF
THE DEADLINE PICKUPS
DIPOTO.
THEY NEED HIM TO BE GOOD TODAY.
>> HIT HARD THE OTHER WAY.
GOT A CHANCE.
FAIR BALL.
YES, INDEED.
KYLE SEAGER SCORES AND THE
MARINERS HAVE A 6-5 LEAD.
>> A BIG HIT.
ON THE GROUND, BASE HIT.
RIGHT FIELD CORNER, J.P.
KYLE SEAGER, CHA-CHING.
5-3, SEATTLE.
>> A 1-0 MARINERS BALLGAME.
STRIKE THREE CALLED!
THAT'S THE BALLGAME!
THE MARINERS PITCH BACK-TO-BACK
SHUTOUTS!
>> HIGH DRIVE RIGHT FIELD.
GOT BIG-TIME CARRIES.
SLICE THAT, BABY!
THREE-RUN HOMER, KYLE SEAGER!
8-5 LEAD FOR THE MARINERS.
>> HE DRILLS THIS, DRILLED AND
THIS IS GONE!
GRAND SLAM!
>> WHAT AN AT-BAT.
>> WONDER WHAT THE VIBE OF THE
CLUBHOUSE WILL BE TONIGHT.
4-0, MARINERS.
STEPHEN: IT'S THE MLB GAME OF
THE WEEK PREGAME SHOW PRESENTED
BY YOUTUBE SHORTS.
IT'S TIME NOW FOR "PICKS TO
CLICK" PRESENTED BY BET M.G.M.
MIKE LOWELL, STEPHEN NELSON
INSIDE STUDIO 42.
WE'RE WATCHING A CLASH OF THE
WEEK.
WHO IS YOUR PICK TO RUN THE
TABLE IN THE AMERICAN LEAGUE?
MIKE: WOW!
I'M GOING TO SOUND LIKE A
FRONTRUNNER, BUT THE RAYS ARE SO
DEEP.
STEPHEN: THERE'S NOTHING WRONG
WITH BEING CHALKY IF IT'S RIGHT.
MIKE: THEY HIT.
THEY CAN PITCH.
THEY BEAT UP ON GOOD TEAMS.
THEY DESTROY BAD TEAMS.
I GOT THE RAYS.
STEPHEN: AND THEY NEVER SAY DIE.
I THINK THEY HAVE 43COMBACK
WINS -- 43 COMEBACK WINS.
YOU CAN'T KILL TAMPA BAY.
THEY ARE NO LONGER THIS UPSTART.
THIS IS A JUGGERNAUT IN THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE.
SO AS WE GO FROM MIKEY'S PICK TO
CLICK, WE WANT TO SHOW YOU THE
POLL RESULTS.
WHO YOU THOUGHT WOULD WIN THE
GAME OF THE WEEK.
65% GOING WITH HOUSTON.
MIKE: I'M WITH THAT.
HOME TEAM.
COMING OFF A WIN.
NO BE PRO.
I'M WITH THEM.
STEPHEN: TODAY -- IT'S GOT THAT
FEELING TODAY -- THIS WEEK,
ANYWAY, HOUSTON WILL MAKE A
STATEMENT.
MIKE: BIG GAME FOR THE MARINERS.
STEPHEN: MASSIVE.
MIKE: THEY HAVE TO BOUNCE BACK.
THEIR LOSSES ARE GUTWRENCHING
AND SOME THAT WERE NEVER IN IT.
LAST NIGHT WAS GUTWRENCHING.
STEPHEN: FLUSH HIT.
FLUSH HIT.
DON'T LET IT TURN INTO A BAD --
ONE LOSS TURN INTO TWO.
ALL RHT.
WE'RE  HERE.
SCOTT,IS,E LOSS TURN INTO AND BE
GAME OF THE WEEK LIVE ON
YOUTUBE.
ENJOY.
[CAPTIONS MADE POSSIBLE BY MLB
NETWORK]
[CAPTIONING PERFORMED BY THE
NATIONAL CAPTIONING INSTITUTE,
WHICH IS RESPONSIBLE FOR ITS
CAPTION CONTENT AND ACCURACY.
VISIT NCICAP.ORG]
>> WHAT A PLAY.
OH, MY!
SCOTT: THEY HAVE HARDBALLING
DOWNTOWN HOUSTON AND THE HOME
TEAM HAS BEEN REWARDING THEIR
FANS FOR YEARS WITH BIG SUCCESS
INSIDE THIS BALLPARK.
THIS YEAR MORE OF THE SAME.
IT'S NOT JUST THE PLAYOFF
APPEARANCES BUT EVEN A NIGHT
LIKE LAST NIGHT, A COMEBACK
WALK-OFF AGAINST A RELENTLESS
DIVISION FOE.
THIS IS THE MLB GAME OF THE WEEK
LIVE ON YOUTUBE PRESENTED BY
YOUTUBE SHORTS.
THE SEATTLE MARINERS ARE IN TOWN
TO CLASH ARE THE HOUSTON ASTROS
FOR SOME WEDNESDAY BASEBALL AT
MINUTE MAID PARK, AND THE STROS
HAVE BUILT A 6 1/2-GAME CUSHION
IN THE A.L. WEST THANKS TO WINS
IN THE FIRST TWO GAMES OF THIS
SET.
THEY'LL CLOSE THE BOOKS ON THEIR
SEASON TODAY.
THE WILD CARD IS WHERE THE DRAMA
IS AT IN THE A.L. POSTSEASON
PICTURE.
THE M'S ARE INVOLVED.
A FEW GAMES TO MAKE UP.
A FEW WEEKS TO GO.
OH, THIS IS GOING TO BE REAL
GOOD.
SCOTT BRAUN ALONG WITH CHRIS
YOUNG.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
ALSO, YOU LIKED PLAYING IN THIS
BALLPARK A LITTLE BIT.
CHRIS: A LITTLE BIT.
I THINK IF YOU PULL UP MY
NUMBERS I HAD GOOD TIMES OUT
HERE.
SCOTT: OK.
I THINK WE'LL PULL HIS NUMBERS
UP AT SOME POINT.
LET'S START WITH THE SEATTLE
MARINERS.
I WILL SAY THEIR GENERAL
MANAGER, JERRY DIPOTO, TALKED
ABOUT THIS TEAM HAVING A SHORT
MEMORY.
WELL, KEEP IT REALLY SHORT.
WE CAN GO A LONG WAY WHEN
TALKING ABOUT A PLAYOFF DROUGHT
THAT'S LONGER THAN ANY IN
PROFESSIONAL SPORTS AT THE
MOMENT.
THIS TEAM WAS AWESOME IN 2001.
CHRIS: YEAH.
WE'D HAVE TO GO BACK ALL THE WAY
TO 2001.
THIS IS A TEAM YOU SEE RANDY
JOHNSON, GRIFFEY, A-ROD.
NO.
NONE OF THOSE PEOPLE WERE THERE.
THEY HAD ICHIRO, BOONE, CAMERON.
THIS IS A TEAM THAT HAD GREAT
DEFENSE, A LIGHTS OUT BULLPEN.
SCOTT: AND THE RAIN CAME FOR A
LONG, LONG TIME, C.Y.
THIS TEAM STILL HAS A DROUGHT
THAT THEY'RE HOPING TO WIPE AWAY
THIS SEASON.
IT'S POSSIBLE.
EVENTUALLY WHEN THE RAIN DOES
CLEAR, IT'S GOING TO BE
GLORIOUS.
CHRIS: ALTHOUGH IT'S NOT THE
2001 TEAM.
THIS TEAM IS BUILT COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT.
THEY ARE BUNCHED WITH A GROUP OF
YOUNG PLAYERS.
SCOTTE SERVAIS HAS ALLOWED THEM
TO COME OUT, COMPETE, PLAY GREAT
DEFENSE AND FIND WAYS TO WIN
CLOSE GAMES.
SCOTT: THERE'S TWO MOTTOS.
ONE ON THE SCREEN, WHY NOT US,
AND THE OTHER, IT'S BEEN A
MINUTE.
BUT THEY'RE WORKING ON IT, OK.
LONGEST ACTIVE PLAYOFF DROUGHTS
ALONG THE FOUR MAJOR NORTH
AMERICAN PRO SPORTS.
WELL, THE MARINERS AT THE MOMENT
TAKE THE CAKE AND ALL THE RAIN.
CHRIS: I GUESS THEY'RE DUE,
RIGHT?
SCOTT: THAT'S A GOOD WAY TO PUT
IT, OK.
IT'S THE LAW OF AVERAGES.
THE MARINERS ARE DUE, AND THEY
DO HAVE A YOUNG EXCITING BALL
CLUB.
YES, IT'S BEEN A MINUTE.
WHILE THE HOUSTON ASTROS HAVE
SEEN A TON OF SUCCESS IN THEIR
ORGANIZATION.
EVEN LAST YEAR, THEY HAD
SUCCESS, BUT IT WAS A WEIRD
2020, NOT JUST FOR THEM BUT FOR
EVERYBODY.
CHRIS: IT WAS A WEIRD 2020 FOR
MULTIPLE REASONS.
NUMBER ONE, WE HAVE TO ADMIT,
COMING OFF THE CHEATING SCANDAL.
THE PRESSURE WAS ON THE ASTROS.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE VERLANDER.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE ALVERY HE IS.
-- ALVAREZ.
CORREA HAD A DOWN YEAR COMING
OFF 2019.
ALTUVE WAS IN THE SAME BOAT.
PEOPLE COMING OUT QUESTIONING
WHAT TEAM IS THIS TEAM.
WHAT ARE THE ASTROS MADE OF?
2021, THEY COME BACK STRONG AND
THEY'RE DOING WHAT THEY'VE
ALWAYS DONE.
SCOTT: YEAH.
AND THAT IS BREAKING, GOOD
PITCHING, ELITE DEFENSE.
THEY BARELY HAVE ANY WEAKNESSES.
CHRIS: I CAN'T SEEM TO FIND TOO
MANY OF THEM.
I MEAN, WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS
OFFENSE, IT'S ARGUABLY THE BEST
OFFENSE IN THE GAME.
THEY'RE STRONG FROM TOP TO
BOTTOM.
YOU HAVE KYLE TUCKER IN THE
SEVEN HOLE, SIX HOLE TONIGHT.
BREGMAN IS OFF THE D.L.
THEY'RE PLAYING GREAT DEFENSE.
THEY'RE PITCHING WELL.
THEY'RE THE TEAM TO BEAT.
SCOTT: YOU CAN SEE THE FEWEST
STRIKEOUTS.
THAT'S ON THE HITTING SIDE.
THEN, ON THE PITCHING SIDE,
DESPITE WHAT WE SHOWED YOU AT
THE NOT OK CORRAL WITH NO
VERLANDER AND, OF COURSE, THEY
LOST COLE A COUPLE YEARS AGO.
THEY'RE TOP FIVE IN STARTING
PITCHING IN E.R.A.
CHRIS: McCULLERS, AR URQUIDY
GOING TONIGHT.
THEY'RE STRONG TOP TO.
BOO.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEIR TEAM
WILL LOOK LIKE IN THE PLAYOFFS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE SO MANY STRONG
SUITS AT THE TOP OF THE LINEUP.
DUSTY WILL HAVE DECISIONS TO
MAKE.
S
SCOTT: YOU'RE RIGHT.
THAT'S WHAT THIS TIME PERIOD IS
ABOUT.
JOSE URQUIDY, WHO IS PITCHING
TODAY, WILL HE BE GOOD ENOUGH TO
CRACK THE PLAYOFF ROTATION?
WE'LL SEE.
CARLOS CORREA, THE SPOTLIGHT HAS
BEEN ON HIM.
LET'S KICK IT TO THE THIRD
MEMBER OF THE TEAM, BRETT DOLAN
HAS MORE.
BRETT: THANKS, SCOTT.
CARLOS CORREA WAS INDEED THE
HERO LAST NIGHT.
A WALK-OFF DOUBLE IN EXTRA
INNINGS AS THE HOUSTON ASTROS
TOOK DOWN THE SEATTLE MARINERS.
NOW, CARLOS HAS BEEN A KEY PART
OF THIS FRANCHISE OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS, AND FOR THE FANS,
THEY'RE CURIOUS WHAT HIS FUTURE
LOOKS LIKE HERE IN H-TOWN.
WE WERE HERE TWO WEEKS AGO WHEN
C
CARLOS'S QUOTE CAME OUT IN THE
ATHLETIC.
SPEAKING IN PAST TENSE TRYING TO
WIN ANOTHER CHAMPIONSHIP TO LEAD
THIS ORGANIZATION WITH TWO OF
THEM.
NOW, WITH McTAGGERT HE CLEARED
THINGS UP.
OBVIOUSLY I DO NOT HAVE A
CONTRACT FOR NEXT YEAR.
WHO KNOWS?
WOULD BE HAPPY TO STAY HERE.
WHEN FREE AGENCY IS LOOMING, YOU
WONDER WHAT IT WILL DO TO
SOMEBODY MENTALLY.
HE GOT OFF TO A GOOD START AS
YOU SEE IN APRIL AND JUNE.
.296.
15 HOME RUNS.
ALMOST 50 R.B.I.'S.
SINCE THEN, 51 GAMES HE'S AT
.251 WITH JUST SEVEN HOME RUNS.
DUSTY BAKER HAS AN EXPLANATION.
CARLOS WAS SICK AROUND THE
ALL-STAR BREAK.
HE SAID HE WAS VERY WEAK.
IT WASN'T COVID.
DIDN'T FEEL LIKE HE WAS QUITE
THE SAME HITTER.
BUT THINGS HAVE CHANGED.
NOW, I DID ASK DUSTY WHETHER OR
NOT HE TAKES THE TEMPERATURE OF
CARLOS JUST TO SEE WHERE HE IS
AND HE SAYS YES.
NOT PHYSICALLY BUT MENTALLY.
CARLOS WANTS TO PLAY A LOT OF
GAMES, MAXIMIZE HIS HEALTH.
LAST NIGHT IS THE KEY GOING
FORWARD.
MORE OF THE BIG-TIME HITS TO WIN
FOR THIS TEAM IN SEPTEMBER AND
BEYOND.
MINUTE MAID PARK IS THE SITE OF
OUR YOUTUBE GAME OF THE WEEK.
OUR LINEUP AND FIRST PITCH
COMING UP.
THE MARINERS AND ASTROS ON
YOUTUBE!
>> FIRST PITCH SWINGING.
J.P. CRAWFORD SINGLES INTO
RIGHT.
>> AND THERE'S A BASE HIT.
>> IT SLHOOTS TO THE RIGHT SIDE.
J.P. CRAWFORD.
AWAY FROM THE SHIFT.
CRAWFORD IS 2-2.
ON THE GROUND, CRAWFORD POPS UP.
COUPLE OF STEPS.
PLAY IN TIME.
KEEPS A RUN OFF THE BOARD AND
ENDS THE TOP OF THE THIRD.
WHAT A PLAY BY J.P. CRAWFORD.
BACK UP THE MIDDLE.
CRAWFORD IS ON THE BOARD FOR THE
FIRST TIME.
THE MARINERS HAVE A GO-AHEAD RUN
RON BASE.
>> J.P. HITTING THE BALL PRETTY
WELL AND GETTING GOOD RESULTS
LATELY.
HITTING STRAIGHT.
IT CONTINUES RIGHT HERE ON THE
THIRD PITCH OF THE BALLGAME.
>> THE OTHER WAY AND J.P.
CONTINUES TO THRIVE DOING THAT.
THEY CAN'T BELIEVE IT.
J.P. CRAWFORD CRUISING INTO
SECOND.
2-2.
>> GOES THE OTHER WAY.
BASE HIT.
KELENIC SCORES.
J.P. CRAWFORD, WHAT A DAY!
SCOTT: THIS IS THE MLB GAME OF
THE WEEK LIVE ON YOUTUBE
PRESENTED BY YOUTUBE SHORTS.
WATCH AND CREATE VIDEOS ON
YOUTUBE.
TRY SHORTS IN THE YOUTUBE APP,
ON YOUR PHONE.
SCOTT BRAUN WITH CHRIS YOUNG AND
BRETT DOLAN.
AND WE DO A LOT HERE ON YOUTUBE
ON A WEEKLY BASIS.
WE'RE THRILLED TO HAVE YOU JOIN
US HERE AND BE PART OF THE
PARTY.
AND ALSO OUR LATEST FEATURE
ALLOWS YOU TO CONTROL THE AUDIO.
YOU CAN PERSONALIZE YOUR
LISTENING EXPERIENCE.
IT'S THE MULTITRACK AUDIO.
HANG OUT WITH US.
YOU CAN CLICK WITH THE HOME OR
RADIO CALL.
MIX IT UP.
YOU DO YOU ON THE SPEAKERS.
TELL YOUR FRIENDS.
YOUTUBE.COM/MLB.
IT'S FREE FOR EVERYONE TO WATCH
TODAY ON MLB'S YOUTUBE CHANNEL.
WE HAVE MICED UP PLAYERS,
INTERVIEWS.
THE WHOLE DEAL.
LET'S GET THIS THING ROLLING
WITH JOSE URQUIDY MATCHING UP
WITH TYLER ANDERSON, YOUR
STARTING PITCHERS.
BOTH OF THEM HAVE QUITE A FEW
SIMILARITIES, C.Y.
CHRIS: A LOT OF SIMILARITIES.
WE WILL START OFF WITH URQUIDY.
HE'S A FOUR-SEAM, SLIDER,
CHANGEUP, CURVE GUY.
HE'S USING HIS CHANGE ABOUT 50%
OF THE GUY.
HE'S TRYING TO GET GUYS TO CHASE
AFTER HE GETS THAT ESTABLISHED.
HE'S IN THE TOP FIVE IN LOWEST
AVERAGES WITH THAT CHANGEUP.
SO I EXPECT TO SEE THAT CHANGEUP
QUITE A BIT TODAY.
SCOTT: THE MARINERS NEED TO TAKE
THIS ONE.
LET'S GO OVER TO THE "KEYS TO
THE GAME" ON THE MARINERS SIDE
ON THE VISITING CLUB.
CHRIS: FOR THE MARINERS, THEY
HAVE TO STAY WITHIN STRIKING
RANGE.
THEY HAVE 29 WINS.
IF THEY CAN STAY CLOSE
THROUGHOUT THE GAME, THEY'LL BE
IN GOOD POSITION TO GET TO THAT
BULLPEN.
ANDERSON, HE HAS TO BRING OUT
THE PAINT BURST TODAY.
STAY AWAY FROM THE MIDDLE OF THE
PLATE.
90 MILES AN HOUR WITH HIS
FASTBALL.
HE NEEDS TO STAY FROM THE MIDDLE
OF THE PLATE.
SEAGER, I SEE HIM BEING CLUTCH
IN A BIG SITUATION TODAY.
URQUIDY, A REVERSE SWITCH GUY TO
WHERE LEFTIES DON'T HIT WELL.
SEAGER IS GO AS THEY GO.
SCOTT: LET'S RUN THROUGH THE
YOUTUBE SHORTS LINEUP CARD FOR
THE VISITING SEATTLE MARINERS.
THEY CHECK IN WITH 75-64 ON THE
SEASON.
J.P. CRAWFORD, HANIGER, SEAGER.
HAVING A MONSTER SECOND HALF.
FRANCE CAN DO IT ALL AT THE
PLATE.
TORO WAS THE PICKUP.
TORRENS IS THE ROOKIE.
JOSE MARMOLEJOS IN THE NINE
SPOT.
YOU ARE KEYEDY LOOKS AROUND --
URQUIDY LOOKS AROUND.
THIS IS START NUMBER TWO.
WE ARE UNDER WAY TO A GLOBAL
AUDIENCE ON YOUTUBE TODAY.
HERE'S CRAWFORD.
EXCELLENT ON-BASE PERCENTAGE
DURING AN EIGHT-GAME ON-BASE
STREAK.
HE FOULS BACK 1-0.
SO JOSE URQUIDY CHECKS IN WITH A
3.42 E.R.A. ON THE SEASON, AND
HE'D BEEN OUT SINCE JUNE 29 WITH
RIGHT SHOULDER DISCOMFORT.
LEFT THE GAME AGAINST BALTIMORE
AFTER AN INNING AND A THIRD.
THAT WAS THE SECOND TIME HE LEFT
AN OUTING WITH THAT ISSUE.
CRAWFORD DRIVES ONE TO RIGHT
FIELD.
THERE'S TUCKER.
FLOATING BACK.
HE MAKES THE CATCH.
SO JOSE URQUIDY POPPED BACK UP
AGAINST SAN DIEGO.
TWO RUNS.
7 1/3.
TWO TIMES THROUGH THE ORDER.
THIS IS THE ARSENAL HE'S WORKING
WITH.
A LOT OF FOUR-SEAM FASTBALL,
SLIDER, CHANGEUP.
HE'S A REVERSE SPLIT GUY.
GOOGLE CLOUD STATCAST.
CHRIS: THE CHANGEUP, HOPEFULLY
WE'LL SEE MORE OF THAT TODAY,
ESPECIALLY WITH THE LEFTIES IN
THE LINEUP.
THEY STRUGGLED GREATLY AGAINST
HIS CHANGEUP.
I SEE HIM PULLING IT OUT IN
PRESSURE SITUATIONS TO WHERE HE
NEEDS A BIG OUT.
SCOTT: URQUIDY HAS HAD BIG-TIME
RESULTS WITH HIS CHANGEUP.
CHRIS: I SEE HIM BEING
AGGRESSIVE IN THE ZONE LATELY.
WE TALKED TO DUSTY BAKER BEFORE
THE GAME TODAY.
HE'S COMING OFF THE I.L.
HAD A GREAT START HIS FIRST
START.
HE'S TRYING TO ESTABLISH EARLY
TO STAY IN THIS GAME.
SCOTT: I LIKE WHAT HIS MANAGER,
DUSTY BAKER, TOLD US THIS
MORNING, AS WE TAKE A LOOK AT
THE ODDS COURTESY OF BET M.G.M.
THE MARINERS GOING UP AND DOWN
ON 3 1/2 RUNS TODAY, WHAT DO YOU
THINK?
CHRIS: I HAVE BOTH TEAMS
SWINGING THE BAT WELL TODAY.
I'M GOING TO GO OVER.
SCOTT: OVER.
OK.
CUT AND A MISS THERE FROM
HANIGER.
THE LINE FROM DUSTY THIS MORNING
ON HIS STARTER.
HE SAID, HE CAN THROW STRIKES IN
HIS SLEEP.
IF ANYTHING, MAYBE THROW A FEW
LESS STRIKES, WHICH YOU NEVER
HEAR ABOUT PITCHERS.
CHRIS: AND YOU ALWAYS HAVE GUYS
LIKE THAT TO WHERE YOU KNOW IF
YOU GET IN A SITUATION TO WHERE
IF YOU HAVE THREE BALLS, IF
YOU'RE HITTING IN THAT
SITUATION, YOU ASSUME HE WILL
THROW YOU A STRIKE WHICH
SOMETIMES WORKS IN YOUR FAVOR
AND MAKES GUYS EXPAND THEIR ZONE
A LITTLE BIT.
SCOTT: THERE'S DUSTY IN HIS 24th
BIG LEAGUE SEASON MANAGING.
HE'S BEEN IN THE GAME MANY
YEARS.
72 YEARS AULD.
OFF THE FIRST BASE BAG.
IT'S A -- 72 YEARS OLD.
MARWIN GONZALEZ HANDLING THE HOT
CORNER TODAY.
NOT MUCH YOU CAN DO ABOUT THAT
ONE.
CHRIS: I THINK THE BAG MAY HAVE
PLAYED GOOD DEFENSE RIGHT THERE.
MAY HAVE SAVED A DOUBLE.
SCOTT: THAT'S TRUE.
FIRST START FOR MARWIN GONZALEZ
SINCE SIGNING A MINOR LEAGUE
CONTRACT ON AUGUST 27.
THERE HE IS.
BELOVED BY BOTH THE FAN BASE AND
BY HIS TEAMMATES.
CHRIS: BREGMAN GETTING A DAY OFF
AFTER THE BIG HOMER LAST NIGHT.
SCOTT: LAST NIGHT WAS EPIC FOR
THE ASTROS.
ALEX BREGMAN HITS A GAME-TYING
TWO-RUN HOME RUN IN THE NINTH
INNING OFF PAUL WHO HAD BEEN
MONEY THIS SEASON.
OH, HE'S ENJOYING THE DAY OFF.
CHRIS: PUT THE FEET UP.
GET COMFORTABLE.
YOU'LL BE THERE UNTIL ABOUT THE
SIXTH OR SEVENTH AND YOU BETTER
START GETTING LOOSE.
SCOTT: THERE WAS CARLOS CORREA
WITH THE WALK-OFF DOUBLE IN
EXTRAS.
IN A ONE LOOKS LIKE OFF THE
MOUND THIS TIME.
AND IT'S GOING TO TURN INTO
ANOTHER INFIELD KNOCK.
MARWIN GONZALEZ HAS TO EAT UP
THE BASEBALL, AND KYLE SEAGER IS
ABOARD.
HAVE YOU EVER SEEN THAT BEFORE,
ONE OFF THE BASE AND THEN RUN
OFF THE RUBBER?
CHRIS: NOT ON BACK-TO-BACK
PLAYS.
THERE'S A GOOD CHANCE THAT'S A
DOUBLE PLAY BALL.
YOU SEE CORREA RIGHT THERE
BEHIND THE BASE RIGHT THERE,
BEHIND THE MOUND.
SCOTT: MIGHT HAVE BEEN OFF HIS
FOOT.
CHRIS: HE FEELS THAT BALL, STEPS
ON SECOND, THROWS TO FIRST.
INNING OVER.
JUST LIKE THAT.
SCOTT: YOU HEARD THE LITTLE
CLICK SOUND.
IF IT WAS OFF HIS FOOT, DO YOU
MAKE SURE HE'S OK?
YOU ARE KEYEDY IS NOT
FILCHING -- URQUIDY IS NOT
FLINCHING.
CHRIS: KEEP THE GAME ROLLING.
SCOTT: HE'S A GUY THAT LIKES TO
PICK UP THE PACE.
URQUIDY IS READY TO GO WHEN HE
GETS THE FASTBALL.
FRANCE IS HITTING .340 SINCE
AUGUST 10.
THAT'S SECOND BEST IN THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE TO THE MAGICAL
JUAN DE-FRANCO, THE SUPER -- DE
FRANCO, THE SUPER GUY ON THE
TAMPA BAY RAYS.
CHRIS: HE HITS.
SCOTT: OPPOSITE FIELD KNOCK.
HE USES THE ENTIRE FIELD.
NOW THE MARINERS HAVE LOADED UP
THE BASES HERE IN THE FIRST WITH
JUST ONE OUT.
CHRIS: THAT'S A GREAT PIECE OF
HITTING RIGHT NOW.
HE'S A SAN DIEGO STATE GUY.
TAUGHT BY THE LATE GREAT TONY
GWYNN.
HE'S ABLE TO HIT THE BALL ALL
OVER THE FIELD.
CONSISTENTLY PUTS TOGETHER BATS.
STAYS IN THE STRIKE ZONE.
TO SEE A BIG GUY DO THAT, HIT IT
ALL OVER THE FIELD, GO THE OTHER
WAY, IT'S NICE TO SEE.
THAT'S WHY HE'S IN THAT FOUR
HOLE.
SCOTT: I DON'T THINK THERE'S
MANY PLAYERS ASTROS FANS WOULD
SAY, OH, NOT THIS GUY, BUT
ABRAHAM TORO FITS THE MOLD AS HE
DIGS IN WITH THE BASES LOADED.
BIGGEST HIT, I WOULD SAY, OF HIS
LIFE AT THIS POINT WAS A GRAND
SLAM AGAINST THIS ASTROS TEAM IN
A WIN ABOUT A WEEK AND CHANGE
AGO.
HE'S BEEN A DIFFERENT BALLPLAYER
SINCE PUTTING ON THIS UNIFORM.
CHRIS: IT'S NICE.
I KNOW HE STRUGGLED A LITTLE BIT
WHEN HE WAS WITH HOUSTON EARLIER
IN THE YEAR, BUT WHEN YOU GET
TRADED TO ANOTHER TEAM WHO IS IN
PLAYOFF CONTENTION, YOU HAVE THE
PRESSURE ON YOU.
THERE'S A LITTLE BACKLASH FROM
IT.
YOU WANT TO GO OVER THERE AND
MAKE A GOOD IMPRESSION.
SO FOR HIM TO COME OUT AND START
HITTING RIGHT AWAY HAD TO TAKE A
HUGE WEIGHT OFF HIS BACK, ALLOW
HIM TO GO OUT AND HAVE FUN.
HE'S CONTINUED TO PLAY WELL.
IN THIS SITUATION WITH SEATTLE,
I MEAN, I THINK THEY HAVE THE
HIGHEST O.P.S. IN BASEBALL WITH
RUNNERS IN SCORING POSITION.
SCOTT: SO --
CHRIS: SO YOU'RE TRYING TO NOT
LET THIS GAME GET OUT OF HAND
TOO EARLY.
SCOTT: YOU DON'T WANT THIS TO
HAPPEN.
NO DEJA VU SAYS ALL OF HOUSTON
AT THE MOMENT, BECAUSE ON AUGUST
31, IN SEATTLE, ABRAHAM TORO
WITH A GRAND SLAM SMASH.
AND THAT WAS THE DIFFERENCE IN
THE BALLGAME FOR THE MARINERS.
GETS A SWING AND MISS.
A 1-2 COUNT ON TORO.
SO THAT WAS THE BIG TRADE RIGHT
NEAR THE DEADLINE.
TORO HEADING OVER TO SEATTLE
ALONG WITH JOE SMITH, KENDALL
GRAVEMAN WAS THE BIG PICKUP IN
THE BULLPEN FOR THE ASTROS ALONG
WITH RAFAEL MONTERO.
TIMING-WISE, IT WAS COMING OFF A
BIG WIN FOR SEATTLE.
GRAVEMAN WAS A HUGE PART OF THE
BULLPEN.
IT DIDN'T LOOK GREAT
TIMING-WISE, BUT JERRY DIPOTO
EXPLAINED -- AS TORO FOULS THAT
ONE BACK -- THE DEAL HAD TO BE
MADE ON THAT VERY DAY.
HERE'S WHY.
MONTERO WAS THE KEY.
HE WAS DESIGNATED FOR ASSIGNMENT
BY THE ASTROS.
THE MARINERS WANTED HIM.
IF THEY WAITED ANOTHER DAY,
MONTERO WOULD HAVE BEEN
AVAILABLE TO ANYONE ON WAIVERS.
THE DEAL HAD TO BE DONE EVEN
THOUGH THE TIMING WASN'T THE
PRETTIEST.
CHRIS: THERE ARE THINGS THAT
HAPPEN BEHIND THE SCENES THAT US
AS FANS OR US IN THE GAME DON'T
KNOW ABOUT.
SCOTT: TORO RIPS ONE TO RIGHT
FIELD.
PLENTY OF OPEN SPACE.
HE'S IN BUSINESS, AND THE
MARINERS CRACK THE SCOREBOARD
FIRST.
HERE'S HANIGER, AND SEAGER WILL
SCORE AS WELL.
IT'S A TWO-R.B.I. TWO-BAGGER FOR
ABRAHAM TORO.
HE CONTINUES TO PUNISH HIS
FORMER SQUAD.
CHRIS: THAT WILL PUT A SMILE ON
YOUR FACE EARLY IN THE GAME.
CHANGEUP LEFT UP IN THE ZONE?
WE HAVE THE CHANGEUP.
YOU SEE THE THREE FINGERS RIGHT
THERE.
THAT'S HIS GO-TO PITCH RIGHT
RIGHT THERE YOU'RE ASSUMING YOU
WANT TO GET A OUT WITH YOUR BEST
PITCH AGAINST A LEFT-HANDED BAT.
TORO IS ABLE TO STAY THROUGH
THAT BALL, GET IT UP JUST HIGH
ENOUGH AND PUT THE BARREL ON IT
AND HIT IT TO THE RIGHT-FIELD
LINE.
SCOTT: ALTUVE IS LIKE, DUDE,
TAKE IT EASY ON US.
11 GAMES AGAINST HOUSTON FOR
TORO.
SIX EXTRA-BASE HITS.
14 R.B.I.'S.
HE'S BEEN A LIGHTNING ROD IN THE
LINEUP FOR THE MARINERS.
THIS IS A PLAYER THAT WAS PICKED
UP IN THE TRADE, TOO.
A DIFFERENT ONE.
IT'S WORKING OUT FOR THEM.
LUIS TORRENS IN HIS LAST 20
GAMES HITTING CLOSE TO .300.
CHRIS: THIS IS A GAME YOU'RE
ALWAYS MAKING ADJUSTMENTS.
HE HAD A SLOW START TO THE YEAR.
ENDED UP GETTING OPTIONED DOWN.
MID-JUNE, CAME BACK UP.
HAS BEEN SWINGING THE BAT WELL
SINCE.
SOMETIMES WHEN YOU HAVE THOSE UP
AND DOWN MOMENTS THROUGH A
SEASON, YOU'RE ABLE TO MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS, CLEAR YOUR MIND,
AND COME OUT READY TO GO.
SCOTT: FRANCE AT THIRD.
TORO AT SECOND.
YOU MENTIONED THIS TEAM BEING
EXCELLENT WITH RUNNERS IN
SCORING POSITION.
THEY'RE 2-2 WITH RUNNERS IN
SCORING POSITION HERE IN THE
FIRST.
HITTER'S 2-0 COUNT FOR TORRENS.
LAYS OFF A PITCH INSIDE.
IT'S 3-0.
CHRIS: URQUIDY NEEDS TO FIND A
WAY TO GET BACK IN THIS COUNT.
HE IS OK GETTING THE RUNNER ON
FIRST BASE, YOU TRY TO GET THE
DOUBLE PLAY BALL.
SCOTT: FOUR PITCHES AND A FREE
PASS FOR TORRENS.
MLB'S YOUTUBE CHANNEL.
THE TRADE HAS BEEN CRAZY.
TRUE STORY.
THAT TRADE WAS HIGHLY
CRITICIZED, NOT JUST LOCALLY,
BUT I WOULD SAY ON A NATIONAL
LEVEL JUST BECAUSE OF THE WAY IT
LOOKED.
OPTICS-WISE.
YOU'RE TRADING AWAY MAYBE YOUR
BEST RELIEVER.
THIS IS A TEAM THAT WAS VERY
MUCH INVOLVED IN THE PLAYOFF RUN
AND THEY STILL ARE.
THEY'RE THREE GAMES OUT OF A
SPOT.
NOBODY KNOWS ABOUT ABRAHAM TORO.
HE'S KIND OF BURIED ON THE BENCH
FOR THE ASTROS AND LOOK AT HIM
GO.
CHRIS: THAT'S WHEN YOU HAVE TO
TRUST YOUR GUYS IN THE FRONT
OFFICE.
YOU HAVE TO TRUST THE PLAN.
THE MARINERS ARE TRYING TO PUT
THEMSELVES IN POSITION TO BE
REALLY GOOD FOR THE UPCOMING
YEARS.
AND TO DO THAT, YEAH, YOU HAVE
GRAVEMAN FOR THE REST OF THE
SEASON.
WHAT DO YOU DO FOR NEXT YEAR?
TORO IS A GUY THAT COMES OVER
AND SWINGS THE BAT WELL.
YOU HAVE A FIRST BASEMAN OR
SECOND BASEMAN FOR THE FUTURE
AND YOU HAVE CONTROL OVER HIM AS
WELL.
THERE ARE SO MANY THINGS THAT GO
INTO THESE DECISIONS THAT FRONT
OFFICES MAKE.
IT'S TOUGH FOR PLAYERS TO DEAL
WITH THEM SOMETIMES.
YOU JUST HAVE TO TRUST THE
PROCESS.
SCOTT: TORO IS UNDER TEAM
CONTROL UNTIL 2026.
THEY'RE LOOKING TO BUILD
SOMETHING WITH LONGEVITY IN
SEATTLE.
THEY'RE HOPING THIS YOUNG MAN AT
THE PLATE IS A BIG PART OF THAT,
JARRED KELENIC.
TAKES THE PITCH LOW.
IT'S ANOTHER MISS FOR URQUIDY,
AND CHRISTIAN JAVIER IS GETTING
WARM IN THE HOUSTON BULLPEN.
WE'RE HERE IN THE FIRST.
GOOD NEWS FOR THE ASTROS IS
THEY'RE OFF TOMORROW.
YOU CAN EMPTY OUT THE RELIEF
PITCHING GROUP.
IF NEED BE.
AND THAT'S ANOTHER MISSED SPOT
FOR URQUIDY.
WHICH IS REALLY RARE TO SEE FROM
HIM.
THIS IS, LIKE I MENTIONED, A GUY
THAT CAN WAKE UP AND THROW
STRIKES.
CHRIS: HE CAN.
HE CAN STILL THROW STRIKES IN
THIS SITUATION.
WHAT HE'S HOPING IS KELENIC WILL
EXPAND HIS ZONE A LITTLE BIT.
SO GREAT JOB BY KELENIC TO STAY
WITHIN HIMSELF.
THESE ARE THE TYPE OF AT-BATS IF
YOU'RE A YOUNG GUY AND YOU'VE
BEEN SCUFFLING QUITE A BIT
THROUGHOUT THE SEASON, THESE ARE
THE TYPE OF AT-BATS EARLY IN THE
GAME THAT YOU CAN HAVE THAT CAN
TURN THIS LAST MONTH OF -- LAST
MONTH OF THE SEASON AROUND FOR
YOU.
COME THROUGH IN A CLUTCH
SITUATION LIKE THIS, KICK 'EM
WHILE THEY'RE DOWN.
EVEN IF IT'S JUST A WALK.
THAT'S A GOOD AT-BAT.
THAT'S AN R.B.I.
KEEP THE LINE MOVING.
SCOTT: THE PLATE DISCIPLINE HAS
BEEN THERE FOR KELENIC IN HIS
MINOR LEAGUE CAREER.
BEEN A LOT OF SWING AND MISS IN
HIS GAME IN THE MAJORS.
GREAT JOB BY MALDONADO TO
PREVENT THE RUN FROM COMING
ACROSS.
KELENIC GOES AFTER THE 3-1.
HE GOT UNDER IT.
AND TUCKER'S COMING IN.
CLOSE ENOUGH.
THAT IT'S NOT GOING TO BE DOABLE
FOR A TAG-UP.
IT'S JUST A FLY BALL OUT.
CHRIS: KELENIC WORKED HIMSELF
INTO A FAVORABLE POSITION RIGHT
THERE.
GOT A GOOD PITCH TO HIT.
JUST JAMMED HIMSELF UP A LITTLE
BIT.
I MEAN, THAT WAS A GOOD PITCH TO
PUT THE BARREL ON.
SOMETIMES WHEN YOU'RE JUST A
LITTLE BIT OFF, GET EXTENDED TOO
EARLY, YOU JAM YOURSELF A LITTLE
BIT.
YOU SEE THAT BALL RUNNING IN ON
HIS HANDS JUST A LITTLE BIT, BUT
IN A HITTER'S COUNT, IF YOU'RE
FEELING RIGHT, YOU'RE READY FOR
THAT PITCH.
SCOTT: CATCHER NUMBER EIGHT
HITTER, TOM MURPHY.
27 PITCHES SO FAR IN THIS INNING
FOR URQUIDY SO FAR.
THERE'S A STRIKE.
IT'S 1-1.
I MEAN, IF HE GETS OUT OF THIS
WITH JUST TWO RUNS ALLOWED, IT'S
A BIG, BIG WIN ON HIS SIDE AFTER
THE WAY THAT THIS INNING
STARTED.
CHRIS: IF YOU CAN GET OUT OF
THIS, YOU GET BACK TO THE
DUGOUT, YOU SETTLE IN, COME
BACK.
YOU LET THOSE TWO RUNS GO.
YOU COME OUT AND START FRESH AND
YOU TRUST YOUR OFFENSE TO BE
ABLE TO RECOUP THOSE RUNS.
SCOTT: MURPHY IN THE AIR.
HE'S GOT IT.
YEAH.
THE GOING TO BE A BIG WIN WHEN
IT COMES DOWN INTO THE GLOVE OF
CARLOS CORREA.
A FOUR-HIT, TWO-RUN FIRST FOR
THE MARINERS.
THEY LOADED UP THE BAGS A COUPLE
TIMES.
IT COULD HAVE BEEN MUCH WORSE.
THE TWO R.B.I.'S, OF COURSE,
REGISTERED TO THE ACCOUNT OF
ABRAHAM TORO.
THE TRADE'S WORKING OUT FOR BOTH
SIDES.
BOTTOM OF THE FIRST COMING UP.
>> HE DOES PULL IT.
AROUND THIRD COMES YULI GURRIEL.
HE'S GOING TO SCORE.
R.B.I. SINGLE, KYLE TUCKER.
RUNNER ON THE GO.
AND TUCKER CALLED SAFE ON A
PITCH JUST OFF THE PLATE.
KYLE TUCKER DRIVES ONE DEEP TO
RIGHT FIELD.
AND GONE!
TWO-RUN HOME RUN, KYLE TUCKER!
ASTROS TAKE THE LEAD, 5-3, IN
THE EIGHTH.
>> THAT BALL WAS DEMOLISHED.
NICE LITTLE BAT FLIP AT THE END
FOR HIM.
>> AS TUCKER HITS ONE PRETTY
WELL TO RIGHT FIELD.
BACK GOES MEYERS.
WATCH IT GO.
BACK-TO-BACK HOME RUNS.
WINNING THE GAME LAST NIGHT AND
ADDING TO THE LEAD TONIGHT.
>> HOLY TUCKER.
HE'S SEEING SOME FASTBALLS AND
HE'S DEMOLISHING SOME FASTBALLS.
>> BREAKING BALL, TUCKER GOES
THE OTHER WAY.
GIVING IT A LOOK.
THIS BALL IS FAIR AND IN PLAY.
NOW, IT BOUNCES INTO THE CROWD.
THAT WILL BE A DOUBLE FOR KYLE
TUCKER.
>> SHOWING POWER TO ALL FIELDS.
SCOTT: IT'S THE MLB GAME OF THE
WEEK PRESENTED ON YOUTUBE.
PRESENTED BY YOUTUBE SHORTS.
ALTUVE, BRANTLEY, GURRIEL,
YORDAN, CARLOS CORREA WITH
DYNAMITE NUMBERS AGAINST SEATTLE
THIS SUN.
KYLE TUCKER IN THE SIXTH SPOT.
OH, ASTRO FANS, YOU'RE SPOILED.
JAKE MEYERS HAS BEEN A SUPER
ROOKIE.
MARWIN GONZALEZ IS BACK WITH THE
STROS.
AND MARTIN MALDONADO WILL CATCH
AND HIT NINTH.
TYLER ANDERSON ON THE MOUND.
LEFT-HANDED PITCHER.
E.R.A. AT 4.35.
HE'S BEEN EVEN STRONGER SINCE
THE MARINERS PICKED HIM UP.
ANOTHER SHREWD MOVE BY THE FRONT
OFFICE.
CHRIS: TYLER ANDERSON HERE,
ANOTHER FOUR-PITCH GUY.
SIMILAR TO URQUIDY.
HE'S A FOUR-SEAM, CUTTER, SINKER
GUY.
THE DIFFERENCE IS HIS VELO IS
FAST.
AROUND 90 MILES AN HOUR.
WHAT HE'S BEEN ABLE TO DO ALL
YEAR LONG, THOUGH, IS CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SWING AND
MISSES.
HE EXPANDS THE ZONE, HITTERS
CHASE.
AND THEY KNOW THAT HE THROWS A
LOT OF STRIKES, WHICH IS WHAT
ALLOWS ALTUVE TO BE VERY
AGGRESSIVE IN THAT SITUATION.
HE KNOWS THAT HE THROWS A LOT OF
STRIKES.
SCOTT: CLEARLY CARLOS CORREA
WAS -- JOSE ALTUVE WAS AWAY.
STAT CAST 3-D POWERED BY GOOGLE
CLOUD.
A LOT OF FOUR-SEAM, CUTTER,
CHANGEUP.
SCOTT SERVAIS SAID THE CUTTER IS
BECOMING MORE AND MORE OF A
WEAPON.
CHRIS: THAT'S WHAT YOU HAVE TO
DO TO KEEP HITTERS OFF BALANCE.
IF YOU ARE A GUY THAT THROWS
FASTBALLS AND YOU ARE THROWING
90 MILES AN HOUR, YOU NEED
SOMETHING TO GET GUYS OFF THE
BARREL.
AND THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
PITCHERS LIKE CC SABATHIA WAS
ABLE TO DO LATER IN THEIR
CAREER.
THEY NEEDED SOME TYPE OF
DECEPTION TO GET GUYS OFF THE
BARREL.
THAT'S WHY HE'S USING HIS CUTTER
IN DIFFERENT SITUATIONS.
YOU SEE ON THE GRAPHIC RIGHT
THERE THAT HE HAS CURVEBALL THAT
HE THROWS FROM TIME TO TIME.
TALKING TO SERVAIS BEFORE THE
GAME, HE KNOWS HE'S A FLY BALL
PITCHER AND HE KNOWS THAT
CURVEBALL IS A GUY THAT GUYS HIT
IN THE AIR AND IN A STADIUM LIKE
THIS AT MINUTE MAID, YOU DON'T
WANT TOO MANY BALLS IN THE AIR.
SCOTT: IT'S NOT A PITCH HE DIALS
UP VERY FREQUENTLY.
IT'S JUST FOR FUN.
1-1 TO BRANTLEY.
IT'S A BALL AND TWO STRIKES.
THIS WAS A HUGE RE-SIGNING IN
THE OFF-SEASON FOR HOUSTON.
MR. CONSISTENCY.
.300-PLUS SINCE 2018 AND HE
SIGNED UP FOR THIS AND NEXT YEAR
WITH THE STROS.
CHRIS: BRANTLEY IS JUST A GUY
YEAR IN AND YEAR OUT THAT GIVES
YOU CONSISTENT AT-BATS.
HE NEVER TRIES TO DO TOO MUCH.
HE'S VERY QUIET AT THE DISH.
NOT TOO MUCH MOVEMENT.
WITH THAT BEING SAID, HE'S ABLE
TO REPLICATE HIS MOVE TIME AND
TIME AGAIN.
STAY THROUGH THE MIDDLE OF THE
FIELD.
AND COME THROUGH IN BIG
SITUATIONS ALL THE TIME BECAUSE
HE NEVER CHANGES HIS APPROACH.
SCOTT: THEY CALL HIM MIKE IN
HOUSTON.
HE'S A MENTOR FOR MANY.
AND HE MAKES CONTACT ON THE 1-2.
A NICE STOP AT FIRST TO THE
COVERING ANDERSON FOR AN OUT.
TY FRANCE PLAYED SOME SNEAKY
FIRST BASE THIS YEAR.
CHRIS: AND TY FRANCE IS A GUY
THAT HE HAD TO WORK ON HIS
DEFENSE.
HE WAS ORIGINALLY IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE INFIELD.
HE HAD TO WORK ON HIS DEFENSE,
AND HE'S ARGUABLY THE BEST FIRST
BASEMAN IN THE GAME RIGHT NOW
WITH DEFENSIVE RUNS SAVED AT
THREE.
SCOTT: WHICH IS CRAZY.
THE MARINERS ALSO WERE FORTUNATE
TO HAVE EVAN WHITE IN THAT SPOT.
HE'S BEEN DOWN THIS YEAR WITH AN
INJURY.
BUT TY FRANCE HAS MORE THAN
FILLED THE VOID, NOT ONLY ON
DEFENSE.
OF COURSE, HE'S BEEN A GREAT BAT
FOR THE TEAM.
SCOTTE SERVAIS TOLD US HOW GOOD
HE IS THIS MORNING.
NOW YULI GURRIEL TAKING A STRIKE
ON THE OUTSIDE CORNER.
CHRIS: AND BACK TO FRANCE REAL
Q
QUICK.
WHEN YOU LOSE A GOLD GLOVE FIRST
BASEMAN, IT HAS TO MEAN SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TEAM TO BE ABLE TO
REPLACE HIM WITH ANOTHER GOLD
GLOVE-CALIBER PLAYER.
SCOTT: ANDERSON WORKING BOTH
SIDES OF THE ZONE.
I CAN'T LOOK AWAY FROM THE
DELIVERY, TOO.
YOU MENTIONED THE DECEPTION WITH
THE CUTTER.
BUT THERE'S THE PITCH AGAIN.
TYLER ANDERSON ALMOST LOOKS LIKE
HE'S STARTING UP HIS BIKE WITH
HIS FOOT AND GETS A SWING AND
MISS AND A STRIKEOUT TO END THE
FRAME ON A 10-PITCH FIRST
INNING.
THREE UP, THREE DOWN AGAINST A
VERY POTENT ASTROS LINEUP.
MARINERS CARRIES THEIR 2-0 LEAD
INTO THE SECOND.
>> ON THE GROUND, TORO CAN'T
HANDLE IT.
CORREA IS IN.
MEANWHILE, GURRIEL IS RIGHT
BEHIND HIM.
HE SCORES, ALSO.
TWO RUNS ARE IN.
>> GETTING THE START IN CENTER
FIELD.
COMING OFF A ROAD TRIP WHERE HE
HIT .300.
HE DRIVES ONE DEEP TO LEFT
FIELD.
FORGET ABOUT IT!
THREE-RUN BOMB BY THE ROOKIE
JAKE MEYERS!
AND THE ASTROS JUMP OUT IN FRONT
5-0.
>> ALVAREZ, NINTH MAN TO BAT IN
THE FRAME.
AND ALVAREZ WHISTLES THIS ONE
DEEP TO RIGHT CENTER FIELD.
IT WILL GET DOWN FOR A BASE HIT
AND GO ALL THE WAY TO THE WALL.
ALTUVE.
6-0, ASTROS.
YORDAN'S 90th RUN BATTED IN THE
SEASON.
NO ONE OUT FOR TUCKER.
>> AND HE DRILLS THIS ONE INTO
LEFT CENTER FIELD.
THAT WILL BE DOWN FOR A HIT.
PAST THE DIVING JARRED KELENIC.
HERE COMES GURRIEL.
HE WILL BE WAVED HOME.
HE'S GOING TO SCORE.
TWO R.B.I. DOUBLE FOR KYLE
TUCKER, AND THE ASTROS IN DOUBLE
FIGURES.
SCOTT: IT'S 2-0, SEATTLE.
THEY ALSO MADE A TRADE ON JULY
27.
GRAVEMAN AND MONTERO TO BOOST
THE BULLPEN FOR HOUSTON.
AND JOE SMITH IS ADDED TO THE
BULLPEN MIX FOR SEATTLE.
ALONG WITH THE NOW GREAT ABRAHAM
TORO.
AND THAT'S THE O.P.S. HEADING
INTO TODAY WHERE HE'S ALREADY
CONTRIBUTED AN EXTRA-BASE HIT
AND TWO MORE R.B.I.'S.
SO OUR FIRST POLL QUESTION IS
VERY RELEVANT.
WHO GOT THE BETTER OF THAT DEAL?
ASTROS, MARINERS?
IT'S AWASH OR TOO SOON?
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
CHRIS: I WOULD SAY AS OF RIGHT
NOW YOU WOULD ASSUME THAT THE
MARINERS GOT THE BETTER END OF
THE DEAL.
BUT THAT COULD CHANGE VERY FAST.
IF IN CONTINUES TO GO ON, THE
ASTROS GO TO THE PLAYOFFS,
GRAVEMAN IS COMING OUT LATE IN
THE GAME TO CLOSE OUT -- TO
CLOSE OUT A BIG WORLD SERIES
GAME, I MEAN, THAT ARGUMENT
COULD EASILY SWITCH TO THE OTHER
SIDE.
RIGHT NOW IT'S SO EASY TO SAY
SEATTLE, BUT YOU JUST DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE FUTURE HOLDS.
SCOTT: TORO HAS BEEN SMASHING
THE BASEBALL FOR THE MARINERS.
GRAVEMAN IS A BIG PART OF THE
BACK END OF THE PEN NOW.
USHG DELIVERS ANOTHER -- URQUIDY
DELIVERS ANOTHER ONE.
CASTILLO IS HELPING THE SEATTLE
BULLPEN AND FILL IT.
CHRIS: WITHOUT THAT LIGHTS OUT
BULLPEN THAT MARINERS HAVE,
SERVAIS IS HAND CUPPED AND --
HANDCUFFED AND THEY WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO WIN THOSE ONE-RUN GAMES.
SCOTT: HELP US OUT FOR THE POLL
QUESTIONS.
ON YOUR COMPUTER SCREEN, MOBILE
DEVICE, WHATEVER IT IS.
THAT'S INTO THE GLOVE OF THE
ROOKIE JAKE MEYERS FOR THE FIRST
OUT.
IT WAS A FIRST INNING FULL OF
TRAFFIC FOR SEATTLE.
AFTER J.P. CRAWFORD FLEW OUT,
HERE'S MITCH HANIGER OFF THE
THIRD BASE BAG.
I THINK THAT WAS OFF URQUIDY'S
FOOT.
WHERE DID THAT GO?
FRANCE CONTRIBUTING THE OPPOSITE
FIELD HIT.
TORO BRINGS TWO HOME WITH A
DOUBLE.
TORRENS FOLLOWS WITH A WALK.
KELENIC FLEW OUT.
MURPHY POPPED OUT.
SO TWO RUNS.
THEY LOADED UP THE BASES A
COUPLE TIMES BUT THEY LEFT THEM
LOADED AS WELL.
MARINERS COMES OFF TWO RUNS OFF
JOSE URQUIDY AND WE'LL SEE IF HE
BOUNCES BACK HERE IN THE SECOND
INNING.
SECOND TIME THROUGH THE ORDER
FOR URQUIDY.
THIS IS CRAWFORD AGAIN.
CHRIS: CRAWFORD ABLE TO HAVE A
BIG MOMENT, BIG TWO R.B.I.,
PITCH OFF THE PLATE, ABLE TO
STAY THROUGH THE MIDDLE OF THE
FIELD AND CONTINUE TO BE CLUTCH
FOR THIS MARINERS OFFENSE.
SCOTT: TWO OF THE KEYS THE
MARINERS WILL TELL YOU TO THEM
BEING INVOLVED IN THE PLAYOFF
PICTURE RIGHT NOW, DESPITE JUST
OK OVERALL TEAM STATS, BULLPEN,
LIKE WE TALKED ABOUT, AND THE
MONEY WITH RUNNERS IN SCORING
POSITION.
CRAWFORD IS ONE OF THOSE THAT
LEADS THE PACK.
.333 IN THOSE SPOTS.
DOESN'T HAVE ONE OF THOSE
POSITIONS AT THE MOMENT.
BUT, HEY, RATHER BE BETTER WITH
GUYS ON THAN NOBODY ON.
CHRIS: AND HE'S BEEN VERY
VALUABLE TO THIS MARINERS
ORGANIZATION ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE BALL.
TALKING TO SCOTT BEFORE THE
GAME.
HE CONSIDERED CRAWFORD THE
QUARTERBACK OF THE INFIELD.
ALTHOUGH YOU HAVE SEAGER THERE
AS THE LEADER OF THE TEAM, HIM
AND CRAWFORD ON THE LEFT SIDE OF
THE INFIELD.
SCOTT: JUST SNUCK A BUNT.
IT'S A FOUL BALL.
THAT WILL LOAD UP THE COUNT FOR
CRAWFORD.
ALL RIGHT, YOUTUBE CREATORS,
HELP US OUT HERE.
POLL STILL GOING.
WE'LL KEEP IT GOING FOR ABOUT AN
INNING.
SECRET BASE IS OUR CREATOR
SPOTLIGHT.
WE'LL TALK MORE ABOUT THEM
LATER.
I THINK THE REAL ANSWER IS TORO
GOT THE BEST END OF IT.
THAT'S TRUE.
ABRAHAM TORO HAS BLOSSOMED.
CHRIS: THAT'S A GREAT POINT
RIGHT THERE.
SOMETIMES YOU CAN GET CAUGHT UP
IN A LOGJAM AS A YOUNG PLAYER
WITH AN ORGANIZATION THAT'S
ALWAYS IN PLAYOFF CONTENTION.
SCOTT: CRAWFORD SPINS ONE TO
LEFT FIELD.
BRANTLEY CHASING IT TOWARDS THE
LINE, IN THE CORNER, MAKES THE
CATCH FOR THE SECOND OUT.
CHRIS: FEW THINGS THE ASTROS
WILL HAVE TO DO TODAY --
CONTINUE TO BE GREAT, TO
CONTINUE TO COME BACK AND TRY TO
WIN THIS GAME.
FIRST THING THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO DO, ANDERSON, HE HAS TO
THROW STRIKES.
YOU HAVE TO MAKE THEM THROW
STRIKES TODAY.
HE HAS THE THIRD HIGHEST CLAYS
RATE IN MLB -- CHASE RATE IN
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL.
THE ASTROS NOT ABLE TO STRIKE
OUT A LOT, ABLE TO GET IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE ZONE, THEY'LL BE
OK TODAY.
YOU HAVE CORREA AND ALTUVE UP
THE MIDDLE OF THE FIELD.
CONTINUE TO PLAY GOOD DEFENSE
AND KEEP THE LINE MOVING.
THE LINE IS SO DEEP.
YOU HAVE TUCKER IN THE SIX HOLE
TODAY.
YOU'RE NEVER OUT OF THE WOODS
WITH THIS OFFENSE.
SO CONTINUE TO KEEP THE LINE
MOVING.
DON'T TRY TO BE THE HERO, AND
ALLOW YOUR OFFENSE JUST DO ITS
THING.
SCOTT: BALL AND A STRIKE TO
HANIGER.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
YESTERDAY, TRAILING BY A COUPLE
RUNS, YOU'RE IN THE NINTH
INNING, OH, ALEX BREGMAN'S UP.
CHRIS: BY THE WAY, WE HAVE THIS
GUY WAITING IN THE WINGS WHO
JUST CAME OFF THE D.L.
HASN'T GONE DEEP SINCE JUNE.
DON'T FORGET, DON'T FORGET WHO
HE'S BEEN FOR OUR ORGANIZATION.
SCOTT: HE DIDN'T FORGET.
OOZING WITH CONFIDENCE.
CHRIS: LOOK AT SOME OF CORREA'S
STATEMENTS AFTER THE GAME.
IT'S LIKE THAT OFFENSE KNEW.
EVERYBODY IN THE DUGOUT KNEW
BREGMAN WAS ABOUT TO COME
THROUGH IN THAT SITUATION.
HE WAS FACING ONE THAT MISSED
SLIDERS.
HE HAD TO COME WITH THE
FASTBALL.
BREGMAN, THOUGH HE HAD NO HOMERS
OFF THE FASTBALL THIS SEASON, HE
WAS ABLE TO COME THROUGH IN THAT
SITUATION.
SCOTT: THIS WOULD BE A NICE
RECOVERY FOR JOSE URQUIDY.
THAT'S AFOULED OFF.
THE ONLY THING IS THE PITCH
COUNT.
LIKE I SAID, YOU HAVE A PRETTY
RESTED ASTROS BULLPEN, AND YOU
HAVE AN OFF DAY TOMORROW FOR
HOUSTON.
SO EVEN IF URQUIDY ONLY GOES
FOUR, FIVE INNINGS, REALLY, EVEN
FOUR AT THIS POINT, BASED ON HIM
STILL WORKING HIS WAY BACK FROM
THE INJURED LIST, THEY'LL BE IN
GOOD SHAPE.
1-2.
SWING AND A MISS.
THERE YOU GO.
AFTER A TWO-RUN, FOUR-HIT FIRST
FROM SEATTLE, IT'S THREE UP,
THREE DOWN FROM JOSE URQUIDY, AS
WE BOUNCE INTO THE MIDDLE OF THE
SECOND.
TWO OUT, NOBODY ON.
>> HERE IS ALTUVE.
SECOND TIME THROUGH FOR THE
ASTROS.
>> ALTUVE HOOKS ONE DOWN THE
LEFT-FIELD LINE.
THIS BALL IS GOOD.
HOME RUN!
JOSE ALTUVE.
HIS FIRST HOME RUN SINCE JULY
30.
AND THE ASTROS LEAD 1-0.
>> A LOT OF FUN TO WATCH THIS
GUY GET HOT DOWN THE STRETCH.
>> KYLE SEAGER, LEADS HERE, TOP
OF THE SIXTH.
>> THIS IS PUMMELED OUT TO
RIGHT.
KYLE SEAGER WITH LEEAVING THE -
KYLE SEAGER LEAVING THE YARD.
PUTTING THE MARINERS IN FRONT.
ALEX BREGMAN, SINGLED IN THE
FIFTH.
>> BREGMAN HITS IT HIGH IN THE
AIR DEEP TO LEFT FIELD, AND YOU
CAN KISS IT GOODBYE?
OFF THE COMMUNITY LEADER SIGNS.
AND WE'RE TIED!
>> THE RUNNER AT SECOND FOR THE
ASTROS ARE GURRIEL.
>> THERE'S A BALL INTO RIGHT
FIELD.
HIT WELL.
THAT WILL BE OVER THE HEAD OF
HANIGER.
IT WILL BOUNCE INTO THE CROWD.
AND THAT WILL BE A GAME-WINNER.
ASTROS WIN IT 5-4 WITH A
WALK-OFF DOUBLE BY CORREA!
>> JUST WHAT HE DOES, T.K.
GETS BIG HITS.
SCOTT: OK.
LET ME FILL YOU IN ON THIS NEW
FEATURE I MENTIONED PROBABLY 10,
15 MINUTES AGO.
FANS WATCHING THE MLB GAME OF
THE WEEK RIGHT HERE ON YOUTUBE
HAVE YOUR CHANCE OF LISTENING
EXPERIENCE.
WE'RE SHOWING YOU HOW TO DO IT.
YOUR ICON AND YOUR PLAYER, HAS
AN AUDIO TRACKS BUTTON.
YOU CAN SELECT PRIMARY.
THAT'S US.
HOME, AWAY, RADIO CALL.
GO BACK AND FORTH.
DO WHAT YOU WANT.
IT'S ALL SYNC UP SEAMLESSLY
INTEGRATED ON YOUR FAVORITE
DEVICES.
YOU WON'T MISS A MINUTE OF THE
ACTION.
IT'S ALL THERE FOR YOU.
LITTLE FEATURE RIGHT HERE ON
YOUTUBE.
SCOTT BRAUN, CHRIS YOUNG, BRETT
DOLAN HANGING OUT WITH YOU ON A
WEDNESDAY AFTERNOON.
MARINERS AND ASTROS PLAYING
AGAINST EACH OTHER IN THE
REGULAR SEASON FOR THE FINAL
TIME IN 2021.
ALVAREZ, CORREA, AND TUCKER DUE
UP HERE IN THE SECOND AGAINST
TYLER ANDERSON, WHO POURS IN A
STRIKE.
CHRIS: ALVAREZ HAS BEEN SUCH A
POLISHED HITTER FROM HIS FIRST
TIME IN THE LEAGUE.
HE'S A GUY I PLAYED AGAINST.
SOMETIMES YOU SIT BACK IN AWE
HOW A YOUNG PLAYER CAN BE SO
QUIET AND SO CONFIDENT AT THE
DISH.
HE LOOKS LIKE A VETERAN.
HE LOOKS LIKE A VETERAN AS SOON
AS HE STEPPED IN THE BOX IN HIS
FIRST SEASON.
SXOIP HE ALSO --
SCOTT: HE ALSO LOOKS LIKE A
POWER HITTER.
THIS IS A BIG, STRONG DUDE.
AND STRONG CONTACT.
PAST THE SHIFTED INFIELDER.
TORO WAS IN A SOMEWHAT CORRECT
SPOT, BUT IT WAS SMOKED OFF THE
BAT OF ALVAREZ, AND HE STARTS
OFF THE SECOND WITH A SINGLE.
CHRIS: THAT'S WHAT YOU CALL
HITTING IT THROUGH THE SHIFT
RIGHT THERE.
SCOTT: YOU'RE SHIFTING ME?
I DON'T CARE.
CHRIS: PLAYING ME IN SHALLOW
RIGHT FIELD?
I CAN GET IT HARD JUST ENOUGH BY
YOU.
NICE EFFORT BY TORO.
SCOTT: YOU'RE GOING, WE'RE GOING
TO BACK YOU UP 30 FEET FOR
MOMENTS LIKE THIS.
AND YET, ALVAREZ STILL COMES
THROUGH.
NOW IT'S CORREA.
MR. WALK-OFF MAN FROM YESTERDAY
IN THE 10TH.
HITS A LEADOFF WALK-OFF DOUBLE
IN THE 10TH YESTERDAY.
RUNNER PLACED ON SECOND BASE TO
START EXTRAS.
AND IT ONLY TOOK ONE A BETTER TO
END THE GAME -- ON A BATTER
TONED THE GAME ON HOUSTON'S
SIDE.
CHRIS: CORREA PUTTING TOGETHER
ANOTHER REALLY GOOD SEASON.
IT'S NICE TO SEE HIM STAY
HEALTHY.
YOU KNOW, THROUGHOUT THE YEAR.
IT'S A BIG YEAR FOR HIM.
CAME OUT THE GATES HOT.
HE SLOWED DOWN A LITTLE BIT, BUT
EVEN HIS SLOWDOWN IS STILL VERY
PRODUCTIVE.
HE CONTINUES TO COME THROUGH IN
CLUTCH SITUATIONS.
SCOTT: LIKE THIS ONE LAST NIGHT.
ADDED TO THE RESUME.
GOOD MUSTARD ON THAT ONE.
AND INTO THE SEATS.
GROUND RULE AUTOMATIC DOUBLE.
GAME-ENDER.
ASTROS TAKE IT.
CHRIS: SOME PLAYERS JUST HAVE
WHAT IT TAKES.
THEY'RE ABLE TO DIG DOWN DEEP IN
BIG SITUATIONS.
SLOW THE GAME DOWN.
SLOW THE HEARTBEAT DOWN AND COME
THROUGH BIG IN SITUATIONS.
CORREA HAS ALWAYS BEEN THAT TYPE
OF PLAYER.
SCOTT: HE RIPS THAT ONE RIGHT
INTO THE CLUB AT THE HOT CORNER
OF KYLE SEAGER.
WOW!
CHRIS: CAN'T WAIT TO SEE THIS
EXIT VELO.
SCOTT: THAT'S ROCKET RETRIEVAL
RIGHT THERE.
CHRIS: THAT'S WHEN YOU GO INTO
THE DUGOUT AND EVERYBODY SAYS
NICE SWING.
MAN, I AM NOT TRYING TO HEAR
THAT.
THAT SHOULD HAVE TAKEN HIS GLOVE
OFF HIS HAND THERE.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS: 112 MILES OFF THE BAT
WILL GET YOU A RIGHT TURN BACK
TO THE DUGOUT.
I'LL TAKE THE JAM SHOT UP THE
MIDDLE ANY DAY.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: GOLD GLOVER.
AT THIRD BASE.
GOLD GLOVE LEFT SIDE OF THE
INFIELD FOR SEATTLE.
SEE, THAT WAS A PLAY MADE BY
SOMEONE WHOS A BEEN AT THE --
WHO'S BEEN AT THE POSITION FOR A
LONG TIME.
THAT'S EVIDENT THERE.
CHRIS: YOU SEE A SMILE ON
SEAGER'S FACE LIKE, WOW.
SCOTT: LOOK WHAT I FOUND.
CHRIS: AND STILL HAVE THE
WHEREWITHAL TO TRY TO GET TO
FIRST BASE AND TRY TO GET THE
DOUBLE PLAY.
SCOTT: THE DEFENSE IN THIS
SERIES FOR SEATTLE HASN'T BEEN
THE SMOOTHEST.
MOSTLY TALKING ABOUT THE
OUTFIELD.
THEY NEED A GAME LIKE THIS.
TUCKER INTO LEFT CENTER.
KELENIC CHASING IT.
AND IT'S GOING TO HOP UP AGAINST
THE WALL.
ALVAREZ HEADING FOR THIRD, AND
HE'S BEEN WAVED HOME.
AND HERE HE COMES.
THROW IS NOT IN TIME!
THE ASTROS ARE ON THE BOARD.
IT'S AN R.B.I. DOUBLE FOR KYLE
TUCKER TO BRING HOME ALVAREZ AND
MAKE IT 2-1.
CHRIS: KYLE TUCKER JUST
CONTINUES TO STAY HOT.
DUSTY BAKER LOVES HIM IN THE
POSITION THAT HE'S AT.
SOME GUYS HAVE THEIR BEST YEARS.
IF YOU'RE PLAYING IN THE SIX
HOLE OR SEVEN HOLE, THERE'S NO
NEED TO ALWAYS MOVE SOMEBODY UP
IN THE LINEUP.
YOU ALLOW THEM TO SETTLE IN
THEIR POSITION IN THE LINEUP AND
CONTINUE TO DO DAMAGE.
YOU SEE THAT BALL HIT INTO THE
GAP.
THAT'S A TOUGH PLAY FOR KELENIC
TO MAKE A MOVE.
THE WAY MINUTE MAID PARK IS
BUILT OVER HERE, ALTHOSE LITTLE
NOOKS AND CRANNIES, THERE'S NO
WAY HE COULD MAKE THAT PLAY.
AND THE BALL BEAT HIM THERE THAT
TIME.
BUT WITH A DROP -- WITH THE
DROP, HE'S SAFE.
SCOTT: THE BALL WAS FUMBLED
THERE BY MURPHY.
ALVAREZ SCORES.
TUCKER DELIVERS AGAIN, AND NOW
IT'S MEYERS.
ALVAREZ CAN MOVE PRETTY WELL FOR
A BIG DUDE.
CHRIS: A BIG MAN.
HE'S PICKING THEM UP AND PUTTING
THEM DOWN.
YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE AT FIRST BASE
AND THAT BALL HITS THE GAP, YOU
BETTER START SCORING, ESPECIALLY
IF I HIT IT.
MORALES IS CALLING A GOOD GAME.
I THOUGHT THE UMPIRE BEHIND THE
PLATE COULD BE A BIG PREDICTOR
HOW THIS GAME GOES.
A GUY LIKE ANDERSON WHO WILL
NEED TO NIBBLE A LITTLE BIT.
THE UMPIRE FORCES HIM TO COME
OVER THE MIDDLE OF THE PLATE,
THIS COULD BE DANGEROUS FOR HIM.
SCOTT: GETS A CHASE THERE FROM
MEYERS.
IT'S 1-1.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT LITTLE
KICK FROM ANDERSON BEFORE HE
DELIVERS?
DOES THAT DISTRACT HITTERS AT
ALL?
CHRIS: IT DOESN'T DISTRACT YOU
TOO MUCH.
THE ONLY THING IT MESSES WITH IS
YOUR TIMING.
YOU'RE TRYING TO CREATE YOUR
TIMING OFF HIS MOTION.
TRYING TO SEE WHEN HE'S GOING TO
BE RELEASING THE BALL.
THAT LITTLE HITCH COULD THROW
YOU OFF A LITTLE BIT.
SCOTT: RUNNERS GOING, AND THAT
IS SMOKED.
IT'S A FOUL BALL.
LOOK OUT, GARY PETTIS, THE THIRD
BASE COACH.
TUCKER WILL HEAD BACK TO SECOND.
CHRIS: HEADS UP BASE RUNNING BY
TUCKER THERE.
PITCHERS FALL INTO PATTERNS.
THEY HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT THAT
GUY AT THE PLATE.
SOMETIMES THEY FORGET ABOUT YOU
AT SECOND BASE.
SO TUCKER BEING READY IN THAT
SITUATION COULD HAVE GOT HIMSELF
AN EASY BAT.
SCOTT: TUCKER CAN MOVE, TOO.
DUSTY BAKER TOLD US THIS
MORNING, THAT'S A 30-30 GUY WE
HAVE SOMETIMES IN THE SIX OR
SEVEN HOLE IN THE LINEUP.
CHRIS: JAKE MEYERS PUTTING
TOGETHER A GREAT AT-BAT HERE.
TALKING TO DUSTY BEFORE THE
GAME, HE'S TRYING TO DETERMINE,
HOW DO YOU DECIDE BETWEEN MEYERS
AND MCCORMICK ON WHO WILL BE
YOUR CENTER FIELDER?
YOU HAVE TWO YOUNG GUYS WITH THE
POTENTIAL TO BE STARS IN THIS
GAME.
YOU'RE TRYING TO KEEP THEM BOTH
HOT.
AND TODAY MEYERS GOT THE CALL.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE A CLOSE
RACE AND WHOEVER'S HOT WILL GET
THE PLAYING TIME RIGHT NOW.
SCOTT: MCCORMICK HIT THE INJURED
LIST A WEEK AND A HALF AGO WITH
THAT HAND ISSUE.
THAT'S REALLY WHEN MEYERS TOOK
OVER AT THE POSITION.
NOW HE'S OFF AND RUNNING.
R.B.I. MACHINE SINCE HE WAS
CALLED UP ABOUT A MONTH AGO.
CHRIS: NOT QUITE WALLY PIPP.
W
YOU TAKE ADVANTAGE AS A YOUNG
PLAYER.
SCOTT: TIME IS CALLED.
BY THE WAY, KIDS, GOOGLE WALLY
PIPP.
CHRIS: THERE WAS A TIME WHEN I
HAD TO GOOGLE HIM.
I'M NOT THAT OLD.
SCOTT: THAT'S A GOOD STORY.
READ AND WATCH.
HE'S DONE ALL OF HIS DAMAGE
AGAINST FASTBALLS IN THE BIG
LEAGUES SO FAR.
HERE HE COMES.
HE MISSES IN.
CHRIS: MEYERS WITH A SHORT,
COMPACT SWING.
HE ALLOWS THE BALL TO TRAVEL,
WHICH WOULD HELP HIM AFTER THE
TWO-STRIKE COUNT, IT WILL HELP
HIM IN THESE SITUATIONS.
HE WILL GET THE BALL DEEP.
HE'S FINE GOING THE OTHER WAY.
HE'S NOT TRYING TO HIT THE BALL
OUT OF THE YARD.
HE WILL ALLOW THAT JUST TO
HAPPEN.
SCOTT: HE HOMERED ON MONDAY IN
THIS SERIES.
A THREE-RUN SHOT IN THE SECOND.
THAT MADE IT 5-0.
HOUSTON HAD A BIG 11-2 WIN IN
GAME TWO OF THE SERIES.
THERE'S A SWING AND A MISS.
ANDERSON'S SECOND STRIKEOUT OF
THE DAY.
CHRIS: THE GRUNT CHANGEUP WORKS
EVERY TIME.
SCOTT: SELL IT.
SOLD.
CHRIS: TOOK THAT OUT OF A ZACH
GREINKE BOOK.
EVERY TIME HE HEARD THAT BIG
GRUNT, SIT BACK AND WAIT LONGER.
HE'S TRYING TO TRICK YOU.
SCOTT: NOW, MARWIN GONZALEZ,
MINOR LEAGUE CONTRACT AUGUST 27.
HE WAS LET LOOSE BY BOSTON.
CHRIS: YOU WOULDN'T KNOW THAT
AROUND HERE FROM THE FAN
REACTION JUST NOW AS HE GOT
CALLED TO THE PLATE.
SCOTT: NO.
SOME HUGE HITS IN HIS HOUSTON
CAREER.
HE PLAYED WITH THE ASTROS FROM
2012 TO 2018.
ALMOST 800 GAMES.
AND THE BIGGEST HOME RUN IN
ASTROS HISTORY.
CHRIS: I'D SAY SO.
SCOTT: 2017 OFF KENLEY JANSEN IN
THE WORLD SERIES.
CHRIS: IN L.A.
SCOTT: AND KENLEY WAS LIGHTS OUT
IN HIS CAREER.
UNTOUCHABLE, BASICALLY.
MARWIN UNPHASED.
A DO IT ALL GUY FOR HOUSTON FOR
MANY YEARS.
SHOWING UP TO THE BALL FIELD
WITH SOMETIMES EIGHT GLOVES IN
HIS LOCKER.
WHEREVER YOU WANT ME IN THE
LINEUP, ON THE FIELD, HE'S READY
TO GO WITH A SMILE.
CHRIS: HE REMINDS YOU OF LIKE A
CHRIS TAYLOR IN L.A.
YOU HAVE A GUY LIKE THAT, YOU
CAN DEAL WITH INJURIES MUCH
BETTER WITH OTHER PLAYERS ON
YOUR TEAM.
BECAUSE AS SOON AS SOMEBODY GOES
DOWN, MARWIN CAN STEP UP AND
PLAY THAT POSITION AND PLAY IT
WELL.
NOT JUST FILL IN BUT GO OUT
THERE AND PLAY THE POSITION
WELL.
SCOTT: HERE GOES TUCKER, AND
GONZALEZ TAKES OFF TO THE
CRAWFORD BOXES.
FORGET ABOUT IT!
THE ASTROS GRAB THE LEAD, 3-2,
OFF A TWO-RUN SHOT FROM MARWIN
GONZALEZ.
WELCOME BACK TO HOUSTON, MARWIN!
CHRIS: NICE HOMECOMING RIGHT
THERE, HUH?
OH, THAT HAS TO FEEL GOOD.
YOU'RE BACK WITH YOUR BOYS.
HAVING FUN.
YOU KNOW EVERYBODY IN THE
CLUBHOUSE ALREADY.
AND THIS BALL GETS A LOT OF
Y
PLATE.
ANDERSON IS A GUY THAT NEEDS TO
GET IN THE CORNER.
IF HE MISSES OVER THE PLATE WITH
THIS OFFENSE, IT COULD GET UGLY
QUICK.
SCOTT: OFF THE BAG HE GOES, IT
FEELS GOOD TO BE BACK.
THAT'S THE THING.
MARWIN REALLY STRUGGLED WITH THE
RED SOX 77 GAMES THIS SEASON,
.202, JUST TWO HOME RUNS.
BUT YOU RETURN HOME TO A PLACE
YOU'RE COMFORTABLE WITH, YOU
MIGHT BE A BIG PART OF THIS TEAM
DOWN THE STRETCH.
NO DOUBT ABOUT IT OFF THE BAT OF
MARWIN GONZALEZ.
HERE'S MALDONADO.
B
BASES EMPTY NOW HERE IN THE
SECOND.
ASTROS NOW UP BY A RUN.
CHRIS: ONE OF THE HUGE BENEFITS
THAT HOUSTON HAS BY BEING SO
DEEP WITH THEIR OFFENSE IS THAT
IT ALLOWS A PLAYER LIKE
MALDONADO, WHO'S NOT HAVING THE
STRONGEST YEAR OFFENSIVELY, TO
BE OK AND JUST CONTINUE TO GO
OUT THERE AND WORK WITH YOUR
STARTING PITCHING STAFF, TCONTRL
THE GAME.
AND HE CALLS AN AMAZING GAME.
YOU CAN'T RUN ON HIM.
GREAT DEFENSIVE CATCHER.
AND VERY VALUABLE TO THIS TEAM.
SCOTT: TAKES HIS FIRST STRIKE.
YEAH, AND WHEN YOU LOOK UP AT
THE LINEUP ONE THROUGH EIGHT.
YOU GO, OK, MARTIN MALDONADO
DOES NOT HAVE TO BE SALVADOR
PEREZ FOR US TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
CHRIS: HE'LL HAVE HIS DAYS.
HE'LL HAVE HIS HIGHLIGHT DAYS
WHEN HE COMES THROUGH IN A BIG
SITUATION.
BUT WHEN YOU'RE THAT DEEP,
LITERALLY ONE THROUGH EIGHT CAN
BEAT YOU IN THAT SITUATION, I
MEAN, HE HIT THAT IN THE EIGHT
HOLE.
YOU HAD YOUR EIGHT HOLE HITTER
TO GIVE YOU THE LEAD BACK AND
GIVE URQUIDY A FRESH START.
SCOTT: AND THAT'S WITH BREGMAN
ON THE BENCH.
TYLER ANDERSON TYING HIS SHOES
AND GETTING READY TO FACE THE
ASTROS' LINEUP FOR THE SECOND
TIME.
ALTUVE POPPED OUT TO SHORTSTOP
FIRST TIME AROUND.
THAT'S JUST NOT THE GUY YOU WANT
TO WALK.
CHRIS: NOT THE GUY YOU WANT TO
WALK, AND THE LAST THREE GUYS
YOU FACED BEFORE THAT, YOU HAD
THREE BALLS OVER 100 MILES AN
HOUR IN A ROW.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS IF YOU MISS
OVER THE MIDDLE.
SCOTT: LOUD CONTACT FROM THE
ASTROS THIS INNING.
ALVAREZ STARTED IT OFF WITH THE
SINGLE.
PAST THE SHIFT.
EVEN KOREA WITH THE SMASH --
CORREA WITH THE SMASH INTO THE
GLOVE TO SEAGER.
CHRIS: ALTUVE, WHAT MAKES HIM SO
GREAT, HE'S SO UNPREDICTABLE ON
WHEN HE'S GOING TO BE OVERLY
AGGRESSIVE AND WHEN HE'S NOT.
NORMALLY WHEN YOU SEE A GUY
SWING AT THE FIRST PITCH OF THE
GAME, HE WOULD NORMALLY TAKE
THAT FIRST PITCH.
ALTUVE ASSUMED HE WOULD GET A
FASTBALL RIGHT THERE AND HE
WOULD TRY TO JUMP ON IT AND JUMP
ON IT AGAIN.
SO FOR ANDERSON, IT'S GOOD HE
WENT WITH THE OFF-SPEED WITH THE
FIRST PITCH.
SCOTT: VETERAN MOVE.
IN ON THE HANDS, POP-UP, AND OUT
OF THE INNING.
BUT THE ASTROS PUT UP THREE, AND
THEY SNATCHED THE LEAD FROM
SEATTLE.
MANY THANKS TO MARWIN GONZALEZ.
HEY, MARWIN, HOUSTON IS HOME.
>> HIT HARD THE OTHER WAY.
A CHANCE.
FAIR BALL.
YES, INDEED.
KYLE SEAGER SCORES AND THE
MARINERS HAVE A 6-5 LEAD.
>> BIG HIT.
ON THE GROUND, BASE HIT.
RIGHT FIELD CORNER.
J.P. WALKS HOME.
KYLE SEAGER, CHA-CHING.
5-3, SEATTLE.
>> A 1-0 MARINERS BALLGAME.
STRIKE THREE CALLED!
THAT'S THE BALLGAME!
THE MARINERS PITCHED
BACK-TO-BACK SHUTOUTS.
>> HIGH DRIVE RIGHT FIELD.
GOT BIG-TIME CARRIES.
SLICE THAT, BABY!
THREE-RUN HOMER, KYLE SEAGER!
8-5 LEAD FOR THE MARINERS.
>> HE DRILLS THIS, DRILLED AND
CRUSHED AND THIS IS GONE!
GRAND SLAM!
>> WHAT AN AT-BAT.
I WONDER WHAT THE VIBE OF THE
CLUBHOUSE WILL BE TONIGHT.
4-0, MARINERS.
SCOTT: OUR FIRST YOUTUBE  POLL
IS NOW CLOSED.
WHO GOT THE BETTER OF THE
ASTROS-MARINERS DEADLINE DEAL?
IT HAS BEEN A BATTLE BACK AND
FORTH.
THE MARINERS TAKE IT BY A 38%
COUNT.
THAT IS WHAT YOU WENT WITH,
RIGHT?
CHRIS: I THINK THE FANS MADE A
GOOD CALL.
SCOTT: SO DOES OUR NEXT GUEST.
WE APPRECIATE THE TIME.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU ON.
CHRIS F.: THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME ON.
SCOTT: WE WERE ASKING EVERYONE
WHO GOT THE BETTER OF THE
ASTROS-MARINERS DEAL.
ABRAHAM TORO LOOKS PRETTY GOOD.
CHRIS F.: HE HAS BEEN
PHENOMENAL.
HE HAS REALLY HELPED US OUT BIG
TIME.
CHRIS Y.: I LOVE YOUR STORY.
FROM STRUGGLING A COUPLE OF
YEARS BEFORE YOU WENT TO KOREA,
WHAT ADJUSTMENTS WERE YOU ABLE
TO MAKE?
CHRIS F.: THE BIGGEST THING I
TOOK WAS FIGURING OUT HOW TO
TRUST MYSELF AND CONTINUE TO BE
CONFIDENT, GOING THROUGH NEW
YORK AND REALLY STRUGGLING
DISRUPTIVE THE CONFIDENCE.
I AM CONFIDENT THIS YEAR AND WAS
ABLE TO GET ON A NICE LITTLE
ROLL AND ABLE TO HAVE SOME FUN.
CHRIS Y.: DOES THE MULTI-YEAR
DEAL EASE SOME OF THE STRESS?
CHRIS F.: THAT DEFINITELY HELPS.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, IT COMES
DOWN TO WANTING TO COMPETE.
SCOTT: SEAGER, FRANCE AND TORO
DUE UP FOR THE MARINERS IN THE
THIRD.
URQUIDY ABOUT TO DELIVER PITCH
NUMBER 50.
IT IS LOW, BALL FOUR.
LEAD OFF WALK FOR THE MARINERS.
WE ARE TALKING TO CHRIS FLEXEN.
ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE, LET US
KNOW AND WE WILL RELAY OVER TO
THEM.
ANOTHER TRADE ADDITION, HOW HAS
HE LOOKED.
EVALUATE WHAT HE DOES.
CHRIS F.: HE IS INTERESTING.
COMES FROM OVER-THE-TOP, THROWS
A FOUR-PITCH MIX.
HE IS A COMPETITOR.
EVERY TIME HE TAKES THE BALL, HE
IS OUT THERE COMPETING.
SCOTT: WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT ALL
OF THE PICKUPS THE MARINERS HAVE
MADE, YOU ARE GOING TO BE PART
OF THAT AND WE WILL SHOW MORE
INTO SECOND.
TY FRANCE IS FACING A 1-0 COUNT.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PLAYERS WHO
CAME AROUND HERE, YOU CAN LOOK
AT THE BULLPEN, SADLER, DREW
STECKENRIDER, THERE ARE A TON OF
PLAYERS WHO HAD A JOURNEY,
STRUGGLES AND OTHER SPOTS, AND
THEN LAND IN SEATTLE AND SEE A
TON OF SUCCESS IN 2021.
THAT IS FOULED BACK.
FLEXEN, SEWALD, THESE UNDER THE
RADAR ACQUISITIONS.
ONCE YOU GET THERE, WHAT MAKES
IT SPECIAL?
IS THERE SOME INGREDIENT THAT
HAS TURNED THE CORNER FOR SO
MANY PLAYERS?
CHRIS F.: I THINK IT IS A GREAT
GROUP OF GUYS.
WE GET ALONG WELL.
WE ARE ALWAYS HAVING FUN
COMPETING IN THESE BALLGAMES.
FOR ME, GETTING THAT OPPORTUNITY
TO GO OUT AND COMPETE.
IT HAS BEEN FUN.
IT IS AWESOME.
SCOTT: IT IS WORKING.
THE MARINERS ARE THREE GAMES OUT
OF A PLAYOFF SPOT.
TY FRANCE FACING A 1-2 COUNT.
IT IS UPSTAIRS, 2-2.
HERE IS OUR FIRST QUESTION FROM
A YOUTUBE CREATOR.
WHO WAS YOUR FAVORITE PITCHER
GROWING UP?
CHRIS F.: I WAS BORN IN THE BAY
AREA AND I WAS A HUGE FAN OF
MATT CAIN.
CHRIS Y.: HE WAS IN MY BOOK, IF
YOU WERE WONDERING.
HE WAS A GREAT PITCHER.
HE ATTACKED THE ZONE.
A THREE-PITCH GUY.
HE IS GOING TO USE HIS FASTBALL
IN AND OUT.
CHRIS F.: A GOOD SLIDER.
SCOTT: WE ARE GOING TO FACT
CHECK THAT.
CHRIS Y.: LET ME HAVE MY MOMENT.
SCOTT: IT IS A "NO," A RARE
MISS.
CHRIS Y.: PULL UP MY TERRIBLE
NUMBERS AGAINST HIM.
SCOTT: 8-36.
TY FRANCE DOWN ON STRIKES.
WHERE IS YOUR FAVORITE STADIUM
TO PITCH AT WENT ON THE ROAD?
CHRIS F.: I HAVE NOT HIT ALL OF
THEM YET.
I THINK I WILL HAVE THREE LEFT
AT THE END OF THE YEAR.
I AM MISSING GIANTS, TORONTO,
ONE OTHER ONE.
BOSTON WAS PRETTY COOL TO
PAYCHECK.
I HAD A LOT OF FUN THERE.
-- THAT WAS PRETTY COOL TO PITCH
AT.
THAT WAS PRETTY AWESOME FOR ME.
CHRIS Y.: DO YOU FIND YOURSELF
AT FENWAY NOT COMING IN ON
RIGHTIES?
DID YOU FIND YOURSELF CHANGING
THE WAY YOU PITCH BECAUSE OF THE
YARD?
CHRIS F.: NO, THAT WAS ONE OF MY
BETTER OUTINGS.
CHRIS Y.: YOU HAD HITTERS THAT
CHANGE THEIR APPROACH BECAUSE OF
BOSTON.
YOU HAVE THE WALL THAT LOOKS
LIKE IT IS 250 FEET AWAY FROM
YOU.
HE CAN PLAY MIND GAMES WITH YOU.
CHRIS F.: I THINK BOGAERTS HIT A
DOUBLE OFF THE WALL, AND DEVERS
HAD A DOUBLE.
I WAS TRYING NOT TO WORRY ABOUT
THAT TOO MUCH.
SCOTT: LIKE YOU SAID, IT WORKED
OUT FOR YOU.
SEVEN INNINGS, ONE RUN DURING
THAT OUTING AT FENWAY PARK FOR
CHRIS FLEXEN.
IT IS 2-2 TO ABRAHAM TORO.
WHAT IS THE BEST NICKNAME YOU
HAVE BEEN GIVEN?
DO YOU HAVE A NICKNAME?
THAT EVERYONE USES?
CHRIS F.: IT IS SIMPLE.
IT IS "FLEX."
PLAIN AND SIMPLE "FLEX."
GET OUT OF HERE!
SCOTT: I AM LOOKING AT BASEBALL
REFERENCE.
"BIG BABY" IS YOUR LISTED
NICKNAME?
CHRIS F.: NEW YORK GAVE ME THAT
IN 2017.
I WAS MUCH HEAVIER AND HAD ZERO
FACIAL HAIR.
THEY LOOKED AT ME AND SAID YOU
LOOK LIKE AN OVERGROWN BABY AND
STARTED CALLING ME "BIG BABY"
AND IT'S STUCK.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: BIG MAN NOW.
TORO, WEAKLEY TO FIRST, HE WILL
STEP ON THE BAG FOR OUT NUMBER
TWO.
WHAT IS THE STORY THERE?
I KNOW THERE WAS SOME WEIGHT
LOSS OVERSEAS.
CHRIS F.: I FEEL GREAT NOW.
AFTER MY 2018 YEAR, I STRUGGLED
WITH SOME INJURIES.
IT WAS LIKE A CAREER CHECK TYPE
OF THING.
FOR ME, IT WAS TIME TO MAKE A
CHANGE.
I WENT FROM 265 DOWN TO 230 FROM
2018 TO 2019.
IN KOREA, I GOT AS LOW AS 215.
I FEEL BETTER, I FEEL MORE
AGILE, I MOVE BETTER AND I AM
ABLE TO RECOVER BETTER.
CHRIS Y.: IT IS DIFFERENT FOR
EVERY GUY.
EVERYONE HAS A DIFFERENT PLAYING
WEIGHT THE NEED TO BE AT.
OVER THE YEARS, YOU FIND OUT
WHAT YOUR HAPPY ZONE IS.
CHRIS F.: FOR ME, LIGHR IS
BETTER.
I HAVE STRUGGLED WITH SOME
INJURIES BUT I THINK WERE WEIGHT
RELATED.
SCOTT: WHAT IS THE KEY FOOD THAT
HELP YOU OUT?
CHRIS F.: FOOD OUT IN KOREA?
SOME SOUP WITH RAMEN.
THE FOOD WAS UNBELIEVABLE.
I HAD A REALLY GOOD EXPERIENCE
UP THERE.
FOR THE WEIGHT LOSS, IT WAS
COMMITTING TO A GOAL AND REALLY
STICKING TO IT.
TRYING TO EAT CLEAN, GRILLED
CHICKEN, STEAK, A LOT OF
VEGETABLES.
SCOTT: I HEARD THE FOOD OUT
THERE WAS INCREDIBLE.
CY, HAVE YOU BEEN?
CHRIS Y.: I ALWAYS WANTED TO GO.
CHRIS F.: IT WAS IN THE MIDDLE
OF COVID, SO I DEDUCTED TO
EXPLORE TOO MUCH BUT IF YOU
EVER GET THE CHANCE TO GO, I
RECOMMENDED.
ONCE THIS COVID THING BLOWS OVER
SOON, I WILL TRY TO HEAD BACK
OUT THERE.
SCOTT: YOU HAVE FRIENDS OUT
THERE AND YOU COULD SAY WHAT
HAPPENED HERE HAS REALLY HELPED
ME IN THE BIG.
CHRIS F.: ABSOLUTELY.
CHRIS Y.: WE ARE GLAD YOU ARE
BACK.
IT IS A GOOD SIGN WHEN YOU ARE
DOING AN INTERVIEW IN YOUR
TEAMMATES ARE THROWING SUNFLOWER
SEEDS AT YOU.
[LAUGHTER]
THAT TELLS YOU THERE IS GOOD
CHEMISTRY GOING ON.
CHRIS F.: JP WAS GETTING ME.
CHRIS Y.: THAT NEVER GETS OLD.
THROW SOME BUBBLEGUM.
SCOTT: THERE IS ONLY SO MUCH
AVAILABLE IN THE DUGOUT.
CHRIS Y.: TELL THE GUYS TO GET
CREATIVE.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: DO NOT THROW ANYTHING TOO
DANGEROUS.
CHRIS F.: NOTHING TOO DANGEROUS
AND NOTHING TOO COLD.
SCOTT: HERE IS TORRENS, THE 1-2,
HE STAYS ALIVE.
WE ARE DOWN TO THE NUMBER 6
HITTER FOR THE MARINERS.
WE ARE HANGING OUT WITH CHRIS
FLEXEN, STARTING PITCHER FOR THE
SEATTLE MARINERS.
WHAT HAS THE SEASON BEEN LIKE?
THIS TEAM IS IN THE THICK OF A
PLAYOFF RACE.
WHAT IS THE DYNAMIC OF THE
CLUBHOUSE?
IT IS LIKE YOU ARE PLAYING IN
THE PLAYOFFS ON A DAILY BASIS.
CHRIS F.: WITH THE SCHEDULE WE
HAVE, A LOT OF THE TEAMS WE ARE
FACING.
IT IS EXCITING.
WE ARE WIN, -- WE ARE LOOKING TO
WIN BALL GAMES, SERIES.
WE HAVE SOME YOUNG GUYS WHO ARE
HOLDING IT DOWN AT THE TOP.
IT IS A LOT OF FUN.
CHRIS Y.: EVEN WHEN I AM
LISTENING TO YOU, IT SEEMS LIKE
YOU ARE IN EVERY AT-BAT WITH
YOUR GUYS OUT THERE.
HAS IT BEEN EVERYTHING YOU
IMAGINED IT TO BE IN A PLAYOFF
RACE?
CHRIS F.: I THINK AS A GROUP, WE
DO A PRETTY GOOD JOB.
SOME OF THE YOUNG GUYS,
INCLUDING MYSELF, I DON'T THINK
I HAVE BEEN PART OF A PLAYOFF
PUSH AT THE MAJOR LEAGUE LEVEL.
I WAS NOT UP THERE IN NEW YORK
FOR ANY OF THAT.
JUST KEEPING OUR HEADS ON
STRAIGHT AND STAYING FOCUSED ON
WINNING BALLGAMES.
SCOTT: GRIND OUT AB'S LIKE LUIS
TORRENS.
HE MAKES CONTACT, IT IS GOBBLED
UP AT THIRD, THROWS ACROSS FOR
THE OUT.
GOOD LUCK THE REST OF THE WAY.
CHRIS F.: APPRECIATE THAT.
TAKE CARE.
SCOTT: MARWIN GONZALEZ MAKING
HIS FIRST START BACK WITH THE
HOUSTON ASTROS, HAS A HOME RUN
IN HIS POCKET AND A NICE PLAY
OVER AT THIRD.
♪
>> IN THE AIR TO LEFT FIELD,
BACK ON IT DIAZ, HE MAKES A NICE
DIVING CATCH.
DIAZ TO THE BACKHAND.
NOT A NATURAL OUTFIELDER BUT
MAKING A FINE PLAY IN LEFT
FIELD.
THAT BALL POPPED IN THE AIR, A
LONG RUN FOR BREGMAN, HE IS THE
ONLY ONE WHO CAN GET THERE AND
HE DOES IN FOUL.
ALEX BREGMAN, A NICE PLAY TO END
THE INNING.
THAT IS A STRIKE HIM OUT, THROW
HIM OUT DOUBLE PLAY.
RUNNER ON THE GO, THE THROW BY
STUBBS IS ON THE MONEY.
>> THROWING A SEED.
>> YULI GURRIEL HITS ONE HIGH
AND DEEP DOWN THE LEFT-FIELD
LINE AND THIS BALL IS GONE.
HE CUTS THE LEAD IN HALF AND IT
IS NOW A ONE RUN GAME.
CARLOS CORREA SENDS ONE DEEP TO
CENTER FIELD.
THAT BALL IS GONE!
BACK-TO-BACK JACKS!
JUST LIKE THAT, THE GAME IS TIED
AT 3-3!
>> TWO PITCHES, TWO BOMBS.
WOW!
SCOTT: YOU ARE WATCHING THE MLB
GAME LIVE OF THE WEEK, LIVE ON
YOUTUBE.
TRY SHORTS IN THE YOUTUBE APP ON
YOUR PHONE.
DO NOT FORGET TO CHECK OUT
YOUTUBE'S LIVE GAME COMMENTARY.
YOU HAVE ASTROS, MARINERS
CHANNELS, A SELECT GROUP OF
YOUTUBE CREATORS.
KEEPING AN EYE ON THE DISCUSSION
THROUGHOUT THE GAME.
THAT INCLUDES QUESTIONS FROM OUR
YOUTUBE CREATORS.
LANCE MCCULLERS JR. WILL JOIN US
SOON.
FIRST PITCH SWINGING, MICHAEL
BRANTLEY GOING TO WRITE-CENTER,
MITCH HANIGER RUNS IT DOWN FOR
THE FIRST OUT.
BRANTLEY FLIES OUT.
BRETT: I KEEP GOING BACK TO OUR
PREGAME MEETING WITH SCOTT
SERVAIS.
WE TURNED AROUND AND THE
MARINERS WERE TAKING INFIELD.
SERVAIS SAID THEY DO THIS EVERY
DAY.
THIS IS THE LAST GAME OF A ROAD
TRIP.
THIS IS A DAY GAME FOLLOWING A
NIGHT GAME IN SEPTEMBER.
I CANNOT BELIEVE IT IS VERY
COMMON AMONG ANY OTHER TEAM.
SCOTT: WE ARE ALL AROUND THE
GAME.
CY, YOU PLAY DOUBLE-DIGIT
SEASONS.
DID YOU EVER DO THAT ON A DAILY
BASIS?
CHRIS: NOT OFTEN.
THESE GUYS ARE YOUNG AND WILLING
TO GO OUT THERE AND GET THE WORK
IN.
THEY ARE GOING OUT THERE TRYING
TO WIN GAMES.
NORMALLY, AFTER A LOSS LIKE THEY
HAD LAST NIGHT, YOU HAVE THE DAY
GAME AFTER THE NIGHT GAME, YOU
WANT YOUR GUYS RESTING.
SCOTT SAID GETTING THOSE GUYS
OUT THERE AND GETTING WORK ON
DEFENSE BEFORE THE GAME -- THEY
DID NOT HIT BATTING PRACTICE --
IT GETS THEM READY FOR THE GAME.
THEY ARE READY TO GO.
SCOTT: IT IS LIKE A WARM UP
WORKOUT.
CHRIS: IT IS A WARM UP.
YOU NEED GUYS LIKE KYLE SEAGER
TO BUY IN ON IT.
THE TEAM GOES AS SEAGER GOES.
WITH THOSE TWO GUYS ABLE TO WORK
TOGETHER AND GET THE BEST OUT OF
THEIR GUYS, THAT IS LEADERSHIP.
SCOTT: GURRIEL TOWARD THE
MIDDLE, AND THAT WILL DROP.
IT IS A BASE HIT FOR YULI.
IT IS A ONE OUT SINGLE FOR THE
ASTROS IN THE THIRD.
CHRIS: THIS ASTROS OFFENSE
CONTINUES TO PUT TOGETHER GOOD
AT-BATS, CONTINUES TO PUT THE
BARREL ON THE BALL.
SCOTT: HE WANTED TO GO.
CHRIS: A FEW HARD STEPS.
SCOTT: THE 37-YEAR-OLD CAN
REALLY MOVE.
CHRIS: HE CAN REALLY TAKE
PITCHES NOW, TOO.
SCOTT: ONE OF THE BETTER STORIES
OF THE HITTING PROFILE SUDDENLY
EVOLVING AT SUCH A LATE AGE.
YULI GURRIEL WAS KNOWN AS A FREE
SWINGER, NOT A GUY WHO WOULD
TAKE WALKS.
ALL OF HE IS TAKING A TON OF
FREE PASSES.
IT WAS A NATURAL PROGRESSION OF
BEING AROUND TEAMMATES WHO TAKE
PITCHES.
IT IS ALMOST AS IF HE HAS ALWAYS
HAD IT IN THE ARSENAL AND HE
DECIDED AT AGE 37, HE WOULD SPIT
ON A FEW MORE PITCHES.
CHRIS: HE IS A GUY WHO COVERS SO
MUCH OF THE PLATE.
EARLY IN YOUR CAREER, YOU KNOW
YOU CAN COVER PITCHES OUTSIDE
THE ZONE.
SOMETIMES YOU HAVE TO KNOW WHEN
TO PASS THE BATON AND HE IS
LEARNING THAT WITH THIS OFFENSE.
HE HAS ALVAREZ BEHIND HIM.
IF THEY WANT TO WALK HIM, HE
WILL TAKE THE WALK AND ALVAREZ
WILL DRIVE HIM IN.
SCOTT: YORDAN ALVAREZ, THAT IS
WHY WE HAVE THE SHIFT TRACKER.
IT SHOWS US WHERE THE INFIELDERS
ARE AT ALL TIMES.
CHRIS: I AM CURIOUS TO SEE IF
THAT RULE WILL EVER GET CHANGED.
SCOTT: THE SHIFT?
CHRIS: THE SHIFT.
SCOTT: I THINK IT WILL AND I AM
DOWN FOR IT AT THIS POINT.
0-2.
CUT AND A MISS.
YORDAN ALVAREZ STRIKES OUT FOR
THE FIRST TIME TODAY.
CHRIS: I AM A SUPPORTER OF
KEEPING THE GUYS ON THE DIRT.
KEEP INFIELDERS ON THE INFIELD
AND OUTFIELDERS ON THE OUTFIELD.
IF YOU WANT MORE PRODUCTION, YOU
WANT MORE ACTION TO HAPPEN, THAT
IS A PRETTY EASY,
STRAIGHTFORWARD WAY TO GET IT
DONE.
SCOTT: REMEMBER, THE SHIFT DID
NOT WORK ANYWAY AGAINST YORDAN
FOR HIS BASE HIT ONE INNING AGO.
THE ASTROS UP THREE.
TUCKER WITH THE R.B.I. DOUBLE, A
TWO-RUN BLAST BY MARWIN GONZALEZ
IN THE 8 HOLE.
HERE IS THE SHORTSTOP CORREA.
2-0.
CHRIS: TALKING ABOUT THE ASTROS
OFFENSE A LITTLE MORE, A RUNNER
ON FIRST AND TWO OUTS, YOU
NORMALLY THINK THAT IS A LOW
STRESS INNING.
BUT WITH THIS ASTROS OFFENSE,
YOU NEVER GET A BREAK.
SCOTT: TALKER HAS BEEN THEIR
HOTTEST HITTER.
HE IS ON DECK.
CHRIS: MORALES WITH THE
CONSISTENT STRIKE ZONE, NOT
GIVING TOO MUCH, FORCING
EVERYTHING OVER THE PLATE.
YOU CAN TELL ANDERSON MIGHT BE
DISCOURAGED BY THAT.
HE WANTS THAT CALL, HE NEEDS THE
CALL.
RIGHT HERE, JUST BECAUSE IT IS
A3-0 COUNT, DO NOT EXPECT THE
CATCHER TO BE SET UP DOWN THE
MIDDLE.
IT IS A BORDERLINE PITCH, BUT IT
IS A BALL.
YOU HAVE A LOT OF UMPIRES WHO
WILL CALL THAT PITCH ON A 3-0,
2-1 COUNT.
SCOTT: THAT WAS RIGHT DOWN
BROADWAY.
THERE IS ROMP IN CREW.
GABE MORALES CALLING A NICE GAME
BEHIND THE PLATE.
-- THERE IS YOUR UMPIRING CREW.
CHRIS: AS A FAN OF THE GAME, I
WANT STRIKES TO BE STRIKES AND
BALLS TO BE BALLS.
IT SHOULD NOT MATTER WHO IS ON
THE MOUND AND -- WHO IS
HITTING.
SCOTT: YOU MEAN TOM GLAVINE GOT
SOME CALLS HE SHOULD NOT HAVE
GOTTEN?
BACKING UP IS KELENIC, HE HAS
PLENTY OF ROOM, AND THAT WILL
RETIRE THE SIDE.
CARLOS CORREA FLIES OUT.
THE ASTROS ARE HANGING ONTO A
3-2 LEAD AS WE GO INTO THE
FOURTH.
♪
>> HE JUST SMOKES IT.
>> FORGET ABOUT IT.
>> GREAT BASEBALL RIGHT THERE.
>> THAT ONE IS GOING TO GO!
>> THAT BALL WAS CRUSHED.
>> THIS IS GOING TO DO IT!
>> STRIKE THREE.
>> THAT WAS A GREAT PLAY.
>> TALKED ABOUT HIS FIELDING
SKILLS.
THAT WAS REMARKABLE.
♪
>> SOMETHING LIKE THIS IS WHAT
THEY CAME FOR.
>> LOU BROCK WAS A GREAT BASE
STEALER.
BUT TODAY, I AM THE GREATEST OF
ALL TIME.
THANK YOU.
>> MAY 1, 1991, RICKEY
HENDERSON, A CLASSIC SPEECH.
WHICH HALL OF FAMER WOULD YOU
HAVE LOVED TO HEAR MIC'D UP FOR
A GAME?
RICKY?
WILLIE MAYS?
YOU KNOW WE ARE PUTTING UP BIG
NAMES.
THIS IS ONE OF MY FAVORITE
YOUTUBE POLL QUESTIONS OF THE
YEAR.
GET INVOLVED RIGHT NOW.
HELP US OUT WITH THE POLL
ANSWER.
SUPER RELEVANT BECAUSE TODAY IS
THE HALL OF FAME INDUCTION
CEREMONY IN COOPERSTOWN.
LOOK AT THE BIG NAMES HEADING
IN, BEING ENSHRINED.
JETER, MARVIN MILLER, TED
SIMMONS, LARRY WALKER.
THAT IS ALL HAPPENING TODAY IN
COOPERSTOWN.
GOOD LUCK ANSWERING THIS YOUTUBE
POLL QUESTION.
THE ONLY REASON I AM GETTING
INVOLVED IS BASED ON THINKING
DEEPER INTO THE ANSWER.
HERE IS CRISTIAN JAVIER.
FOR ME, IT IS EASY TO GO WITH
RICKEY HENDERSON, BECAUSE YOU
KNOW HE WILL BE A WALKING
COMEDIAN IN THE DUGOUT.
I WANT TO HEAR HIM, INNINGS ONE
THROUGH NINE.
CHRIS: THERE ARE LEGENDS WHO ARE
GREAT STORYTELLERS.
I HAVE BEEN FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO
PERSONALLY KNOW RICKEY.
I WAS WITH OAKLAND.
I PERSONALLY KNOW WILLIE MAYS.
WHEN I WOULD GO TO PLAY THE
GIANTS WHEN I WAS IN ARIZONA,
FOR SOME REASON, WILLIE MAYS
TOOK A LIKING TO ME.
HE WOULD TAKE ME TO HIS HOUSE,
FEED ME, SHOW ME HIS M.V.P.'S,
GOLD GLOVE TROPHIES.
IF I HAD TO CHOOSE ONE, I AM
CHOOSING JACKIE ROBINSON.
I WANT TO HEAR THOSE STORIES AND
GAIN AS MUCH KNOWLEDGE AS
POSSIBLE.
SCOTT: YOU DEFINITELY CANNOT GO
WRONG.
THAT MAKES SENSE.
I KNOW A COUPLE OF THESE GUYS, I
WILL PUT THEM ASIDE BECAUSE WE
HAVE SPOKEN BEFORE.
DIDN'T YOU DO SOME WORK WITH ROD
CAREW?
CHRIS: I DID.
SCOTT: I WILL NAME DROP FOR YOU.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: JARRED KELENIC STRUCK OUT
ON THREE PITCHES.
THAT ONE IS SOCKED TO CENTER
FIELD OFF THE BAT OF TOM MURPHY.
QUICKLY, TWO UP AND TWO DOWN.
JAVIER TAKING OVER.
THE 24-YEAR-OLD LAST PITCHED
DURING A LOSS TO SAN DIEGO.
HE GAVE UP HOMERS TO MACHADO AND
WIL MYERS.
FORMER YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE
GAME, CRISTIAN JAVIER, EARLIER
IN THE YEAR.
JAVIER HAD A DOMINANT
PERFORMANCE AGAINST THE ANGELS.
AM I RIGHT?
TRUCK CREW?
CHRIS: FOR A GUY WHO THROWS SO
MANY STRIKES, THE ONLY THING
THAT GOT THE STARTER AND TROUBLE
WERE THE FIRST PITCHES.
HE WAS ONLY 3-15 WITH FIRST
PITCH STRIKES AND THAT ALLOWED
HIS PITCH COUNT TO GET UP FAIRLY
QUICKLY.
SCOTT: I WAS RIGHT.
IT WAS AGAINST THE ANGELS, FIVE
SHUTOUT INNINGS.
THE SLIDER IS THE MONEY PITCH
FOR JAVIER.
HE HAS ONE OF MY FAVORITE TERMS
FOR A PINCH, THE INVISIBALL.
THAT IS OFF THE BAT OF JOSE
MARMOLEJOS.
DEEP LEFT FIELD, AND IT IS OFF
THE TOP OF THE WALL!
IT IS A TWO-OUT DOUBLE FOR THE
MARINERS 9 HITTER.
CHRIS: THAT LEFT FIELD WALL IN
HOUSTON AND IN BOSTON, IT GIVETH
AND IT TAKETH AWAY.
A LOW LINE DRIVE BUT I THOUGHT
WOULD BE A HOMER WOULD HIT THE
WALL.
AND THEN YOU HAVE A LAZY FLY
BALL TO LEFT FIELD.
IT IS NORMALLY A ROUTINE NOW.
BUT SINCE IT IS ONLY 315 DOWN
THE LEFT-FIELD LINE, IT IS ABLE
TO HIT THE WALL AND TURN INTO A
DOUBLE.
SCOTT: FLIP THE LINEUP CARD BACK
TO THE LEADOFF MAN, J.P.
CRAWFORD.
YOU MENTIONED FENWAY PARK, THE
MONSTER FEELS CLOSE IN LEFT
FIELD.
SOMETIMES THE CRAWFORD BOXES
HAVE A SIMILAR FEEL.
IT IS A GOOD SPOT TO TARGET,
ESPECIALLY IF YOU ARE A RIGHTY
PULL HITTER.
CHRIS: THE EXPECTED BATTING
AVERAGE ON THAT BALL RIGHT THERE
IS .100.
I ASSUME IT IS BRINGING THOSE
TWO STADIUMS INTO PLAY.
IF I HIT THAT BALL, YOU BETTER
BELIEVE I WILL NOT FEEL GUILTY
OR BAD ABOUT IT.
I WILL TAKE THAT DOUBLE HOME
WITH ME.
SCOTT: YOU TOOK 11 HOMERS HOME
WITH YOU FROM THIS BALLPARK IN
32 GAMES.
WE ARE SHOWING YOU THE BATTING
AVERAGE WITH TWO OUTS AND
RUNNERS IN SCORING POSITION.
FOR CRAWFORD, IT IS AMONG THE
AL'S FINEST AT .385.
YOUR O.P.S. IN THIS PARK WAS
OVER 1.000.
CHRIS: I ALWAYS WANT TO PLAY
HERE.
WHEN I CAME HERE IS A MEMBER OF
THE VISITING TEAM, I LITERALLY
HAD TO BUY A SESSION FOR MY
FAMILY.
I ENJOYED -- I LITERALLY HAD TO
BUY A SECTION FOR MY FAMILY.
IT IS NOT TOO LATE.
SCOTT: LET'S RUN IT BACK.
CY IN  HOUSTON.
CHRIS: IF THEY CALL ME, I WILL
ANSWER.
I PROMISE.
SCOTT: CY IN MINUTE MAID PARK.
WOW.
IF I YOUTUBE CREATOR ASKS YOU
WHERE IS YOUR FAVORITE ROAD
BALLPARK --
CHRIS: THIS IS IT.
SCOTT: TWO ON FOR SEATTLE.
IT IS YOUR HOMETOWN, AND YOU
RAKED HERE.
CHRIS: SOMETIMES IT WOULD BE
SLIGHTLY STRESSFUL COMING HOME.
YOU WANT TO SEE EVERYBODY.
YOU ALSO WANT TO FOCUS ON YOUR
GAME, TRY TO GO OFF THERE AND
HAVE SUCCESS.
I ENJOYED THE EXTRA PRESSURE OF
HAVING MY FAMILY OUT THERE AND
FEELING LIKE I HAD TO DO
SOMETHING.
SCOTT: ONE THING YOUR AGENCY DID
WELL WAS SAY, OK, ASTROS MOVE TO
THE AMERICAN LEAGUE, WE WILL
MOVE C.Y. TO THE AMERICAN LEAGUE
SO HE CAN CONTINUE TO HIT IN
THIS BALLPARK MORE FREQUENTLY.
THERE IS A STRIKE FROM JAVIER.
IT IS THE NUMBER 2 HITTER, MITCH
HANIGER.
BRETT: I USED TO INTERVIEW THE
POST GAME PLAYER OF THE GAME.
I USED TO HAND THESE PLAYERS $50
CASH.
I PROBABLY GAVE HIM $300 AT
MINUTE MAID PARK.
CHRIS: I THINK IT WAS IN THE
FORM OF A GIFT CARD.
SEATTLE PUTTING ITSELF INTO
POSITION TO HAVE A BIG INNING.
SCOTT: VERY MUCH SO.
CRISTIAN JAVIER LABORING A
LITTLE BIT, NOW FACING THE MEATY
PART OF THE ORDER.
CHRIS: TALKING ABOUT THAT
INVISIBALL, HE IS A HIGH
PERCENTAGE FASTBALL GUY.
SOME GUYS ARE ABLE TO THROW A
FASTBALL, IT HAS SOME EXTRA
BACKSPIN, IT RISES THROUGH THE
ZONE.
AS A HITTER, YOU FEEL LIKE YOU
ARE ABOUT TO PUT THE BARREL ON
IT AND YOU WALK BACK TO THE
DUGOUT CONFUSED.
HOW DID THAT JUST HAPPEN?
SCOTT: IT IS FRUSTRATING FOR
THOSE UPPERCUT SWINGS.
HANIGER, GOING AFTER THE
INVISIBALL.
THANK YOU, MR. JAVIER.
A GOOD CLINIC ON THE PITCH THAT
MAKES CRISTIAN JAVIER SO
SPECIAL.
ASTROS UP ONE.
>> HANG ONTO THE ROOF!
>> THIS ONE IS OUT OF HERE!
>> MIDDLE OF THE INFIELD IS
BACK, HOPING TO TURN A DOUBLE
PLAY, CONCEDING THE TYING RUN.
>> ALTUVE DRIVES ONE DEEP TO
LEFT FIELD.
THAT IS GONE!
A WALKOFF SLAM!
JOSE ALTUVE!
>> ARE YOU SERIOUS?
WOW!
>> A WALKOFF GRAND SLAM FOR JOSE
ALTUVE!
WINS IT IN THE BOTTOM HALF OF
THE 10TH!
JOSE DRIVES ONE DEEP TO LEFT
FIELD.
YOU HAVE TO BE KIDDING ME!
SIX-RUN BOTTOM HALF OF THE
NINTH!
ALTUVE HAS DONE IT AGAIN!
MAYBE THE MOST IMPROBABLE
COMEBACK IN THE MAJOR LEAGUES
THIS YEAR!
>> UNBELIEVABLE.
SCOTT: IT IS CREATOR SPOTLIGHT
TIME.
WE FOCUS ON A YOUTUBE CONTENT
CREATOR.
TODAY, WE SHINE IT ON SECRET
BASE.
OVER 1.1 MILLION SUBSCRIBERS.
HE SPOKE TO US ON THE PREGAME
SHOW.
HE LOVES THE METS.
HE GAVE US A FEW CHANNEL
DESCRIPTIONS.
ENDY CHAVEZ HOME RUN ROBBERY.
2006 NLCS GAME 7 AT SHEA
STADIUM.
WE ARE LOOKING FOR SOME
QUESTIONS FOR LANCE MCCULLERS
JR. WHEN HE JOINS US SOON ON
YOUTUBE.
3-2, ASTROS IN FRONT.
LAST GAME BETWEEN THESE TWO IN
THE SEASON SERIES.
TYLER ANDERSON MATCHING UP
AGAINST KYLE TUCKER.
HERE IS LANCE MCCULLERS JR.,
JOINING US FOR THIS HALF INNING.
GREAT TO TALK TO YOU.
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
LANCE: I AM DOING WELL.
SCOTT: DOING REALLY WELL.
WATCHING KYLE TUCKER IN THE 6
SPOT, LOOK LIKE A 2 OR 3 HITTER
FOR ANYONE ELSE.
IT IS TWISTING, THAT IS IN
FAIRGROUND!
KYLE TUCKER HEADING FOR THIRD
AND HE IS SAFE!
YOU DO NOT SEE THAT EVERY DAY.
CHRIS: WHAT A WAY TO START THE
INNING!
SCOTT: THERE IS YOUR LAUNCH
ANGLE!
WHAT WILL THAT NUMBER LOOK LIKE?
LANCE: SOMEWHERE IN THE 40 TO 48
RANGE.
SCOTT: I WILL GET THAT NUMBER IN
A SECOND.
LANCE: THE FIRST GUY I SAW HIT
ONE OFF THE GATES WAS COLBY
RASMUS.
NOBODY HAD SEEN ONE HIT OFF THE
BEAMS.
AFTER 15, 16, THEY STARTED
HITTING THEM PRETTY OFTEN.
SCOTT: THAT WAS TRULY A
MOONSHOT.
CHRIS: THAT IS A TOUGHER PLAY
THAN PEOPLE GIVE IT CREDIT FOR
FOR HANIGER.
YOU ARE RUNNING FULL SPEED TO
THE LINE, IT LOOKS LIKE THE BALL
CHANGES DIRECTION.
THERE IS NO FOUL TERRITORY.
ALL YOU SEE IS THE WALL.
IT IS VERY DIFFICULT TO GAUGE
WHEN YOU NEED TO SLOW DOWN.
YOU SEE THE BALL HAVING THAT
EFFECT COMING BACK.
LANCE: I THINK THAT IS AN
IMPOSSIBLE PLAY.
I DO NOT THINK HANIGER COULD DO
MUCH RIGHT THERE.
SCOTT: IT LOOKED LIKE IT
COMPLETELY CHANGED DIRECTIONS
FOR MITCH HANIGER AND THE
RIGHT-FIELD CORNER.
AND THEN, HE GRABS THE BASEBALL
BEFORE IT COULD POTENTIALLY HAVE
ENDED UP IN THE SEATS.
IT COULD HAVE BEEN A GROUND RULE
DOUBLE, AND IT ENDS UP BEING A
LEADOFF TRIPLE.
IT LOOKS LIKE THEY WILL REVIEW
THINGS AND MAKE SURE IT DID NOT
HIT ONE OF THOSE RAILS.
WOW!
CHRIS: IT DOES NOT LOOK LIKE IT
HIT THE RAIL.
IT IS ONE OF THE SITUATIONS
WHERE IF YOU ARE HANIGER, YOU
ARE RUNNING OUT OF ROOM SO FAST,
YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND THE BALL
HAS A FALLING EFFECT, IT FALLS
IN THE OPPOSITE DIRECTION.
LANCE: IF IT HITS THE ROOF IN
FAIR TERRITORY, IT IS A FAIR
BALL.
I THINK THIS ONE WILL STAY PUT.
CHRIS: IT NORMALLY ONLY COMES
INTO PLAY IN STADIUMS LIKE
TAMPA.
>> WE HAVE SEEN IT A COUPLE OF
TIMES.
RAFAEL DEVERS HIT ONE UP THERE
OFF THE BEAM.
I HAVE SEEN COLBY RASMUS HIT A
COUPLE UP THERE.
YOU SEE SOME HIT UP THERE, LIKE
IN THE FOUL GROUND, RIGHT AROUND
THIRD BASE.
THE ONES OUT THERE IN RIGHT
FIELD, YOU HAVE TO GET IT REALLY
SQUARED, YOU HAVE TO HIT IT
SUPERHIGH.
I DON'T KNOW HOW HIGH THAT WAS,
BUT IT IS TOUGH.
SCOTT: ARE YOU READY FOR THIS
LAUNCH ANGLE?
55 DEGREES.
LANCE: HE BARRELED IT.
SCOTT: HE BARRELED IT STRAIGHT
UP AND IT TURNED INTO A TRIPLE.
SHOWING ALL THE REPLAYS WE HAVE
FOR YOU.
I DON'T KNOW.
CHRIS: I DON'T SEE ANY CHANGE OF
DIRECTION.
>> THEY MIGHT BE REVIEWING IF
THE FAN TOUCHED IT.
SCOTT: WHICH WOULD TURN IT INTO
A GROUND RULE DOUBLE.
CHRIS: IT SEEMS LIKE THEY ARE
TRYING TO REVIEW IF IT IS A
DOUBLE OR TRIPLE.
SCOTT: YOU TWO CREATORS, WE WILL
TAKE YOUR QUESTIONS FOR LANCE.
HE IS SAFE AT THIRD BASE.
IT IS ALL GOOD.
THIS WAS THE FAN PORTION OF IT.
THE FAN REACHES OVER, BUT IT
LANDS IN THE GLOVE OF MITCH
HANIGER.
GOOD THING FOR THE ASTROS SIDE
THAT HE DID NOT GRAB THE
BASEBALL, BECAUSE KYLE TUCKER
GETS AN EXTRA-BASE OUT OF IT.
IT IS A HIT.
YOU CANNOT CHARGE AN ERROR
AGAINST THE RIGHT FIELDER
ON THAT ONE.
JAKE MEYERS WILL DIG IN.
NOW WE CAN HAVE A NORMAL
CONVERSATION AS MEYERS TAKES A
PITCH OUTSIDE.
WE HAVE TO START WITH THE SLIDER
AND HOW IT HAS PROGRESSED.
I CALLED YOUR GAME A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO ON YOUTUBE AND I WAS
READING ABOUT HOW THE PITCHING
STAFF OR THE PITCHING COACHES
SAID, LET'S TAKE IT EASY ON THE
SLIDER AND SEE HOW IT LOOKS.
NOW, THEY ARE LIKE, USE IT
HOWEVER YOU WANT.
CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THE
PROGRESSION?
LANCE: IT IS SOMETHING I HAVE
ONE TO THROW FOR A COUPLE YEARS.
I HAD NOT COMMITTED TO IT EARLY
IN CAMP TO GET THE REPS.
LAST YEAR, IN THE ALCS, I GIVE
UP A COUPLE HOMERS ON SOME GOOD
CURVEBALLS.
IT REALLY MADE ME FEEL LIKE I
NEED TO MIX IT UP A LITTLE BIT
TO THE RIGHTIES WITH THE WAY MY
PITCH GROUPS LOOKED.
THE SLIDER, KIND OF MIRRORING.
IT GIVES ME THE ABILITY TO
ATTACK IF I AM BEHIND.
I CAN CHALLENGE GUYS IN THE ZONE
AND GET GOOD RESULTS, TRY TO GO
DEEPER INTO GAMES.
IT HAS BECOME A PITCH I FEEL
COMES WHAT THROWING.
SEATTLE TRIED TO STACK THE
LEFTIES AGAINST ME, THEY DON'T
WANT MUCH TO DO WITH THE SLIDER.
IT HAS BEEN A BIG WEAPON FOR ME.
SCOTT: DOES THE SLIDER HAVE A
NAME FOR THE NATIONAL AUDIENCE?
THE CURVEBALL IS THE SNAPDRAGON.
LANCE: ME AND COLLIN MCHUGH HAD
A JOKE, THAT IS WHAT WE CALL
CURVEBALLS IN GENERAL.
WE WOULD SAY THROW THE BANGER.
NO OFFICIAL NAME YET.
COLLIN THROWS A SIMILAR PITCH.
IT IS DISGUSTING.
YOU SEE WHAT HE IS DOING WITH
TAMPA BAY.
WHEN THEY COME HERE IN LATE
SEPTEMBER, WE WILL HAVE TO HAVE
A FORMAL DISCUSSION.
CHRIS: LANCE, CHRIS, HERE.
YOU WERE A GUY, WHEN I WAS ON
THE OPPOSITE TEAM, I LOVED GOING
AGAINST YOU.
I WAS CURIOUS, HOW FAMILIAR ARE
YOU WITH YOUR PITCH PERCENTAGES
AND YOUR NUMBERS THROUGHOUT HIS
SEASON?
WE WOULD HAVE SCOUTING REPORTS
ON YOU AND SAY, ANY TIME THIS
GUY IS IN A HITTER'S COUNT, YOU
ARE GOING TO GET A BREAKING BALL
SO SELL OUT AGAINST THE BREAKING
BALL.
IN THOSE SITUATIONS, YOU WOULD
THROW US FASTBALLS.
HOW AWARE OF YOUR NUMBERS AND
HOW MUCH ARE YOU STARTING THAT
AND KNOWING HOW THE OTHER TEAM
IS APPROACHING YOU WHEN YOU
PITCH?
LANCE: IN THIS DAY AND AGE,
THERE IS SO MUCH INFORMATION FOR
BOTH SIDES.
YOU TRY TO KEEP THE OTHER TEAM
GUESSING.
THERE IS NO MYSTERY.
IF YOU ARE LEFTY, I WILL THROW
YOU A GOOD AMOUNT OF BREAKING
BALLS.
IF YOU ARE A RIGHTY, YOU WILL
GET SLIDERS.
THERE ARE GAMES WHERE IF I'M
FEELING GOOD, I CAN THROW THE
CHANGE OF 20% OR 25% OF THE
TIME, THAT WOULD THROW A WRENCH
IN THE TEAM'S PLANS SCOTT:.
SCOTT:MORMON GONZALEZ BOUNCES
OUT.
TWO DOWN, WITH TUCKER AT THIRD.
LANCE: I TRY TO STRETCH THE ZONE
A LITTLE BIT.
IF YOU ARE OUT IN FRONT OF THE
PLATE, YOU EXPECT MORE OF A
CHANGEUP.
THE CUTTER UP AND AWAY, 88 TO
91.
I ADDED THE CUTTER LATE LAST
YEAR, I FELT LIKE I WAS NOT
GETTING THE LOOK I WANTED FROM
LEFTIES.
IF I AM FACING A TEAM AND I SAY,
THIS IS THE GAME PLAN.
THE OTHER DAY, I WAS FACING TY
FRANCE, HE HAS A FANTASTIC
SEASON WITH MEN IN SCORING
POSITION.
I ATTACKED HIM WITH SOME TWOS
BECAUSE I FELT THE SLIDER WAS
SOMETHING HE WAS LOOKING FOR.
SCOTT: A NICE RECOVERY FROM
TYLER ANDERSON AFTER THE
LEADOFF TRIPLE.
LANCE: THANKS.
SCOTT: LANCE MCCULLERS JR.,
GREAT COMBO, GREAT GAME PREPPER.
IT IS 3-2, ASTROS LEAD IT AFTER
FOUR.
>> WHETHER HE IS RESCUING
HOMELESS ANIMALS OR WORKING WITH
AT RISK YOUNG PEOPLE, LANCE
MCCULLERS JR. IS DRIVEN BY A
PHRASE HE HAS DRIVEN BY 1000
TIMES.
LANCE: THERE IS A BRIDGE IN
HOUSTON AND IT IS PAINTED ON
THEIR, "BE SOMEONE."
>> IT IS A CORE VALUE OF LANCE
MCCULLERS JR..
HE HAS IT TATTOOED ON HIS ARM,
JUST BELOW THE ASTRONAUT, WORLD
SERIES TROPHY AND HOUSTON
SKYLINE.
LANCE: THAT AREA OF MY ARM IS
DEDICATED TO THE AREA OF
HOUSTON.
>> MORE OFTEN THAN NOT, WHEN
LANCE MCCULLERS JR. IS GIVING
BACK, A COMPANY THAT INVENTED
ONE OF THE MOST UNIQUE BASEBALL
RELATED PRODUCTS IS SUPPORTING
HIM.
DUGOUT MUGS MAKES CUSTOMIZED
BASEBALL BAT DRINKING MUGS.
LANCE: ANYTIME A MUG OF MIND'S
SPOT, THERE ARE PROCEEDS DONATED
TO THE FOUNDATION.
SCOTT: THE FIRST YEAR TRADITION
CONTINUES WE HAVE GIVEN OUR
VIEWERS THE POWER TO VOTE WHICH
STANDOUT PERFORMER WILL RECEIVE
THE YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME
TROPHY.
WE WILL HAVE POLLING OPTIONS.
YOU CAN HELP US HANDOUT SOME
HARDWARE IMMEDIATELY AFTER THE
GAME COMES TO A CLOSE.
LAST WEEK, LOGAN WEBB.
WHICH HALL OF FAMER WOULD YOU
HAVE LOVED TO HEAR MIC'D UP AND
AGAIN?
BABE RUTH WINS IT.
THIS WAS AN ULTIMATE CLASH OF
FOUR LEGENDS.
YOU CANNOT GO WRONG.
CHRIS: YOU CANNOT GO WRONG.
THERE WILL BE A LOT OF HISTORY,
NO MATTER WHO YOU SEE OUT THERE.
BABE RUTH WILL HAVE SOME GREAT
STORIES FROM BACK IN THE DAY.
WAY BACK.
SCOTT: THAT IS IN THE DIRT FROM
CRISTIAN JAVIER AS WE START OUT
THE FIFTH INNING WITH SEAGER,
FRANCE AND TORO, TRAILING BY A
RUN.
SEAGER WITH AN INFIELD HIT AND A
WALK.
HE SCORED BACK IN THE FIRST.
WE ALSO HAD FOUR VERY DIFFERENT
PERSONALITIES.
NOT THAT I KNOW ANY OF THEM --
YOU DO.
CHRIS: [LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: WE DON'T KNOW BABE.
WE HEAR STORIES.
I'M SURE ON CERTAIN DAYS, BABE
WAS VERY ENTERTAINING.
CHRIS: RICKEY TELL SOME GREAT
STORIES, TOO.
AND THE FACT YOU ARE TALKING IN
THIRD PERSON.
SCOTT: THAT IS WHAT SOLD IT FOR
ME.
RICKEY WOULD BE NARRATING AND
PLAYING TO THE YOUTUBE CROWD.
CHRIS: RICKEY WOULD HAVE STOLE
SECOND AND THIRD, IF RICKEY DID
NOT GO DEEP.
RICKEY WOULD HAVE PROBABLY GONE
DEEP.
SCOTT: THAT IS WHAT I AM LOOKING
FOR.
SEAGER LAYS OFF THE 2-1.
IT IS 3-1.
KYLE SEAGER IS ONLY HITTING .212
, BUT HE IS UP TO 34 HOME RUNS
THIS SEASON, 18 AND THE SECOND
HALF OF THE YEAR.
AND HE WALKS FOR THE SECOND TIME
IN A ROW.
STATCAST POWERED BY GOOGLE
CLOUD.
THIS WILL TELL A SIMPLE STORY
FOR US.
KYLE SEAGER LIKES TO PULL THE
BASEBALL FOR HIS POWER.
28 PULLED HOME RUNS.
CHRIS: I AM OK WITH THAT AS A
PLAYER.
WHAT THAT TELLS ME IS HE KNOWS
WHAT HIS APPROACH IS.
HE KNOWS THE CALIBER OF PLAYER
HE IS AND HOW HE WILL BE THE
MOST SUCCESSFUL AT THE PLATE.
SOME GUYS, IF THEY TRY TO HIT
THE BALL THE OTHER WAY, IF HE
TRIES TO HIT SINGLES DOWN THE
LEFT-FIELD LINE, HE MIGHT LOSE
THAT STRENGTH.
HE UNDERSTANDS HIS STRENGTH AND
TRIES TO PULL THE BALL OUT OF
THE YARD.
TY FRANCE IS HAVING A CAREER
SEASON.
BRETT: HE GOT THE OPPOSITE FIELD
BASE HIT IN THE FIRST INNING.
SCOTT SERVAIS TOLD US HE USES
THE WHOLE FIELD AS GOOD AS ANY
RIGHT-HANDED HITTER HE HAS SEEN
IN A LONG TIME.
C.Y. BROUGHT UP PLAYING FOR TONY
GWYNN AT SAN DIEGO STATE.
GWYNN USED TO GIVE HIM A DECAL
FOR THE BACK OF HIS HELMET EVERY
TIME HE GOT AN OPPOSITE FIELD
BASE HIT.
YOU WONDER IF THE THOUGHT THAT
TRAINING FROM TONY GWYNN STICKS
WITH HIM TODAY.
EVEN IF YOU GO BACK TO A COUPLE
OF YEARS AGO, WHEN FRANCE GOT
CALLED UP MID-AUGUST TO SAN
DIEGO FROM EL PASO, HE WAS
HITTING .399.
NO ONE HIT .400 IN THE PCL SINCE
THE 1930'S.
THE LAST GUY IN THE BIG LEAGUES
TO CHASE .400 WAS TONY GWYNN IN
1994.
HE HAD TO SETTLE FOR .394.
SCOTT: THAT IS GREAT STUFF.
I CALLED THE TRIPLE-A ALL-STAR
GAME THAT YEAR.
I KNOW THERE ARE SOME BIG-TIME
NUMBERS AND TRIPLE-A, BUT IS HE
REALLY HITTING .399?
WHO IS THIS GUY?
HE WAS BARELY RECEIVING ANY
ATTENTION.
CHRIS: HE IS ONE OF MY FAVORITE
TYPES OF PLAYERS.
A BIG GUY WHO IS JUST TRYING TO
GET HITS.
IT TELLS ME HE WILL DEVELOP THAT
TOWER.
HE HAS 15, 16 HOME RUNS BUT THAT
POWER WILL CONTINUE TO RISE.
AS LONG AS HE CONTINUES TO GET
HITS, HE WILL INTRODUCE THE
POWER.
THE MAJORITY OF THE TIME, TAKING
YOUR HIT IS WHAT THE TEAM NEEDS.
SCOTT: SCOTT: CHASING SOME HIGH
CHEESE.
MEYERS CHASING IT, HE HAS THE
BASEBALL.
NOW HEADING BACK TO FIRST AND IN
THERE SAFELY IS KYLE SEAGER.
JAKE MEYERS WITH THE CLOSING
SPEED.
WHAT A CATCH!
CHRIS: WHAT A GREAT PLAY.
YOU WOULD ASSUME THAT IS A LEFT
FIELDERS BALL.
WITH ALL THOSE LITTLE CUTOUTS AT
MINUTE MAID PARK, YOU NEED ONE
PERSON TO TAKE CHARGE.
MEYERS PROBABLY CALLED THAT BALL
EARLY.
THEY HAVE A TRUST OUT THERE
AMONG OUTFIELDERS.
SCOTT: HE STUMBLED, TOO, AND
KIND OF DISAPPEARED ON US.
CHRIS: THAT IS A GUTSY PLAY.
SCOTT: THIS IS WHERE STATCAST
REALLY HELPS US OUT.
THE PERCENTAGE CHANCE ON A BALL
HIT THAT WAY IN TERMS OF EXIT
VELOCITY, LAUNCH ANGLE, HOW
OFTEN DOES HE GET CAUGHT?
10% OF THE TIME.
THAT IS AN ELITE CATCH OUT THERE
IN CENTER FIELD.
CHRIS: THAT WALL IS VERY SCARY
WHEN YOU ARE A CENTER FIELDER
RUNNING DIRECTLY AT IT.
IF THAT BALL IS FIVE FEET TO THE
RIGHT, IT IS PROBABLY A DOUBLE
OFF THE WALL.
SCOTT: HE WENT 168, SPRINT SPEED
AT 29.5.
THIS GOES BACK TO THE DISCUSSION
OF, WHO IS GOING TO BE YOUR GUY
IN CENTER FIELD FOR THE
POSTSEASON?
CHAS MCCORMICK AND JAKE MEYERS
OUT THERE LATELY.
DUSTY BAKER TOLD US THIS MORNING
THERE IS MORE EXPERIENCE FOR
MEYERS AND CENTER AND I COULD
MAKE THE DIFFERENCE, ESPECIALLY
WHEN YOU THINK OF POSTSEASON
BASEBALL, WHEN DEFENSE IS
AMPLIFIED.
CHRIS: DUSTY SAID HE HAS MORE
EXPERIENCE IN CENTER FIELD, HE
HITS LEFTIES SLIGHTLY BETTER,
MCCORMICK HAS THE EDGE ON THE
POWER.
WHEN YOU HAVE TWO GUYS WERE
HITTING COMPARABLE, AND A
PLAYOFF SITUATION, YOU WILL LEAN
TOWARD WHO WILL PLAY BETTER
DEFENSE.
WHEN THE PLAYOFFS COME AROUND,
PITCHING AND DEFENSE IS WHAT
WINS GAMES FOR YOU.
SCOTT: THE ASTROS ARE THE BEST
IN BASEBALL.
CLEARLY, DEFENSE MATTERS TO THIS
TEAM.
THEY HAVE THE FORMULA.
CHRIS: TRYING TO GET THOSE 27
OUTS AS FAST AS POSSIBLE AND AS
EFFICIENT AS POSSIBLE.
SCOTT: CORREA GOES THE SHORT WAY
AND RETIRES THE SIDE.
GOOD PITCHING AND STRONG DEFENSE
AND CENTER FROM THE ROOKIE.
ASTRO STILL UP, 3-2.
♪
>> >> HERE COME THE MEN OF THE
HOUR, MARK MCGWIRE, WHO IS 0-1.
SITTING ON 61 HOME RUNS.
DOWN THE LEFT-FIELD LINE!
IS IT ENOUGH?
GONE!
THERE IT IS!
62!
TOUCH FIRST, MARK.
YOU ARE THE NEW SINGLE-SEASON
HOME RUN KING!
PEOPLE CANNOT IMAGINE WHAT THOSE
TWO HAVE BEEN THROUGH IN 1998.
TWO MEN FROM COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT BACKGROUNDS JOINED
TOGETHER IN 1998 IN THE ROGER
MARIS CHASE.
IT IS MARK MCGWIRE WHO GETS TO
THE TOP OF THE MOUNTAIN, HOME
RUN NUMBER 62, IN THE CARDINALS
145TH GAME OF THE YEAR.
SCOTT: WE ARE IN THE HOME FIFTH,
ASTROS LEAD IT 3-2.
DUSTY BAKER IS INCHING CLOSER TO
THIS EXCLUSIVE CLUB.
YOU NEED 2000 TO GET BY THE
BOUNCER.
THIS IS A SNEAK PEEK AT THE 2000
WIN CLUB.
SOME DRESS FANCY, SOME ARE IN
THEIR GAME UNIFORMS.
CHRIS: EVERYONE IS LEGENDARY.
DUSTY IS 70 A GREAT SEASON WITH
THE ASTROS.
I WAS SO HAPPY TO SEE HIM GET
ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY TO MANAGE.
YOU DO NOT NORMALLY SEE THESE
VETERAN GUYS STILL MANAGING
BALL.
FROM A.J. HINCH TO DUSTY BAKER,
THOSE ARE TWO GUYS WHO WORK VERY
DIFFERENT WAYS.
DUSTY BAKER IS THE ULTIMATE
PLAYERS MANAGER.
HE EARNS THE TRUST OF HIS
PLAYERS AS SOON AS HE WALKS INTO
THE ROOM.
IF YOU ARE A PLAYER, WHEN DUSTY
SPEAKS, YOU LISTEN.
AT 72 YEARS OLD, I AM HAPPY HE
IS GETTING THIS OPPORTUNITY.
HE BELONGS IN THE HALL OF FAME.
SCOTT: HE WANTS A WORLD SERIES
TITLE AS A MANAGER.
STILL GOING AFTER THAT TO
SOLIDIFY THE HALL OF FAME CASE.
CHRIS: MOST WINS WITHOUT A WORLD
SERIES.
SCOTT: THERE IT IS.
CHRIS: 1,973 GAMES.
SCOTT: INCREDIBLE.
CHRIS: HE HAS HAD SOME PRETTY
GOOD TEAMS, AS WELL.
SCOTT: HE MANAGED THE TALENTED
WASHINGTON NATIONALS BALLCLUB.
CHICAGO CUBS, BACK IN THE DAY.
RIGHT NOW, THIS HOUSTON ASTROS
TEAM IS SUPERSTRONG IN EVERY
CATEGORY.
ALTUVE, THE LEADOFF MAN, HOMERED
YESTERDAY.
THAT IS RIPPED.
DOES HE HAVE IT ON BACK-TO-BACK
DAYS?
HE DOES!
JOSE ALTUVE DID NOT HOMER FOR
ABOUT A MONTH.
GOES LONG YESTERDAY, DOUBLES UP
THIS AFTERNOON!
IT IS NUMBER 27 ON THE SEASON.
IT MAKES IT 4-2, HOUSTON.
CHRIS: HE IS KNOWN TO PULL THE
BALL.
HE IS NOT THE SAME HITTER HE WAS
YEARS AGO, TRYING TO HIT THE
BALL THE OTHER WAY.
HE IS GOING UP THERE TRYING TO
DO DAMAGE.
HE IS ABLE TO DRIVE IT OUT OF
THE YARD RIGHT THERE.
PROBABLY 316 FEET, I WOULD SAY.
IT IS ALL HE NEEDED.
SCOTT: THAT IS ONLY A HOME RUN
IN ONE STEADY IN THE MAJOR
LEAGUES.
I AM NOT JUST STAYING THAT.
CHRIS: THAT IS NOT A HOMER IN
BOSTON.
THAT WOULD POTENTIALLY BE A
SINGLE IF THE LEFT FIELDER KNOWS
HOW TO PLAY IT OFF THE WALL.
IT IS NOT ABOUT HOW FAR IT GOES.
SCOTT: FIRST ROW, CRAWFORD
BOXES, HOMER FOR ALTUVE.
AND NOW A ROLLER FOR ABRAHAM
TORO TO CLEAN UP.
A VETERAN GROUP.
A CORE FOR A WHILE FOR
HOUSTON.
FIVE TEAMS MANAGED BY DUSTY IN
24 SEASONS.
A GOOD LOOK AT A SAN FRANCISCO
GIANTS TEAM THAT MADE IT TO THE
WORLD SERIES.
HE'S JUST BEEN NOT ONLY A SMOO
TH, EXPERIENCED VOICE IN THE
CLUBHOUSE, BUT REALLY A STRONG
AMBASSADOR FOR THE BALLCLUB.
AS YULI GURRIEL TAKES THE 1-0.
2-0.
CHRIS: HE IS ONE OF THOSE
MANAGERS TO WEAR AS A PLAYER YOU
ARE ABLE TO GAIN THAT TRUST
RIGHT AWAY BECAUSE YOU KNOW HE
WILL TELL YOU EXACTLY HOW IT IS.
IF YOU ARE NOT HIS GUY, HE WILL
LET YOU KNOW HAVE TO EARN THIS
SPOT.
HE IS GOING TO LOOK OUT FOR YOU
AND PUT YOU OUT THERE NO MATTER
WHAT.
IF YOU HAVE SOME STRUGGLES, HE
IS GOING TO STICK WITH YOU
BECAUSE HE UNDERSTANDS FOR US TO
WIN, YOU HAVE TO GO.
HE HAS MANAGED SOME GOOD
BALLCLUBS, BENT UP THE
POSTSEASON MULTIPLE TIMES.
-- BEEN TO THE POSTSEASON
MULTIPLE TIMES PER THE WORLD
SERIES IS A COINCIDENCE.
PURE COINCIDENCE IT IS REALLY
HARD TO WIN A WORLD SERIES.
EVERYBODY HAS TO BE HOT AT THE
RIGHT TIME.
IF THAT DOES NOT HAPPEN YOU DO
NOT WIN THE WORLD SERIES.
PART OF THE GAME.
SCOTT: FOUR PITCH BASE ON BALLS,
FOR YULI GURRIEL.
THIS COPYRIGHTED TELECAST IS
PRESENTED BY THE OFFICE OF
COMMISSIONER OF BASEBALL AND MAY
NOT BE RETRANSMITTED IN ANY FORM
OR TO ANY DESCRIPTIONS OF THIS
GAME MAY NOT BE DISSEMINATED
WITHOUT EXPRESS WRITTEN CONSENT.
[CAPTIONS MADE POSSIBLE BY MLB
NETWORK]
[CAPTIONING PERFORMED BY THE
NATIONAL CAPTIONING INSTITUTE,
WHICH IS RESPONSIBLE FOR ITS
CAPTION CONTENT AND ACCURACY.
VISIT NCICAP.ORG]
NOW YORDAN ALVAREZ, ONE OUT AND
ONE OUT.
I MENTIONED AMBASSADOR FOR DUSTY
FOR THIS TEAM, BECAUSE THEY HAD
TO WEATHER THE STORM OF THE SIGN
STEALING SCANDAL FROM A COUPLE
YEARS AGO.
HE HAD TO DEAL WITH A LOT OF
THOSE QUESTIONS WHEN HE WASN'T
HERE.
ALVAREZ IS, A FOUL BALL HOOKED
TO THE RIGHT SIDE.
ANOTHER HARD HIT BASEBALL OFF
THE BAT OF THE ASTROS CLEANUP
HITTER, BUT DUSTY IS A GUY WHO
HAD THE RIGHT ANSWERS TO HELP
THEM GET THROUGH THINGS.
EVEN LAST YEAR WE WENT OVER SOME
OF THE ADVERSITY THEY DEALT
WITH.
THEY WERE ONE WIN AWAY FROM THE
WORLD SERIES WITH DUSTY RUNNING
THE SHIP.
THAT IS A BAD YEAR IN HOUSTON.
THIS TEAM HAS BEEN ON SOME RUN
FOR A LONG TIME NOW.
CHRIS: I'M VVERY -CURIOUS- VERY
CURIOUS AFTER THIS YEAR WITH THE
ASTROS DECIDE TO DO WITH DUSTY
BAKER.
HOW MANY MORE YEARS WILL HE GET
THE OPPORTUNITY TO MANAGE, OR
WILL HE WALK AWAY?
SCOTT: HOW MANY YEARS DOES HE
WANT TO MANAGE?
HE SAYS HE WANTS TO KEEP
ROLLING.
GREAT BALLCLUB TO LEAVE.
RUNNERS GOING.
PITCH IS HIT HARD OFF THE BAT
OF ALVAREZ AND RIGHT TO HANIGER.
HE'S COMING FOR FIRST AND HE'S
GOING TO MISS HIM.
TY FRANCE DID NOT NAIL THE TAG
DOWN ON GURRIEL.
JUST ONE OUT BUT A GOOD TRY BY
HANIGER, WHO HAS AN EXCELLENT
ARM IN RIGHT FIELD.
CHRIS: GREAT JOB BY GURRIEL
KEEPING HIS HEAD ON A SWIVEL.
YOU ARE TRYING TO STEAL THAT
BASE.
YOU'LL SEE HE PEEKS.
OH, I GOTTA GET BACK.
AND LUCKILY THE THROW WAS JUST A
LITTLE BIT UP THE BASELINE.
HE WAS ABLE TO GET BACK AND
EVADE THE TAG BARELY.
SCOTT: LOOK AT THIS AVOIDANCE BY
YULI GURRIEL.
DON'T TOUCH ME.
THAT UNIFORM, IT IS A GOOD CLEAN
-- NEEDS A GOOD CLEANING NOW.
CHRIS: THAT IS WHAT YOU WANT IS
A PLAYER.
YOU GOT TO GET DIRTY.
SCOTT: THERE WAS A LOT OF
DISCUSSION EARLIER IN THE
COMMENTARY ABOUT THE MARINERS
UNIFORMS.
SPORTS GAMING UNIVERSE SAID
THESE MANNERS --  MARINERS ALT
JERSEYS HAVE TO BE ALL OF ONE OF
MY FAVORITES.
MAKES ME THINK OF GRIFFEY JR.
WHEN THEY HAD SOME SUCCESS LATER
ON.
"THAT'S THE MAGIC OF THE
NORTHWEST GREEN JERSEYS."
LOVE THEM.
IS THAT TEAL?
IF WE ARE GETTING FANCY.
CHRIS: IT IS JUST CLASSIC.
IT DOES REMIND YOU OF GRIFFITH.
REMINDS YOU OF THE KID WITH HIS
HAT BACKWARDS.
SCOTT: COOLEST CUSTOMER IN THE
BIG-LEAGUES.
ALMOST A COUPLE DECADES.
THIS MARINERS BALLCLUB TRYING TO
GET BACK TO THE PLAYOFFS FOR THE
FIRST TIME SINCE 2001.
THEY ARE THREE GAMES AWAY FROM A
PLAYOFF SPOT, THAT SECOND
WILD-CARD ENTERING THE DAY.
HOUSTON AT 81-57, 6 .5 GAMES UP
ON SECOND PLACE SEATTLE IN THE
DIVISION.
TYLER ANDERSON 73 PITCHES.
IS HE GOING TO PICK ON YULI
AGAIN?
FOUL BALL.
CHRIS: HOPEFULLY I DO NOT JINX
ANDERSON.
BUT HE GOES A LITTLE BIT AGAINST
THE GRAIN OF TODAY'S GAME.
IN THAT THIRD TIME AROUND THE
LINEUP, O.P.S. DOES NOT GO UP
AGAINST HIM.
HE'S ABLE TO GET TO THE LINEUP
THREE TIMES, AND GUYS
CONSISTENTLY BE AROUND THE SAME
NUMBERS, AS OPPOSED TO ODORIZZI
YESTERDAY.
THERE WAS A LITTLE CONFLICT
AFTER THE GAME BECAUSE HE WAS
PULLED AFTER ONLY 60
SOMETHING PITCHES, IT WASN'T A
LOT OF PITCHES.
SCOTT: 66 PITCHES.
HE SAID IF NOT I WOULD BE THE
SUBJECT.
BASICALLY SAID 66 PITCHES
THROUGH FIVE.
TRYING TO INFER HE SHOULD'VE
PITCHED LONGER.
HE IS A VETERAN ON THE MOUND.
HE VOICED HIS OPINION AND HE
CHATTED WITH THE FRONT OFFICE
AND THE COACHING STAFF TO CLEAR
THINGS UP.
BUT THESE ARE KIND OF LIKE
PLAYOFF GAMES.
THIS IS THE LAST GAME OF THE
SEASON.
AND LOOK AT CARLOS CORREA
CONNECT INTO RIGHT FIELD.
TWO OUT SINGLE.
ASTROS IN BUSINESS IN THE FIFTH.
WITH KYLE TUCKER COMING UP.
2-2 TODAY WITH A DOUBLE AND A
TRIPLE.
CHRIS: A QUICK VISIT.
THEY DO HAVE SOMEBODY UP IN THE
BULLPEN.
SCOTT: YOU SAID, I DO NOT WANT
TO JAMES HIM.-- TO JINX HIM.
CHRIS: I THOUGHT ABOUT NOT
SAYING IT.
BECAUSE EVERY TIME YOU SAY
SOMETHING HE COMES BACK AND
BITES YOU.
BUT BECAUSE OF THE NUMBER SAYING
HE CANNOT GET TO THE LINE OF
THREE TIMES, THAT IS HOW HE
EARNED THIS OPPORTUNITY TO GET
OUT OF TROUBLE RIGHT HERE AND
STILL TRYING TO FIGHT HE GET
HIMSELF -- FIND A WAY TO GET
HIMSELF A WIN.
SCOTT: SOMETIMES CARLOS CORREA
STRUGGLED TO STAY ON THE FIELD.
YOU CAN SEE JUST HIS SECOND
SEASON AT 120 PLUS GAMES.
BUT WHEN HE IS ON THE FIELD, HE
HAS BEEN SUPER PRODUCTIVE.
LAST YEAR WAS A DOWN SEASON BUT
IT WAS A SHORTENED SEASON.
MANY STARS STRUGGLED IN LIMITED
TIME, BUT IT WAS THE PERFECT
YEAR TO HAVE A PLATFORM SEASON
FOR CARLOS CORREA.
IT'S NOT JUST WHAT HE DOES AT
THE PLATE.
HE IS HAVING A SUPER YEAR ON
DEFENSE.
AND THE METRICS BACK THAT UP.
CASEY SADLER GETTING HOT.
BIG TEST FOR TYLER ANDERSON.
ONLY AT 76 PITCHES AND HE HAS
GIVEN M'S FIVE INNINGS IN EACH
START HE HAS MADE SINCE JOINING
THE BALLCLUB VIA TRADE.
CHRIS: THE ONLY DANGEROUS PART
WITH TUCKER IS THAT HE HAS HIT
THE BALL HARD TWO TIMES, A
SINGLE AND A DOUBLE AND TRIPLE
ALREADY.
HE SEES ANDERSON REALLY WELL.
THAT IS THE ONLY THING THAT
COULD POTENTIALLY CHANGED THIS
DECISION WHEN YOU ARE TRYING TO
DECIDE IF I FACE THE SITUATION
OR NOT.
SCOTT: YOU HAVE YOUR LEFTY-LEFTY
MATCHUP.
2-0.
CLOSE TO HITTING THE HANDS OF
KYLE TUCKER.
CHRIS: AND A LOT OF TIMES
LEFTY-LEFTY MATCHUP OR WRITING
MATCHUP MATTERS WHEN YOU ARE
TRYING TO MAKE THIS DECISION --
OR RIGHTY-RIGHTY MATCHUP MATTERS
MAKING THIS DECISION.
YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT THE PREVIOUS
AT-BATS AND UNDERSTAND HOW THE
GUY IS SEEING THE BALL.
SCOTT: BALLS ARE 100 PLUS MILES
AN HOUR OFF THE BAT FOR TUCKER.
NOW 3-0.
CHRIS: AND ANDERSON KNOWS, HE
KNOWS -- HE MAY NOT KNOW, TWO
MISSILES OFF THIS GUY'S BAT.
EVEN IN THIS 3-0 COUNT, HE IS
NOT TRYING TO THROW A COOKIE
DOWN THE MIDDLE.
YOU CAN SEE THE CATCHER SET UP
ON THE CORNER TRYING TO EXECUTE
A PITCH, HOPING HE CAN EXPAND
THE ZONE A LITTLE BIT.
SCOTT: ONE OF THE BEST CONTROL
ARTISTS IN THE GAME.
THE 3-0 IS A LITTLE UP AND I DO
NOT THINK THAT SHE WANTED THAT
CALL BUT I DO NOT THINK -- HE
WANTED THAT CALL BUT I DO NOT
THINK HE NEEDS THAT.
HERE COMES SCOTT SERVAIS.
I DO NOT THINK HE NEEDS TO DEAL
WITH KYLE TUCKER WITH THE
PRODUCTION HE HAD AGAINST HIM.
HE JUST MISSED UP ACCORDING TO
GABE MORALES.
DO YOU LIKE THIS CALL?
AND I ASK THAT, BECAUSE, AND
THAT IS THE PITCH FROM STATCAST,
JAKE MEYERS IS ON DECK.
MEYERS 0-2, COUPLE STRIKE OUT
SWINGING.
I THOUGHT ANDERSON WOULD HANG
AROUND HERE TO TRY TO GET
HIMSELF OUT OF THE INNING.
THIS IS ACTUALLY GOING TO BE THE
FIRST TIME IN 27 STARTS FOR
TYLER ANDERSON THAT HE DOESN'T
GO AT LEAST FIVE INNINGS.
HE IS CLEARLY FRUSTRATED,
SADLER'S GOING TO TRY TO CLEAN
UP THIS MESS IN THE FIFTH.
>> OH, NO.
OH, MY GOD.
>> RUNNERS FOR SECOND.
[LAUGHS]
>> WE'RE THIRD.
ANYTHING IS POSSIBLE.
OH.
>> [LAUGHS]
>> [INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGHS]
HOW ARE YOU BROTHER?
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[LAUGHTER]
>> UNA SOPRESA?
SI.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
SCOTT: GOOGLE CLOUD IS HELPING
TO EMPOWER STATCAST TO REVEAL
NEW INSIGHTS, TAKING YOU DEEPER
INTO THE GAME THAN EVER BEFORE.
GOOGLE CLOUD IS THE OFFICIAL
CLOUD TECHNOLOGY OF MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL.
AND STATCAST POWERED BY GOOGLE
CLOUD HAD TO DO A LOT OF WORK
HERE.
AND FOLLOW THIS BASEBALL FROM
KYLE TUCKER, NOT TO THE SEATS,
TO THE ROOF!
55 DEGREES ON THE LAUNCH ANGLES.
IN THE AIR FOR 6.8 SECONDS.
IS I T COMING BACK?
CHRIS: YOU HAVE SEVEN SECONDS TO
MAKE THE PLAY RIGHT THERE.
SCOTT: AND MITCH HANIGER COULD
NOT FIND IT IN RIGHT FIELD.
NOW THE BASES ARE LOADED FOR
HOUSTON.
KEY SPOT IN THE GAME.
TYLER ANDERSON REMOVED FOR CASEY
SADLER, WHO HAS BEEN LIGHTS OUT
IN HIS 30 APPEARANCES THIS YEAR.
E.R.A. A FEW SHADES BELOW 1.0.
ONE OF THOSE GEM FINDS FOR THE
FRONT OFFICE.
HE'S REALLY TURN HIS CAREER
AROUND.
HIS FOURTH ORGANIZATION SINCE
2018, AND BY FAR HIS BEST SEASON
OF HIS CAREER.
CHRIS: ALTHOUGH THIS GUY IS
STATISTICALLY THE BEST IN THE
LEAGUE, AND THIS IS THE GUY
YOU WOULD BRING INTO INTO A
SITUATION BECAUSE ALTHOUGH IT IS
THE FIFTH INNING, THIS COULD BE
THE INNING THAT DETERMINES WHO
WINS OR LOSES THIS GAME.
IF YOU ARE JAKE MEYERS COME I
THINK YOU ARE ARE OK SEEING --
ARE OK SEEING SADLER.
AFTER THE FIRST STRIKEOUTS --
AFTER TWO STRIKEOUTS IN THE
FIRST COUPLE OF AT-BATS.
SCOTT:  MEYERS DOES TAKE OFF,
GIVES THAT ONE A RIDE TO DEEP
CENTER FIELD BUT KELENIC IS
THERE.
ALL WORKED OUT FOR SCOTT
SERVAIS, PULLS THE PLUG ON
ANDERSON AND GOES WITH HIS
SUPERSTRONG PEN BUT THE ASTROS
ADD INSURANCE IN THE FIFTH.
NUMBER 27 FOR NUMBER 27.
WATCHING IT ALL GLOBALLY TODAY
ON YOUTUBE.
ASTROS GOING FOR THE SWEEP,
DOUBLING UP THE M'S, 4-.2
>> OH, MY!
HANG ONTO THE ROOF!
>> THIS ONE IS--
>> OUTTA HERE!
>> [SPEAKING SPANISH]
TY FRANCE.
6-5.
>> SWINGING A HIGH FLY BALL INTO
THE RIGHT FIELD, HANIGER COMES
IN.
TORO DRIFTING OUT.
THE MARINERS SECOND BASE MEANT
-- OH, HE MADE THE CATCH!
HE LOST IT IN A POPPED IN THE
AIR LIKE A SNOWBALL AND HE MADE
THE CATCH AGAIN!
>> ONE OUT, BASES LOADED.
TO TORO.
HE DRILLS THIS.
DRILLED AND CROSSED AND THIS IS
GONE!
GRAND SLAM!
SCOTT: WE ARE IN THE SIXTH.
GREAT BALLGAME TODAY BETWEEN THE
MARINERS AND ASTROS.
CHECKING OUT THE FREE AGENT
CLASS OF SHORTSTOPS.
JAVY BAEZ, CARLOS CORREA, COREY
SEAGER, MARCUS SEMIEN IS PLAYING
SECOND BASE BUT HE CAN CERTAINLY
HANDLE SHORTSTOP, AND THEN
TREVOR STORY.
FRANCISCO LINDOR WOULD HAVE BEEN
A FREE AGENT BUT THE METS LOCK
HIM UP TO A LONG-TERM DEAL RIGHT
BEFORE THE SEASON STARTED.
SO, OUR NEXT POLL QUESTION HAS
TO DO WITH THAT AFTER THIS PITCH
FROM CRISTIAN JAVIER MISSES DOWN
TO JERED CELTIC, -- TO JERED
KELENIC.
WHICH FREE AGENT SHORTSTOP IS
MOST LIKELY ON THE MOVE CHANGING
TEAMS THIS SEASON?
A BLOOP SHOT OVER THIRD.
A SEEING EYE SIGNAL FOR JARRED
KELENIC TO START THE SIXTH.
BACK TO THE POLL QUESTION.
GET THE ANSWER FROM CY, WHAT HE
THINKS AND A MOMENT.
WHO IS MOST LIKELY ON THE MOVE,
BAEZ, CORREA, SEAGER AND START?
-- AND STORY?
I THINK ALL FOUR CHANGE TEAMS
IN THE OFF-SEASON.
WHAT ABOUT YOU?
CHRIS: ALL FOUR COULD DEFINITELY
CHANGE TEAMS.
I SAW SOME RECENT
STATEMENTS FROM VIERLING.
IF I HAVE TO CHOOSE ONE GUY THAT
WILL BE MOVING, I AM ASSUMING
THAT SEAGER WILL BE MOVING
AROUND AND THE SIGNING OF
TREA TURNER WAS SO MANY
VERSATILE GUYS IN THAT DODGERS
OFFENSE, I DO NOT THINK THE
DODGERS WILL GO OVER THE TOP TO
KEEP SEAGER, AND I THINK THERE
IS ANOTHER TEAM THAT WOULD BE
WILLING TO PAY UP.
SCOTT: YOU THINK HE IS THE MOST
LIKELY.
EVEN MORE SO THEN TREVOR STORY
ON THE ROCKIES WHO IS GOING TO
BE A FREE AGENT.
THINK THERE IS A BETTER CHANCE
THAT HE LATCHES BACK WITH THE
TEAM THAT HE PLAYS WITH RIGHT
NOW?
CHRIS: I'M GOING TO STICK WITH
MY GUT, ALTHOUGH THEY BOTH CAN
BE MOVED.
SEAGER IS THE GUY MOST LIKELY TO
SCOTT: HE'S GOING TO HAVE SOME
MONEY TO SPEND.
MAYBE THEY LAND ONE OF THE
SHORTSTOPS.
CHRIS: LET ME RUN IT BACK.
SOME OF THE DRAMA THAT BAEZ HAS
HAD.
I'M SORRY, EVERYBODY.
BAEZ IS PROBABLY GOING TO MAKE A
MOVE UNLESS HE FINDS A WAY TO
REKINDLE THAT RELATIONSHIP IN
NEW YORK.
SCOTT: I'M GOING TO GIVE A
THUMBS DOWN TO HIM RETURNING TO
THE METS THIS OFF-SEASON.
0-2, MISSES UP AND IN TO TOM
MURPHY, NUMBER EIGHT HITTER.
THAT'S WHY I'M LOOKING AT THAT
LISTACH IT IS A GOOD QUESTION
BECAUSE I THINK THEY ALL COULD
BE MOVING.
SO, WHICH ONE IS MOST LIKELY.
IF YOU ARE BANKING ON ONE, IT IS
DEFINITELY NOT GOING TO BE WITH
THE SAME BALLCLUB THAT HE IS
WITH RIGHT NOW.
WHAT'S YOUR PICK?
VOTE, AND WE WILL SHOW THE
RESULTS LATER.
WORKS RALEY COULD BE NEXT FOR
HOUSTON AFTER --  BROOKS RALEY
COULD BE NEXT AFTER JAVIER.
STILL COMING OFF THE SHOULDER
INJURY.
HE MISSED A GOOD CHUNK OF TIME.
MAKING JUST HIS SECOND START OFF
THE I.L.
NOW JAVIER TAKING OVER FOR SOME
LONG WORK.
CHRIS: HAVING A WEAPON LIKE
JAVIER.
HE CAN THROW A LOT OF FASTBALLS.
TO COME IN AND GIVE YOU SOME
QUALITY INNINGS IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE GAME, THAT IS SO VALUABLE
FOR THAT BULLPEN IN ALLOWING THE
GUYS AT THE BACK END TO STATE IN
-- STAY IN THE ROLE YOU WANT TO
SEE THEM IN.
SCOTT: THE FLEX POSITION.
HE CAN START, TO.
0-- START, TOO.
MADE NINE STARTS.
BIG SWING AND MISS.
CRISTIAN JAVIER.
TWO SCORELESS, TWO HITS, A
COUPLE WALKS.
LAST YEAR FINISHED IN THIRD
PLACE IN NATE LOWE ROOKIE OF THE
YEAR VOTING.
-- IN A.L. ROOKIE OF THE YEAR
VOTING.
WELL, BRETT, THE ASTROS
CAN SWING THE BAT.
THEY HAVE GREAT DEFENSE.
THERE IS NO MORE COAL, THERE IS
NO MORE VERLANDER.
THEY PUMP OUT ARMS IN THIS
ORGANIZATION.
>> I THINK BRETT STRONG IS A GUY
WE KNOW ABOUT.
MAYBE WE DO NOT GIVE HIM THE
FULL CREDIT ON WHAT HE HAS DONE
SINCE 2015.
WHERE THE ASTROS RANKED THIRD IN
THE MAJORS IN EARNED RUN AVERAGE
SINCE 2015, SECOND IN WHIP IN
FIRST IN OPPONENTS O.P.S.
DODGERS LEAD ALL THE CATEGORIES
BUT THERE IS A BIG DIFFERENCE IN
PITCHING.
VERLANDER HAS NOT BEEN A FACTOR.
AND BRENT STROM FINDS A WAY TO
GET A DIME IN HIGH FASTBALL'S,
CURVEBALL USAGE, USE ALL THE
QUADRANTS.
HE CAME HERE WITH JEFF LUHNOW
AND A.J. HINCH.
HE IS STILL HERE WITH TASTY
BAKER -- WITH DUSTY BAKER.
HE IS A BIG PART OF WHAT THEY DO
PITCHING WISE.
SCOTT: HE WAS INTO PITCHING UP
IN THE ZONE BEFORE IT WAS COOL.
BACK WHEN IT WAS SINKERS DOWN,
SLIDER DOWN, GET THOSE GROUND
BALLS.
A FLY BALL OFF THE BAT OF
MARMOLEJOS.
IN FOUL TERRITORY IS GURRIEL
FOR THE FIRST OUT IN THE S
IXTH.
CHRIS: YOU HAVE SOME TEAMS THAT
ADJUST UNDERSTAND THE PITCHING
PHILOSOPHY.
THE ASTROS AND THE WHITE SOX
HAVE REALLY GOOD PITCHERS.
THEY HAVE A PLAN AND APPROACH TO
ATTACK AN OFFENSE AND IT HAS
BEEN PROVEN TO WORK.
SCOTT: AND THEY ARE GOING TO
WORK WHERE THEIR NEXT MAN ON THE
MOUND, BROOKS RALEY.
DUSTY BAKER TAKES THE BALL FROM
CRISTIAN JAVIER.
TWO ON FOR SEATTLE AND THE
SIXTH.
RALEY COMING IN.
>> RIGHT NOW THE MARINERS
LOOKING FOR THE TIE.
THEY WOULD TAKE A FLY BALL.
THEY WOULD LOVE A BASE HIT INTO
THE GAP IF THEY COULD WIN --
>> EVERYBODY IS GOING TO BE
STRAIGHTAWAY.
ALL RIGHT.
BALL HIT RIGHT CENTER I CAN GO
FIRST AND THIRD.
LEFT CENTER, FIRST AND THIRD P
LEFT-FIELD  LINE IS SOFTER IF IT
STAYS DOWN  THERE, I CAN GO FROM
FIRST HOME.
I KNOW HOME FIELD, SO HERE IT
IS.
>> ON THIRD BASE.
NO BALLS AND A STRIKE TO
MARTINEZ.
>> SWUNG ON.
A BASEHIT!
>> SCORE EASY.
I TURNAROUND TO SEE WHERE JUNIOR
WAS.
>> HE'S COMING AROUND.
>> HE WAS FLYING.
NEVER SEEN HIM RUN THAT FAST
BEFORE.
>> HERE IS JUNIOR TO THIRD BASE.
>> MY WIFE SAYS, I DIDN'T KNOW
YOU COULD RUN THAT FAST.
"SHH, I'M NOT GOING TO SHOW THAT
ALL THE TIME."
>> THE THROW TO BE PLATE WILL BE
LATE.
I DON'T BELIEVE IT!
IT JUST CONTINUES!
MY OH MY!
SCOTT: THIS WHY REALLY -- T
HIS RIVALRY IS HEATING UP AT HAS
BEEN LOPSIDED.
ASTROS 36 WINS, 11 LOSSES
AGAINST THE MARINERS SINCE THE
START OF 2019 P THE SECOND MOST
DOMINANCE WE HAVE SEEN FROM ONE
DIVISION OPPONENT AGAINST
ANOTHER IN THE LAST FEW YEARS.
ONLY CLEVELAND POUNCING ON THE
TIGERS HAS SHOWN US MORE
DOMINANCE.
THAT CONTINUES THIS WEEK, AT
LEAST, BUT LIKE I MENTIONED,
SEATTLE HAS PLAYED MUCH BETTER
AGAINST THEM THIS SEASON.
GO BACK TO 2019, THE ASTROS WERE
18-1 AGAINST SEATTLE.
LAST YEAR 7-3, THIS YEAR 11-7.
THINKING SWEEP TODAY.
LEADING 4-2 WITH BROOKS RALEY,
THE LEFT-HANDER TAKING OVER FOR
DUSTY BAKER'S HOUSTON ASTROS
BALLCLUB GOING UP AGAINST SCOTT
SERVAIS AND A SURGING SEATTLE
TEAM THAT THEY HOPE HAS THEIR
BEST YEARS AHEAD OF THEM, ONE OF
THE TOP FARM SYSTEMS IN THE
SPORT AS WELL.
JUST THREE GAMES AWAY FROM A
PLAYOFF SPOT, TOP OF THE ORDER.
J.P. CRAWFORD.
TWO ON, ONE OUTIN T VISITING
-- IN THE VISITING SIX.
HERE ARE RALEY'S NUMBERS.
NOT PRETTY.
E.R.A. AND THE 5.5 RANGE.
LAST PITCHED IN SAN DIEGO ON
SUNDAY.
PICKED UP THE LAST OUT OF THE
SIXTH INNING.
ONLY FOUR TOSSES AND THAT ONE
CHRIS: HE IS ANOTHER KITCHEN
SINK GUY.
CUTTER SLIDER, HE CAN PRETTY
MUCH THROW ANYTHING BUT HE STILL
GETS IN TROUBLE WITH THAT CUTTER
AND SINKER WHEN HITTERS -- WITH
HITTERS HITTING OVER .300 OFF
THOSE PITCHERS.
SCOTT: WITH KELENIC REACHING ON
THE SINGLE, MURPHY WALKING AND
NUMBER NINE HITTER, JOSE
MARMOLEJOS THE LAST MAN OUT, IT
-- C5 IS MANAGING.
CHRIS: AS MARMOLEJOS IS COMING
TO THE PLATE.
I'M ASSUMING YOU HAVE A RUNNER
ON FIRST AND SECOND, NO OUTS.
YOU'RE SCUFFLING A LITTLE BIT.
IS THIS A SITUATION THAT YOU PUT
A BUNT DOWN?
AND NORMALLY WOULD SAY YES.
I THINK THE MANAGER HAS TO BE
THINKING ABOUT THAT BUT THE
PROBLEM IS THAT HE HASN'T BUNTED
THIS YEAR.
SCOTT: AND IN HIS PRO CAREER
HE NEVER HAD A BUNT.
AS J.P. CRAWFORD STRIKES OUT.
THIS PITCH FROM RALEY TIPPED
INTO THE GLOVE.
BUT MARMOLEJOS HAS DONE SOME
SERIOUS DAMAGE IN THE MINOR
LEAGUES.
BUT I WAS THINKING HAS HE BUNTED
MUCH IN HIS LIFE?
THE ANSWER ISN O.
-- IS NO.
CHRIS: THAT'S WHY I PERSONALLY
BELIEVE YOU HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THAT IN THE MINOR
LEAGUES.
YOU DO NOT KNOW WHAT YOUR ROLE
IS GOING TO BE WHEN YOU GET
CALLED TO THE BIG LEAGUES.
JUST BECAUSE YOU ARE IN THE 3,
4, 5 HOLE DOUBLE-A IT DOES NOT
MEAN YOU WILL BE THAT MIDDLE OF
THE ORDER GUY IN THE BIG
LEAGUES.
AS A MANAGER, I THINK SCOTT IS
HOPING THAT IF HE GETS IN THAT
SITUATION, HE CAN CALLI T,
BECAUSE YOU DO NOT WANT TO WASTE
AN AT-BAT ON A GUY THAT IS NEVER
BUNTED BEFORE.
YOU ARE DOWN BY TWO RUN WITH A
GUY SCUFFLING WITH THE BAT TO BE
ABLE TO GET THOSE RUNNERS OVER
AND GIVE CRAWFORD A DIFFERENT
MINDSET AS HE'S GOING TO THE
PLATE WITH A RUNNER ON THIRD
BASE WITH LESS THAN TWO OUTS.
AS A WHOLE THE MARINERS DON'T
BUNT.
THE FOURTH FEWEST IN THE MAJORS
THIS SEASON.
I KNOW BUNTING IS A LOST ART,
BUT IT SOMETIMES WHEN I AM
WATCHING A GAME, IT JUST SEEMS
LIKE THE RIGHT PLAY.
AND TEAMS RARELY  GO TO IT
ANYMORE.
SCOTT: THE MARINERS DID IT LAST
NIGHT IN THE TOP OF THE 10TH.
DIDN'T WORK OUT FOR DYLAN MOORE.
MARINERS COME UP EMPTY IN THAT
INNING.
THEN THE ASTROS WALKS THEM OFF.
BUT YOU'RE RIGHT.
I MEAN, SEATTLE AND HOUSTON ARE
IN THE BOTTOM FOUR IN BUNTS IN
BASEBALL THIS YEAR.
CHRIS: AND SOMETHING ELSE THAT
CAN GO INTO THAT DECISION IS HOW
WAY THEY NORMALLY HIT -- HOW
WELL THEY NORMALLY HIT WITH
RUNNERS IS GOING POSITION.
SCOTT: HANIGER BOUNCES OUT.
BROOKS RALEY PICKS UP TWO OUT.
AND THE MARINERS STRAND TWO IN
THE SIXTH.
STILL HAVE JUST TWO FROM THAT
FIRST INNING.
♪
>> EMBEDDED THIS TIME OF THE
GAME KYLE IS EXTREMELY -- YOU
CAN BET AT THE TIME OF THE GAME
THAT KYLE IS AWARE OF THE FACT
THAT THERE IS A ZERO AND THAT
HIT COLUMN.
>> THERE IS A LINE DRIVE.
IT'S CAUGHT ON THE LINE.
TWO MEN ARE GONE.
BALL TO SHORT.
WON'T GO!
GOT HIM!
>> THERE'S THE DRAMA RIGHT
THERE.
SEE THAT ZERO?
LOPEZ FOR THE -- NO HITS FOR
THE METS.
CURVEBALL.
TWO OUTS AWAY FROM A NO-NO.
2-2 PITCH, STRIKE THREE!
THE 1-2 PITCH.
SWUNG ON AND MISSED.
A NO-HITTER FOR KYLE.
SCOTT: HEY, LISTEN TO MLB'S
PODCASTS WITH THE LATEST
ANALYSIS FROM INSIDERS AND
IN-DEPTH INTERVIEWS WITH
BASEBALLS BECAUSE STARS.
SUBSCRIBED AT MLB.COM/PODCASTS.
THE MLB BALLPARK APPLE COMPLETE
YOUR NEXT VISIT TO THE
BALLPARK.
ACCESS EXQUISITE CONTENT AND
MUCH MORE.
DOWNLOAD THE BALLPARK APP TODAY.
IT'S HOT OUTSIDE AND HOUSTON.
BUT GUESS WHAT?
THIS BALLPARK HAS A LID ON IT.
AND IT HEPS.
-- IT HELPS.
ORBIT IS VERY THANKFUL FOR THE
CLIMATE CONTROL AS YOU CAN SEE.
HE IS ONE OF MY FAVORITES, BY
THE WAY.
CHRIS: THE SWEAT HAPPENING UNDER
THAT SUIT RIGHT NOW.
SCOTT: ORBIT'S THE NEW SCHOOL
PHILLY PHANATIC FOR ME.
SIMILAR PERSONALITY BUT HAS SOME
MODERN TRICKS.
SO DOES JOE SMITH.
HE'S 37 YEARS OLD.
HAS ONE OF THOSE UNIQUE ARM
ANGLES THEY GIVE YOU A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT LOOK OUT OF
THE BULLPEN.
HE HAS PITCHED BETTER WITH
SEATTLE SINCE MOVING OVER IN THE
HIGHLY PUBLICIZED TRADE THAT
FEATURED ABRAHAM TORO AND
KENDALL GRAVEMAN.
SMITH NOW AGAINST HIS FORMER
BALLCLUB AND HOUSTON IN THE
SIXTH.
CHRIS: LIKE YOU SAID COME HE IS
ANOTHER GUY WHO HAS BENEFITED
FROM THE CHANGE OF SCENERY.
7.0 E.R.A. WITH HOUSTON.
ABLE TO COME TO SEATTLE, GET A
FRESH START AND HAVEN'T E.R.A.
IN THE LOW 2'S.
HE IS ALWAYS HAD THAT FUNKY ARM
ANGLE, SINKER SLIDER GUY.
HIS SLIDER WAS VERY EFFECTIVE IN
THE PAST BUT THIS YEAR IT HAS
BEEN HIT A LITTLE BIT AND THAT'S
WHAT CAUSED THE ISSUE WITH HIS
E.R.A. OVER WITH HOUSTON.
SCOTT: MATCHING UP WITH HIS
FORMER TEAMMATE MARWIN GONZALEZ.
HE HOMERED IN THE SECOND.
CHRIS: WHEN YOU'RE COMING FROM A
SIDE ARM ANGLE WITH THAT SLIDER,
YOU LITERALLY NEED DEAD BALL
-- THAT BALL FOR MARWIN TO START
OFF THE PLATE TO COME BACK OVER
THE MIDDLE.
WEATHER, GETS TO YOU, THAT IS
---  BY THE TIME IT GETS TO IF
IT STARTS OFF THE PLATE, IT IS
IN OFF THE PLATE.
IT IS TOUGH TO GAUGE AS A HITTER
WHERE THE BALL NEEDS TO START
WHEN YOU HAVE A RELIEVER COMING
IN --  COMING IN WITH A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT ARM ANGLE.
SCOTT: YOU FACED HIM 2-7.
DID NOT LOOK LIKE MARWIN WAS
COMFY THERE.
SKIED AND CAUGHT.
ONE OUT INT HE SIXTH.
KYLE ROWLEY WITH THE MICROPHONE
TODAY FOR US ON YOUTUBE.
KYLE: MY UNCLE HAS ABNORMALLY
LARGE HANDS.
IT IS THE BIGGEST WORLD SERIES
RING EVER MADE.
FOR THE MARLINS.
2003 OR 2002.
HE WENT AND THEY DID NOT HAVE
ANYTHING THAT FIT HIM.
IT WAS A 17.5?
HE HAS SAUSAGE FINGERS.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: STORYTIME WITH KYLE ALL
DAY LONG ON YOUTUBE.
CHRIS: HIS UNCLE'S GOING TO
APPRECIATE THE TV TIME ABOUT HIS
SAUSAGE FINGERS.
SCOTT: HE'LL LIVE FOREVER ON
YOUTUBE.
CHRIS: I NEED TO SEE THESE
FINGERS.
WE NEED A PHOTO OF THE FINGERS.
SCOTT: POST A VIDEO.
OOH!
MALDONADO THINKING ABOUT A BUNT
FOR CY, BUT PULLS BACK.
CHRIS: I LIKE IT, WHEN YOU'RE
HITTING YOU TRY TO GET CREATED.
HE CAN PEEK DOWN THAT THIRD-BASE
LINE AND HE SEES HOW FAR BACK
SEAGER IS AND HE SAYS, IF I GET
IT BY THE PITCHER, I THINK EVEN
I CAN BEAT THIS OUT.
SCOTT: IT IS KIND OF LIKE A
BUNT, AND BARE HAND, JOE SMITH
WROTE.
-- THROW.
DID HE STAY ON THE BAG?
TY FRANCE DID.
CHRIS: WHO SAYS PITCHERS ARE NOT
ATHLETES?
THAT WAS A VERY ATHLETIC PLAY BY
JOE SMITH.
BARE HAND THIS BALL.
HE UNDERSTOOD THE RUNNER THAT
WAS RUNNING, GOT HIS FEET UP
UNDER HIM, DID NOT HAVE TO RUSH
IT AND MADE THE SOLID THROW TO
FIRST BASE.
SCOTT: A NICE BAREHANDED, CALLED
IT A SNATCH.
LOOK AT THIS, WHOOP.
CHRIS: IF YOU HAVE ALTUVE
RUNNING, IT FORCES HIM TO RUSH
MORE.
WHEN YOU HAVE THE CATCHER
RUNNING, YOU KNOW YOU HAVE A
LITTLE EXTRA TIME TO GET YOUR
FEET UP ON YOU, PLANT, AND MAKE
A STRONG THROW TO FIRST.
SCOTT: JOSE ALTUVE TIME.
HOMERS IN THE FIFTH.
HE HAD GONE 134 AT-BATS WITHOUT
A HOME RUN, JULY 30 UP UNTIL
WITHOUT A HOME RUN., JULY 30
.
TODAY, NUMBER 27.
CHRIS: SMITH IS STAYING RIGHT ON
THE CORNERS RIGHT THERE.
SCOTT: THIS IS A SIZZLING BAT.
TWO IN HIS LAST TWO.
HOMERLESS IN HIS  PRIOR 31.
GOOD SWINGS FROM JOSE.
CHRIS: FOR JOSE TO DO WHAT WE
CALL IN THE BASEBALL COMMUNITY A
TROPHY TAKE, A TROPHY TAKE IS
WHEN YOU PRETTY MUCH STAND UP
THERE, TAKE A FALL DOWN THE
MIDDLE, YOU HAD NO INTENTION OF
SWINGING.
THAT TELLS YOU HOW UNCOMFORTABLE
IT CAN BE TO FACE JOE SMITH.
SCOTT: FOR ONE.
AND KELENIC MAKES THE CALL.
THE SIDE IS RETIRED.
THREE UP, THREE DOWN.
JOE SMITH DOING HIS JOB.
MARINERS NEED TO FIGURE OUT SOME
OFFENSE.
4-2 AFTER SIX.
♪
>> YES!
[BEEP]
♪
>> A STRIKE.
I THANK YOU THOUGHT THAT WAS THE
END OF THE INNING.
[LAUGHS]
HE DID PUNCH  HIM.
>> HE WILL BE HEARING ABOUT THAT
IN THE UMPIRES ROOM.
>> DOWN THE LINE AND CAUGHT.
ONE GONE.
>> THIS BALL IS HOOKING BACK
FAIR.
NO FOUL.
>> OOH!
[BOING[
>> OFF HIS FOOT.
CAN SANTANA GET AN OUT?
YES!
>> OFF HIS FOOT.
62 FEET IN THE AIR.
OLE.
>> SWUNG ON AND MISSED, THROW TO
SECOND.
HE NEARLY MISSED IT.
A NICE MOVE BY MATEO.
HE WAS OUT.
>> YOU TALK ABOUT ATHLETICISM,
HUH?
HOW DOES HE AVOID THAT TAG?
>> NOW YOU SEE ME, NOW YOU
DON'T.
A LITTLE MAGIC OUT THERE.
>> THIS IS MY CHANCE.
I HAVE AN AUDIENCE NOW.
IF CODY JAMES HEARS THIS, WE'RE
GOING TO THE CONCERT.
THIS OFF-SEASON.
SO.
ALWAYS FOUND ME
♪
IT IS NOT LIKE HE IS MY WALK-UP
SONG OR ANYTHING.
SCOTT: CODY IS DEFINITELY GOING
TO HEAR THAT.
THOSE TWO ARE GOING TO HANG OUT
IN THE OFF-SEASON.
WE'RE FINISHING UP THIS POLL
QUESTION.
WHICH FREE AGENT SHORTSTOP IS
LIKELY ON THE MOVE THIS
OFF-SEASON?
A LOT OF ASTROS FANS ARE
WATCHING AND VOTING AND THINKING
THAT CARLOS CORREA IS ON HIS WAY
TO ANOTHER BALLCLUB.
35%.
HE TAKES IT.
CHRIS: A LOT OF SHORTSTOPS ON
THERE.
WHO DO YOU THINK GETS THE
BIGGEST CONTRACT OUT OF THOSE
GUYS?
SCOTT: OOH, THAT IS ANOTHER
QUESTION.
BEFORE THE SEASON STARTED I
WOULD HAVE SAID KYLE'S BROTHER
COREY.
1-1.
TO THE ELDER SEAGER.
COREY'S DEALT WITH SOME INJURIES
THIS YEAR BUT, MAN, HE WAS A
SUPERSTAR IN THE POSTSEASON LAST
YEAR.
WORLD SERIES M.V.P.
DID HE WIN NLCS M.V.P.?
HE DID.
BIG CUT AND A MISS FROM BIG BRO
KYLE.
1-2.
KYLE'S BEEN WITH THE SAME
FRANCHISES ENTIRE CAREER -- HIS
ENTIRE CAREER.
FORMER THIRD ROUND PICK OUT OF
NORTH CAROLINA IN 2009.
HE'S UP THERE.
11 SEASONS WITH THE BALLCLUB AND
THERE IS A CLUB OPTION FOR
SEAGER IN 2022 FOR 15 MILLION
BUCKS.
CHRIS: THERE IS NO DOUBT ON THAT
CLUB OPTION.
GETTING PICKED UP.
HE IS YOUR GUY.
HE IS SO DURABLE.
HE CAN PLAY A FULL SEASON.
HE IS NOT GETTING INJURED.
HE'S RELIABLE.
TO BE RELIABLE HAS A COST.
SCOTT: HE IS DOWN ON STRIKES.
HERE COMES TY FRANCE.
I THOUGHT WHEN YOU TOLD ME THE
MARINERS WERE GOING OVER ON THE
ODDS COURTESY OF BET GM, IT WAS
MONEY.
THEY HAD TWO RUNS IN THE
FIRST BUT THEY NEED TO REACH
FOUR.
MAYBE WE SEE ANOTHER PITCHER.
GARCIA, ONE OF THE NEWER MEMBERS
OF THIS BULLPEN, WILL HEAD TO
THE MOUND AND TAKE OVER FOR THE
ASTROS IN A MOMENT.
>> SHUT YOUR EYES AND BE READY
TO BAIL OUT.
>> I CAN REMEMBER TALKING TO
PLAYS AND OTHER TEAMS TALKING
ABOUT JR. ITIS.
>> YOU SAW A LOT OF CASES OF
J.R. ITIS.
SOMEBODY WOKE UP WITH A STIFF
NECK.
SOMEBODY ELSE HAD A FEVER OR
COUGH.
THEY DIDN'T WANT TO BE OUT
THERE.
>> HALL OF FAME GUYS, THEY DID
NOT WANT TO PLAY.
THEY TAKE THEIR DAYS OFF WHEN
J.R. WAS PITCHING.
>> AT 6'8" AND 250 POUNDS HE WAS
AN IMPOSING PRESENCE ON THE
MOUND.
AND THERE WAS SOMETHING SCARY
ABOUT J.R. RICHARD.
>> HE IS SO STRONG.
HE HAS GOT THE MOST FEROCIOUS
HANDSHAKE THAT I'VE EVER
ENCOUNTERED.
HE HAS GOT MAMMOTH HANDS..
>> I WAS A P.R. GUY WE HAD
IMPOSED FOR A PITCHER HOLDING
EIGHT OR NINE BASEBALLS IN ONE
HAND.
>> HE PUT NINE FALLS IN HIS
>> WE MADE A POSTER OUT OF IT.
>> EVERYBODY TRIED TO SEE HOW
MANY BALLS THEY COULD HOLD IN
THEIR HAND.
I DON'T THINK I COULD HOLD SEVEN
GOLF BALLS.
>> I HAD TWO PITCHES.
FAST AND FASTER.
AT MY BEST I COULD THROW IT
THROUGH CARWASH AND NEVER GET IT
WET.
SCOTT: GO BEHIND THE SCENES
OUT THE LATEST MIC'ED UP
CONTENT AT THE MARINERS YOUTUBE
CHANNEL.
AN MLB ORIGINAL SEASON 2 IS LIVE
WITH NEW EPISODES EVERY WEEK.
LEARN MORE ABOUT THE GAME YOU
LOVE ON YOUTUBE.COM/MLB.
THAT IS WHERE YOU ARE RIGHT NOW
FOR THE GAME OF THE WEEK.
ASTROS AND MARINERS FOR THE LAST
TIME IN 2021 IN THE REGULAR
SEASON.
FIRST AND SECOND PLACE BALLCLUBS
IN THE A.L.
WEST.
NEXT UP OUT OF THE BULLPEN,
31-YEAR-OLD GARCIA.
FIRST PITCH FOULED BACK BY
FRANCE.
WE SAW TIMI START THE SIXTH
INNING-- WE SAW YIMI YESTERDAY.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
WE'LL LET BROOKS RALEY STRIKEOUT
SEAGER AND YOU TAKE OVER FOR
FOUR, FIVE AND SIX.
THERE IS THE NUMBERS FOR GARCIA
ON THE YEAR.
HIS FOUR SEAM FASTBALL VELOCITY
HAS BOOSTED UP FROM LAST YEAR
WHICH WAS A CAREER YEAR.
CHRIS: AND, EVEN AT 21, HE
STARTED TO OPEN UP HIS ARSENAL A
BIT.
HE HAS BECOME PRETTY MUCH A FOUR
OR FIVE PITCH GUY WITH A FOUR
SEAMER, THE SLIDER, THE CURVE
ANY INTRODUCE THE CHANGEUP AND
THE SINKER AS WELL TO TRY TO MIX
IT UP AND KEEP GUYS MORE
OFF-BALANCE.
SCOTT: OOH.
TY FRANCE FOULED ONE OFF HIS
LEG.
CHRIS: HE HAS ALWAYS BEEN AN
EXTREME FLY BALL GUY.
BESIDES 2020, HE'S BEEN GIVING
UP THE LONG BALL AND THAT HAS
GOT HIM IN TROUBLE.
SCOTT: HOW DOES THAT FEEL?
CHRIS: OH, IT NEVER HITS THE
SHINGUARD.
SHINGUARD'S RIGHT THERE, AND HE
FOUND A WAY TO HIT RIGHT ABOVE
IT.
SCOTT: HE'S BACK IN THERE.
A BALL AND TWO STRIKES.
CHRIS: HERE WE GO.
YOU SEE.
YOU WOULD THINK THEY MAKE THE
SHINGUARD TWO INCHES TALLER BUT
IF YOU DID HE WOULD JUST HIT IT
OFF IS KNEE.
YOU CONTINUE TO MOVE IT UP OF
WHERE YOU HIT THE BALL.
YOU HAVE THAT PROTECTION FOR
GOOD REASON BECAUSE IT PROTECTS
YOUR FOOT, PROTECT, PROTECTS
YOUR SHIN.
YOU CANNOT PREDICT WHERE THAT
BALL IS GOING TO GO.
SCOTT: MORE SHIN COVERAGE,
PLEASE.
CHRIS: HE'S FEELING IT.
IF HE GETS A GROUND BALL WE WILL
SEE HIM LIMP DOWN THE LINE.
SCOTT: THAT HAPPENED TO YORDAN
ALVAREZ.
HE CAME BACK QUICKLY.
CHRIS: HIT IT OFF HIS BACK KNEE.
I WAS WATCHING THAT GAME.
I KNOW THAT HURT.
I THOUGHT HE WOULD BE OUT.
SCOTT: ME, TOO.
TY FRANCE IS GOING TO HEAD TO
SECOND EASILY WITH A STANDUP
DOUBLE.
CHRIS: HE'S STILL FEELING
THAT.
A DOUBLE MAKES IT FEEL A LITTLE
BETTER.
SCOTT: RUN IT OUT.
THAT WAS ABSOLUTELY CRANKED.
CHRIS: A GREAT PIECE OF HITTING,
LINE TO LINE GUY.
HE DOESN'T PANIC.
STAYS WITH HIS APPROACH.
HE CAN GO RIGHT FIELD LINE, PULL
DOWN THE LEFT-FIELD LINE.
WE'VE BEEN HARPING ON HIM ALL
GAME.
BUT HE IS A GREAT HITTER.
SCOTT: YIMI JUST ENTERED, AND
THEY ARE HAVING A CHAT ON THE
MOUND.
HERE'S HANIGER.
HIS FIRST A.B. HE WENT TO RIGHT
FIELD WITH A SINGLE.
CHRIS: BUT THAT IS THE BENEFIT
OF RANCE HITTING THE -- FRANCE
HITTING THE BALL OVER THE YARD
PICKED YOU CANNOT SHIFT HIM.
YOU HAVE TO PLAY STRAIGHT UP AND
IT OPENS UP HOLES FOR HIM TO BE
ABLE TO GET THOSE HITS.
SCOTT: ANY HITS FASTBALLS BUT
WHAT MAKES HIM STANDS OUT IS THE
SECONDARY STUFF, HE CAN HANDLE
AS WELL.
THAT IS PHIL MATON.
ANOTHER NEW MEMBER OF THE
BULLPEN FROM THE TRADE
DEADLINE IN THAT MYLES STRAW
DEAL WITH CLEVELAND.
THAT WAS THE ONE PORTION OF THE
BALLCLUB THAT NEEDED WORK FOR
HOUSTON, FIRST HALF OF THE
SEASON, THERE WAS BULLPEN
ISSUES.
ENTER YIMI GARCIA AND KENDALL
GRAVEMAN, AND PHIL MATON.
PROBLEM SOMEWHAT SOLVED.
CHRIS: HOUSTON ALWAYS DOES A
GOOD JOB OF BRINGING IN
COMPLIMENTARY PIECES.
THEY ARE ONE OF THE TEAMS THAT
HAS KEPT THEIR CORE TOGETHER FOR
A WHILE.
THESE GUYS ON THE FIELD ARE THE
SAME GUYS I WAS PUTTING AGAINST
A FEW YEARS AGO, AND THAT IS NOT
COMMON IN TODAY'S GAME.
GUYS MOVE AROUND BUT HOUSTON HAS
BEEN ABLE TO KEEP THEIR CORE
TOGETHER AND BRING IN A FEW
PIECES WHEN THEY NEED THEM.
IT COULD CHANGE THIS OFF-SEASON
A LITTLE BIT WITH CORREA
POTENTIALLY LEAVING AND FOR
LANDING POTENTIALLY LEAVING --
AND VERLANDER POTENTIALLY
LEAVING.
BUT THEY HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DEAL
WITH IT.
GERRIT COLE IS NOW THE START FOR
THE YANKEES.
YET, STILL, THIS IS A TOP-FIVE
FIVE STARTING PITCHING E.R.A.
TEAM.
CHRIS: WHEN THEY LOST COLE.
THEN I SAW THE NEWS OF LOSING
VERLANDER.
SCOTT: TORO, A SQUIBBER.
AND THE PLAY IS NOT IN TIME.
OFF THE BAG IS GURRIEL.
SAFE AT FIRST IS TORO.
FRANCE MOVES UP TO THIRD.
CORREA COULDN'T MAKE THE PLAY.
LONE MAN ON THE LEFT SIDE OF THE
INFIELD.
CHRIS: MARWIN RIGHT THERE.
SCOTT: MARWIN.
CHRIS: THAT IS WHAT HAPPENS WITH
THE SHIFT.
SOMETIMES GUYS GET OUT OF
POSITION, AND THAT IS BALL THAT
IS NORMALLY RIGHT AT CORREA.
ROUTINE PLAY DIRECTLY AT HIM.
WITH THAT SHIFT, FORCES MARWIN
TO MOVE TO THE SIDE.
YOU SEE HIM FALL AFTER THE
THROW.
THE BALL WAS PULLING THAT WAY
THAT HE WAS FALLING AND IT PULLS
GURRIEL OFF THE BAG.
SCOTT: IT'S A HIT FOR ABRAHAM
TORO.
RUNNERS ON THE CORNERS WITH ONE
DOWN IN THE SEVENTH.
HERE'S TO RENZ.-- TORRENS.
I LIKE KEEPING MY SHORTSTOP ON
THAT SIDE.
IF HE'S ALL ALONE ON THE LEFT
SIDE, KEEPING HIM IN FAMILIAR
TERRITORY.
I KNOW THAT MOST BASEBALLS ARE
HEADING TOWARDS THE MIDDLE AND
THAT IS WHY THE SHIFT IS ON BUT
MARWIN CAN HANDLE A BALL OF THE
MIDDLE.
CHRIS: EXACTLY.
THAT IS SOMETHING YOU SEE WITH
SAN DIEGO TO WEAR WHEN THEY DO
THEIR SHIFT, MACHADO WILL GO
OVER TO THE OTHER SIDE.
YOU KEEP YOUR SHORTSTOP IN
POSITION BECAUSE HE SHOULD HAVE
THE MOST RANGE.
YOU KEEP HIM BY HIMSELF AND
ALLOW HIM TO MAKE THOSE PLAYS.
SCOTT: THAT IS WHY CORREA HAS A
TOP FIVE WINS ABOVE REPLACEMENT
MARKS, THE STAT TO MEASURE HOW
EFFECTIVE HE HAS BEEN, TOP FIVE
IN THE A.L.
OK, SO, DEFENSE DID NOT WORK OUT
FOR HOUSTON AGAINST TORO.
BUT STATCAST POWERED BY GOOGLE
CLOUD SHOWING US JAKE MEYERS
FIGURING OUT WHERE THAT BASEBALL
WAS GOING TO END UP AND MAKING A
CATCH THAT HAPPENS JUST 10% OF
THE TIME.
106 FEET COVERED BY THE ROOKIE
CENTER FIELDER TO ROB TORO BACK
IN THE FIFTH.
AND THERE'S A BIG STRIKEOUT
PICKED UP BY GARCIA.
TORRENS GOES DOWN.
TWO AWAY.
CHRIS: TWO BEAUTIFUL SINKERS
RIGHT THERE ON THE CORNER.
WHEN YOU FEEL LIKE YOU'RE ABOUT
TO HIT IT AT THE LAST SECOND IT
DROPS ONTO YOUR BAT.
THAT IS A PERFECT LOCATION.
HIT-- HITIN THAT LOWER RIGHT
QUADRANT.
AND 96 NEVER HURT.
TWO MILES AN HOUR CHANGES YOUR
DYNAMIC AS A PITCHER.
SCOTT: THIS IS A HUGE MATCHUP
AGAINST A TEAM LOOKING UP AT
HOUSTON IN THE STANDINGS THIS IS
A HUGE MATCHUP AGAINST A TEAM
LOOKING UP AT HOUSTON IN THE
STANDINGS.
SO NOW IT IS PHIL MATON TIME
WITH TWO OUTS AND TWO ON FOR
SEATTLE.
>> WITH THE TEAM JUST ONE GAME
BACK, THE SEPTEMBER BATTLE CRY
THAT HAD COME OUT OF THE STANDS
WAS FEELING MORE REAL THAN EVER.
>> SOMEBODY HAD ABANDONED.
REFUSE TO LOSE.
AND LOU SAID, I SAW A SIGN,
THAT WAS IT.
>> THE SELLOUT CROWD GIVES THEM
A STANDING OVATION.
>> I REMEMBER THAT EVEN IF WE
WERE LOSING, WE FELT THAT WE CAN
COME BACK IN ANY GAME.
>> AND WE ARE EVEN AT 7-7.
>> EVERY DAY THERE WAS A NEW
HERO.
>> ALEX -- DEEP TO LEFT FIELD!
AND THE MAGIC IS IN SEATTLE!
>> AND THE MARINERS WIN IT!
46,000 FANS ARE LOSING THEIR
MINDS.
>> KEMPER WAS STARTING TO REALLY
RECOGNIZE THAT SOMETHING SPECIAL
WAS HAPPENING --  PEOPLE WERE
STARTING TO REALLY RECOGNIZE
THAT SOMETHING SPECIAL WAS
HAPPENING HERE.
>> THAT TIME, THERE IS NO LOUD
STADIUM.
EVERY DAY WAS LOUDER AND LOUDER
AND LOUDER.
>> THE KINGDOME BECAME ONE OF
THE CHARACTERS IN THE STORY.
IT WAS LIKE BEING INSIDE A
POPCORN BOTTLE EVERYTHING ON
NIGHT.
SCOTT: LET'S GO BACK IN TIME.
EDGAR MARTINEZ, THE HALL OF
FAME.
ALDS.
1995, GAME FIVE.
THAT WAS A TALENTED SEATTLE
TEAM.
COME ON DOWN.
CHRIS: HE WAS GLIDING AROUND
THOSE SPACES.
THAT IS ONE OF THE MOST
MEMORABLE PLAYS EVER.
SCOTT: BUT THEY HAVE NEVER BEEN
TO THE WORLD SERIES.
THE LONGEST ACTIVE PENNANT
DROUGHT.
45 SEASONS, THE ONLY ACTIVE MLB
FRANCHISE TO NEVER MAKE IT TO
THE FALL CLASSIC.
SEE THE OTHER STREAKS ARE FOR
TEAMS THAT A BENCH TO THE WORLD
SERIES.
SO, THEY HAVE THAT, AND THE POST
SEASONLESS DROUGHT WHICH GOES
BACK TO 2001, BUT THEY ARE
WORKING ON THAT.
PHIL MATON, NUMBERS WITH
CLEVELAND AND HOUSTON THIS YEAR.
GOING UP AGAINST JARED
KELLEY.
-- JARED KELENIC.
MEYERS TRACKING THAT, SIMILAR
SPOT.
THIS TIME HE WILL HAVE TO PLAY
IT OFF THE WALL, AND THE
MARINERS ARE GOING TO TIE UP
THIS GAME.
JERRY KALLICK -- JARRED KELENIC
HAS HIMSELF A TWO R.B.I. DOUBLE.
ONE PITCH TURNS INTO A 4-4
CONTEST.
CHRIS: THAT IS A GREAT PIECE OF
HITTING.
FOR KELENIC TO BE READY FOR THAT
FIRST PITCH BREAKING BALL, I'M
ASSUMING THAT THERE WAS
SOMETHING IN THE SCOUTING
REPORT.
A LOT OF TIMES BEFORE YOUR
AT-BAT YOU GO TO YOUR HITTING
COACH AND YOU LOOK AT THE
SCOUTING REPORT AND YOU KNOW
WHAT HE THROWS, AND RIGHT HERE
FOR HIM TO BE ABLE TO TAKE THAT
BREAKING BALL THE OTHER WAY, IT
TELLS ME HE WAS READY FOR IT.
WILLING TO SIT BACK AND WAIT ON
IT AND DRIVE THE OTHER WAY.
A GREAT PIECE OF HITTING.
SCOTT: FRANCE IS IN.
TORO'S STANDING.
WE ARE TIED.
NOW IS THE TIME TO MENTION THAT
THE SEATTLE MARINERS ARE 2917 IN
-- ARE 29-17 IN ONE RUN GAMES.
MOST ONE RUN WINS IN BASEBALL
THIS YEAR.
HOUSTON  IN THOSE GAMES
ARE16-16.
TWO WORDS THAT HAVE BEEN ECHOED
NATIONALLY ABOUT THE MARINERS,
BUT I DON'T CARE A TON ABOUT,
RUN DIFFERENTIAL.
CHRIS: AT THIS POINT IN THE
YEAR, YES, RUN DIFFERENTIAL
MATTERS.
IT TELLS YOU ABOUT YOUR TEAM.
BUT, GOING INTO THE LAST MONTH
OF THE SEASON, AS THE TEAM, YOU
ARE NOT WORRIED ABOUT IT.
CAN'T WORRY ABOUT THAT ANYMORE.
IT DOESN'T MATTER HOW WE GOT
HERE.
ALL THAT MATTERS IS THAT WE ARE
DOESN'T MATTER THAT WE ARE MINUS
45 RUN DIFFERENTIAL.
THAT'S A BIG DEAL AND IT SPEAKS
A LOT TO THEIR BULLPEN, BUT WHEN
YOU'RE PLAYING THE GAME, YOU ARE
NOT WORRIED ABOUT ANY OF THAT
RIGHT NOW.
YOU ARE JUST HAPPY TO BE IN THIS
POSITION.
SCOTT: A LOT OF LATE OFFENSE AND
A SHUTDOWN BULLPEN FOR SEATTLE
PART OF THAT ONE RUN RECORD.
THIS IS THE CAREER
PINCHHITTING LINE FOR JAKE
BAUERS, 7-33.
IN HIS LAST 17 GAMES, HE IS
10-30.
SO IN 2007 THERE WAS ARIZONA
DIAMONDBACKS TEAM THAT WON THE
A.L. WEST, N.L. WEST WITH A
-20 RUN DIFFERENTIAL.
THE MARINERS ARE AT -56.
CHRIS: I KNOW A BIT ABOUT THAT
TEAM.
I THINK I PLAYED ON THAT TEAM.
SCOTT: YOU DID.
CHRIS: WITH THAT TEAM IN 2007,
I REMEMBER WE DEPENDED ON OUR
BULLPEN SO MUCH.
WE HAD GOOD STARTING PITCHING.
BUT WE NEEDED OUR BULLPEN.
WE KNEW WE COULD PLAY SEVEN
INNING GAMES.
BRANDON LYON WAS OUT THERE.
IF WE COULD BE CLOSE AFTER SEVEN
WE FELT CLOSE THAT WE COULD WIN.
THE MARINERS ARE IN THAT
POSITION NOW.
SCOTT: YOU LED THAT 2007 TEAM
WITH 27 HOME RUNS.
TIES UP THE GAME.
FRESH CONTEST.
LET'S STRETCH.
♪
>> COME JOIN THE TEAM.
BE A PART OF THE ASTROS BUDDIES
CLUB.
KIDS 12 AND UNDER CAN SIGN UP TO
BE A MEMBER OF THE CLUB WHERE
MEMBERS GET ACCESS TO EXCLUSIVE
ACTIVITIES, BACKPACK, SOCKS AND
HAT, ALL FOR ONLY $25.
SHOW YOUR ASTROS PRIDE AT
SCHOOL AND AT THE BALLPARK.
GET YOUR MEMBERSHIP BY VISITING
ASTROS.COM/BUDDIES.
>> LOOKING FOR FUN WITH THE
FAMILY THIS SUMMER?
LOOK NO FURTHER THAN MINUTE MAID
PARK.
>> CARLOS CORREA!
♪
>> A WALKOFF GRAND SLAM!
>> BALL RIPPED DOWN THE RIGHT
SIDE.
ASTROS WIN IT!
>> GE TYOUR TICKETS NOW AT
ASTROS.COM/TICKETS.
SCOTT: THE POST SEASON RACE IS
ON.
MLB.TV.
RESTRICTIONS APPLY.
VISIT MLB.TV FOR DETAILS.
COMING OFF THE SEVENTH INNING
STRETCH WHERE WE GAVE OUT SOME
PEANUTS AND CRACKER JACKS.
IT WAS FUN.
A TRADITION IN THE ASTROS BOOTH.
WORST RUN DIFFERENTIAL AMONG
TEAMS WITH A .500.
THEY ARE NINE GAMES OVER AT
-56.
MEANWHILE, THE ASTROS ARE PLUS
176, THIRD BEST IN MAJOR LEAGUE
BEST --  BASEBALL.
GUESS WHAT?
TO  ME, THAT ALSO GIVE EXTRA
CREDIT TO SCOTT SERVAIS AND THE
MANAGER OF THE YEAR RACE IN THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE.
MANAGING TIGHT BALLGAMES
INTERNING TURNING UP WITH
VICTORIES AND THAT HELP.
-- AND TURNING UP WITH
VICTORIES.
THAT HELPED.
FORGET RUN DIFFERENTIAL.
HE CALLS IT FUN DIFFERENTIAL.
CHRIS: AS A MANAGER YOU HAVE TO
MAKE A LOT OF CLUTCH CALLS AND
WITHOUT THOSE ONE RUN GAMES,
THOSE MARINERS ARE IN A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT POSITION.
WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT THE
MARINERS ARE DOING THEIR GAME.
BEING ABLE TO WIN THOSE CLOSE
GAMES GIVES THE TEAM THE EXTRA
BOOST OF CONFIDENCE TO WHERE YOU
FEEL LIKE YOU ARE NEVER OUT OF
THE GAME AND YOU ARE READY TO
PLAY IN YOUR BEING VERY
COMPETITIVE AND IT IS GREAT FOR
THEM.
SCOTT: ANTHONY MISIEWICZ IN THE
GAME.
FIRING A STRIKE.
BRANTLEY, GURRIEL, ALVAREZ DUE
UP FOR HOUSTON IN THE HOME
SEVENTH.
BRANTLEY IS HITLESS TODAY.
CHRIS: WE A EARLIE-- WE SAID
EARLIER, CAN THE KEYS TO THE
GAME, YOU HAVE TO STAY WITHIN
STRIKING DISTANCE.
THEY ARE THERE.
SCOTT: NOW IT IS UP TO THE
BULLPEN.
IT BOUNCES OFF HIS PITCHING
HAND AND TURNS INTO AN INFIELD
KNOCK FOR MICHAEL BRANTLEY.
WE'LL SEE IF HE'S OK.
THAT'S A HIT.
AND HOW'S THAT LEFT-HAND?
CAN SEE WHERE IT GOT HIM.
CHRIS: HE'S RUBBING THE BALL
DOWN.
I THINK HE IS STAYING IN THE
GAME.
HIS BODY LANGUAGE LOOKED LIKE HE
WAS HURTING QUITE A BIT RIGHT
THERE.
HE WAS IN BETWEEN TRYING TO USE
HIS GLOVE AND HIS HAND.
SOMETIMES YOU WILL SEE PITCHERS
JUST TRY TO GET OUT OF THE WAY
AND LET THEIR DEFENSE BEHIND THE
MAKE THE PLAY BUT HE GOT HIS
FEET TIED UP TO WHERE HE FELT
SOMETHING ON HIS ANKLE OR HIS
LEGS TO WHERE HE WAS LIMPING.
JUST AN AWKWARD PLAY, VERY
AWKWARD.
LOOKS LIKE HE'S DOING ALL RIGHT,
THOUGH.
SCOTT: ALWAYS GO GLOVE.
YOHAN RAMIREZ IS THERE JUST IN
CASE.
MANAGERS TOLD HIM YOU CAN SHOW A
LITTLE BIT.
LOOKS LIKE DIEGO CASTILLO IN THE
BULLPEN IS ALSO JUST STARTING TO
STRETCH THE ARM AND GET READY.
GREAT POINT BY COWBOY JEFF.
THE ASTROS ALWAYS SEEM TO BE IN
CLOSE GAMES IN THESE GAMES OF
THE WEEK.
YEAH, JEFF.
WE THANK THEM FOR THAT.
GURRIEL ON THE GROUND AND THIS
COULD BE TWO.
CRAWFORD FIRES TO FIRST IN TIME.
AND SUDDENLY THE LEFT-HAND FEELS
EVEN BETTER.
CHRIS: ABSOLUTELY.
HE LEADS THE MARINERS AND
APPEARANCES THIS SEASON.
HE IS A DEPENDABLE GUY.
HE'S GOING TO FIND HIS WAY INTO
THE LINEUP WHEN THE GAME STARTS.
ON HIS WAY TO THE MOUND.
SCOTT: BRANTLEY TAKES CARE OF
GURRIEL.
SWEET TURN THERE BY J.P.
CRAWFORD.
OFF THE FEED FROM TORO.
AND HERE COMES YORDAN ALVAREZ.
ONE MORE LOOK FROM GURRIEL.
YOU SAID IT, STILL LIMPING A
BIT.
BRUCE SAVAGE 26 YEARS OLD --
MUSIEWICZ, 26 YEARS OLD, FACING
YORDAN ALVAREZ.
LEFTY ON LEFTY, ALTHOUGH I WILL
SAY ALVAREZ IS NO PROBLEM -- HIS
YOUNG CAREER.
CHRIS: NO PROBLEM WITH HIM.
ABLE TO STAY SQUARE.
SCOTT: HE LIFTS ONE TO RIGHT
CENTER.
HANGING UP THERE FOR HANIGER TO
PUT HIM AWAY.
THE OFF HIT FOR BRANTLEY.
GURRIEL BOUNCES INTO A DOUBLE
PLAY.
AFTER SEVEN, 4-4.
>> I AM FROM SEATTLE,
WASHINGTON.
SCOTT: ANOTHER GREAT ONE.
THE MLB GAME OF THE WEEK IS
PRESENTED BY YOUTUBE SHORTS.
WATCH AND CREATE VIDEOS I KNEW
TWO.
TRY SHORTS ON YOUR PHONE AND
CHECK OUT THE ASTROS PAGE FOR
BEHIND THE SCENES TAKES FROM
YOUR FAVORITE PLAYERS, COACHES,
BROADCASTERS AND MORE.
VISIT YOUTUBE.COM/ASTROS TO
SUBSCRIBE TODAY.
BALLGAME STILL FRESH.
4-4.
WE ARE IN THE EIGHTH.
KENDALL GRATEFULLY AGAINST HIS
FORMER BALLCLUB, THE 30-YEAR-OLD
HAVING A CAREER SEASON, E.R.A.
AT 1.69.
I REMEMBER WHEN HE WAS A
STARTING PITCHER IN 2015, SOFT T
OSSER, PITCHING LOW 90'S,
91-ISH.
NOW THE SINKER AMPERAGE IS --
AVERAGES 96.
HE'S TRANSFORMED IT INTO A
SERIOUS WEAPON OUT OF THE
BULLPEN.
CHRIS: WHAT A TRANSFORMATION
THAT IS.
WHEN HE IS ON THE MOUND YOU'RE
GOING UP THERE KNOWING HE WILL
GIVE YOU A SINKER BUT HE HAS A
BIG DEPTH ON IT TO IT'S A
STRUGGLE TO GET TO.
SCOTT: TRADED AT THE DEADLINE
FROM SEATTLE TO HOUSTON.
ASTROS NEEDED BULLPEN HELP.
THIS WAS THEIR BIG TARGET.
HERE HE IS PITCHING IN THE
EIGHT.
SCORELESS EIGHT LAST NIGHT, 15
PITCHES TO GET THE JOB DONE.
MARMOLEJOS IN THE NINE SPOT.
DOUBLED IN THE FOURTH.
TAKES A STRIKE TO START OFF THE
EIGHTH.
CHRIS: RIGHT AT THE FIRST PITCH
SLIDER, YOU'RE KEEPING EVERYBODY
HONEST, MAKE SURE IS NOT TRYING
TO JUMP SHIP OR SNEAK ATTACK YOU
RIGHT OUT OF THE GATE.
SHOWED THE SLIDER FIRST.
THEN GO TO YOUR BREAD AND
BUTTER, WHICH IS THAT SINKER.
SCOTT: HAD FUN WITH THAT.
CHRIS: WHAT I DID LIKE ABOUT
SEEING THE PERSONAL SIDE OF
PLAYERS WHEN HE DID GET TRADED
FROM SEATTLE HE WAS VERY
EMOTIONAL ABOUT IT.
YOU REALIZE THE TYPE OF BONDS
THESE GUYS HAVE WITH EACH OTHER.
SCOTT: MARMOLEJOS NOT PLEASED
WITH A CALLED STRIKE THREE.
FROZEN.
CHRIS: A BORDERLINE PITCH RIGHT
THERE.
SCOTT: WHAT'S YOUR CALL?
CHRIS: IT IS BEEN A GREAT STRIKE
ZONE ALL DAY.
THAT IS A BORDERLINE PITCH.
I'M MAD IF I'M HITTING.
BUT ONCE I GO INTO THE VIDEO
ROOM OR MAYBE AFTER THE GAME TO
LOOK AT THAT PITCH, WHAT I'M
GOING TO SAY IS THAT YOU HAVE
NOT CALLED THAT ALL DAY.
SCOTT: SOUNDS GOOD.
CHRIS: NOT HAPPY ABOUT THAT.
SCOTT: THROUGH THE VACATED LEFT
SIDE.
ONE OUT KNOCK FOR J.P. CRAWFORD.
A MONEY PITCH FOR KENDALL
GRAVEMAN TO PICK UP THE FIRST
OUT, BUT NOW DEALING WITH THE
RUNNER ON FIRST AND CRAWFORD.
CHRIS: J.P. CRAWFORD BEING ABLE
TO BEAT THE SHIFT RIGHT THERE.
KEEPS FINDING A WAY TO GET ON
BASE, MAKE THINGS HAPPEN
ESPECIALLY AGAINST THE ASTROS.
SCOTT: IN CLUTCH MOMENTS.
WE'RE UP TO HANIGER.
HIS BASE HIT WAS OFF THE
THIRD-BASE BAG IN THE FIRST.
A TWO RUN FIRST INNING FOR
SEATTLE.
FIRST FIVE BATTERS WENT FOR AND
-- FOUR AND FIVE IN THE GAME.
THEY COOLED OFF AND PICK THINGS
BACK UP IN THE SEVENTH WITH TWO
MORE TO TIE THINGS UP THANKS TO
A JARRED KELENIC DOUBLE.
CHRIS: GREAT PITCH.
PAINTING DOWN IN THE ZONE.
HANIGER -- KNOWS TO BE
AGGRESSIVE IN THE BOX.
HE WAS READY TO MAKE A MOVE BUT
THAT SINKER IS SO SNEAKY HE
COULD NOT PULL THE TRIGGER ON
IT.
SCOTT: HANIGER DOES PULL THE
TRIGGER THIS TIME.
AND IT'S IN THE SHALLOW RIGHT,
IT IS GOING TO FALL.
ON TO SECOND IS THE THROW IN
TIME!
KYLE TUCKER DEKED US A BIT ON A
LITTLE BLOOPER THAT ENDS UP B
EING A FORCE OUT AT SECOND.
CHRIS: AND THAT IS A PLAY WHERE
NOBODY DID ANYTHING WRONG.
CRAWFORD DID EXACTLY WHAT HE WAS
SUPPOSED TO DO.
WHEN YOU'RE IN BETWEEN FIRST AND
SECOND AND YOU WATCH THAT BALL
IN THE  AIR, THERE IS NO REAL
WAY FOR YOU TO TELL OF TUCKER IS
GOING TO BE ABLE TO MAKE THAT
PLAY OR IF HE'S GOING TO LET IT
DROP.
AND TUCKER DID THE RIGHT THING
BY NOT GIVING UP ON THE BALL,
SHOWING THAT HE WAS COMING
AFTER.
WHEN THE BALL DROPS, HAVING THE
WHEREWITHAL TO KEEP HIS BEARINGS
TO MAKE A STRONG THROW TO SECOND
BASE.
AND A GREAT SNAGGED BY ALTUVE --
A GREAT SNAG BY ALTUVE.
ALTUVE HAD TO TURN TO A FIRST
BASEMAN RIGHT THERE.
SCOTT: WOW.
TWO DOWN IN THE EIGHTH.
CHRIS: GREAT CALL RIGHT THERE.
GREAT PLAY BYA GETTING STRETCHED
-- BY ALTUVE GETTING STRETCHED
OUT.
SCOTT: MONEY THROW.
A FIELDER'S CHOICE.
FOR MITCH HANIGER.
CHRIS: THAT IS THE MOST
UNFORTUNATE PART ABOUT THAT IS
YOU GET A FIELDER'S CHOICE.
COULD BE A SINGLE IF NOBODY WAS
ON BASE.
SCOTT: NO HIT FOR HANIGER,
MAKING HIM NOW 1-5 ON THE DAY.
KYLE SEAGER STERN.
-- KYLE SEAGER'S TURN.
KYLE TUCKER.
IS A SPECIAL BALLPLAYER.
TOOLS GALORE.
HE'S GOT POWER IN THE BAT.
HE CAN RUN.
CLEARLY CAN FIELD HIS POSITION.
YOUNG BALL PLAYER.
CHRIS: WHEN YOU THINK OF THE
ASTROS, KYLE TUCKER IS NOT THE
FIRST PERSON YOU THINK OUT.
WHEN YOU COME TO THE GAME IN SEE
HIS SKILL SET, SEE WHAT HE IS
ABLE TO DO ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
BALL, AND REALIZE HOW VALUABLE
HE IS TO HIS TEAM.
SCOTT: THAT ONE LOOKED LIKE IT
MISSED THE MARK ON THE CHANGEUP
FROM GRAVEMAN.
STRIKE ONE.
CHRIS: THE ZONE IS OPENING UP
LATE IN THE GAME.
SCOTT: THAT'S NOT.
SEAGER WAITED FOR A TICK.
CHRIS: SEAGER FROZE ON THAT ONE.
HERE WE GO.
SCOTT: GRAVEMAN IS LIKE, WHERE
WAS THE PITCH BEFORE?
NOT THAT THAT MATTERS, BUT.
KYLE SEAGER TAKE YOUR BASE.
THAT WAS LOW.
CHRIS: THAT'S A BALL.
SCOTT: MALDONADO IS AN EXCELLENT
FRAMER BEHIND THE PLATE.
LOOK AT WHERE HIS GLOVE ENDS UP,
RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF THE ZONE.
CHRIS: A VETERAN MOVE RIGHT
THERE.
SCOTT: TY FRANCE CLIMBS IN.
A SINGLE, DOUBLE AND TWO
STRIKEOUTS.
CHRIS: BEING VERY EFFECTIVE TO
RIGHT-HANDED SEE HITTERS.
--  RIGHT-HANDED HITTERS.
I DO NOT KNOW IF THAT BOTHERS TY
FRANCE BECAUSE HE IS NOT UP
THERE TRYING TO HIT IN
EXTRA-BASE HIT.
HE IS TRYING TO KEEP THE LINE
MOVING.
HE WILL TAKE A SLAP THE OTHER
WAY AND BE VERY HAPPY WITH IT.
SCOTT: WHERE IS THAT BASEBALL?
MALDONADO CAN'T FIND IT.
BOTH RUNNERS WILL MOVE UP.
GRAVEMAN HAD TO HELP AMOUNT FOR
SECOND.
-- HAD TO HELP HIM OUT.
CHRIS: RIGHT HERE, YOU HAVE
FRANCE, BEEN HOT ALL YEAR.
YOU HAVE TORO ON DECK WHO HAS
KILLED YOU SINCE THE TRADE
HAPPENED.
THIS IS A SITUATION WHERE IT IS
A TOUGH CALL TO MAKE FOR DUSTY
BREAKER, FOR MALDONADO-- AND
DUSTY BAKER, FOR GRAVEMAN, AND
FOR MALDONADO.
YOU HAVE THE RIGHTY-ON-RIGHTY
MATCHUP THAT YOU NORMALLY WOULD
WANT RIGHT HERE.
SCOTT: WILD PITCH FROM GRAVEMAN.
PICK YOUR POISON.
FRANCE HAS THE HIT TOOL.
AND HE PULLS ONE, THIRD BASE
SIDE.
THIS WILL DO IT.
ALL RIGHT.
WASN'T THE SMOOTHEST DAY FOR
KENDALL GRAVEMAN BUT NO RUNS
COME ACROSS FOR SEATTLE.
THEY STRAND TWO IN SCORING
POSITION AND THIS GAME REMAINS
TIED AT 4-4.
>> THEY COME EVERY DAY AND THEY
SUPPORT US.
THEY ARE OUT THERE SCREAMING AND
REPLAY BETTER AS A TEAM.
>> WE HAVE THE BEST FANS IN
BASEBALL.
WE GO OFF THEM.
>> THIS IS ONE OF THE MOST
COMMUNITY MINDED TEAMS I HAVE
EVER BEEN IN.
THESE GUYS ARE VERY AWARE THAT
THEY ARE PART OF THE COMMUNITY.
I HAD A LONG CONVERSATION WITH A
LOT OF THE GUYS.
HAD A REAL LONG CONVERSATION
WITH BREGMAN.
YOU GOT ALTUVE, AN YOU GOT
CORREA IN ALL THESE GUYS ALWAYS
STEP UP FOR THE COMMUNITY.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS PRETTY COOL.
>> LET'S DO IT.
SCOTT: LOCKED UP AT  4-4.
ASTROS HAVE DONE IT AND TAKEN A
COUPLE OF PENNANTS AND ONE
CHAMPIONSHIP.
THE CARDINALS AND BRAVES IN THE
1990'S.
THE YANKS ARE THE LAST TEAM TO
WIN BACK-TO-BACK WORLD SERIES,
THREE IN A ROW IN THAT TIME
PERIOD.
THEN YOU LOOK AT THAT OAKLAND
TEAM IN THE 70'S.
IT ODESN'T HAPPEN -- DOESN'T
HAPPEN OFTEN TO GET THAT
CONSISTENT SUCCESS WE HAVE SEEN
FROM THIS HOUSTON FRANCHISE.
ALSO, I THINK HOW DIFFICULT IT
IS TO WIN BACK TO BACK WORLD
SERIES TITLES.
WE HAVE NOT SEEN IN OVER 20
YEARS I THINK THE TEAM THAT WON
LAST YEAR, STILL HAS A GOOD
SHOT.
THE LOS ANGELES DODGERS FIGHTING
FOR THE N.L. WEST AND WE WILL
GET TO THEM IN A MOMENT.
DIEGO CASTILLO IS ABOUT TO MAKE
HIS 50TH APPEARANCE.
HE STARTED THE YEAR IN TAMPA
BAY, ONE OF THEIR BETTER
RELIEVERS, CLOSING OUT GAMES AND
YOU KNOW THAT RAYS.
WE HAVE THE MOTIONS.
CHRIS: YOU HAVE  A TRUE SLIDER.
DIEGO CASTILLO IS A MAJORITY
SLIDER GUY.
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THAT MUCH
CONFIDENCE IN YOUR SLIDER TO
WHERE GUYS KNOW THEY ARE GOING
TO GET IT AND THEY STILL CAN HIT
IT -- CAN'T HIT IT, THAT SHOWS
YOU THE DEFINITELY HAS ON IT.
SCOTT: THERE IT IS TO CARLOS
CORREA.
CHRIS: THAT WAS A SHORT SLIDER,
TOO.
ALMOST HAD A CUTTER ACTION, JUST
ENOUGH TO GET YOU OFF THE
BARREL.
BUT HE CAN THROW STRIKES WITH IT
AS WELL.
SCOTT: DIFFERENT VERSIONS OF THE
SLIDER.
MAKING IT LIKE MULTIPLE PITCHES.
THAT ONE IS CONNECTED.
IT IS A FASTBALL.
CORREA LIKES IT.
HE'S ON TO THE LEADOFF HIT IN
THE EIGHTH.
CHRIS: THIS IS WHAT THE ASTROS
DO.
CORREA'S BEEN HAVING GREAT
AT-BATS OF LATE.
CONSISTENTLY PUTTING GREAT
AT-BATS TOGETHER, COMING THROUGH
LATE IN THE GAME.
YOU GET CORREA IN THE SEVENTH,
EIGHTH AND NINTH INNING, IT IS
ALL MOST A GUARANTEE THAT HE
WILL COME THROUGH ON YOU.
SCOTT: MAKES A -- PICKS A GOOD
SPOT.
LOOKS OVER TO THE DUGOUT TO PUMP
THEM UP.
DISAPPOINTED.
CHRIS: WHAT HE IS DISAPPOINTED
IS IN THE SHIFT.
FEEL LIKE SOMEBODY IS SUPPOSED
TO BE RIGHT THERE.
IT MESSES WITH SOME PITCHERS.
I PLAYED WITH SOME GUYS THAT
WOULD RATHER NOT HAVE THE SHIFT
AT ALL AND TAKE -- THEIR
MEDICINE.
THEY COULD NOT STAND THAT ONE
TIME YOU HIT THE BALL RIGHT AT
WHERE SOMEBODY SHOULD BE AND IT
GIVES UP A BASE HIT, ESPECIALLY
LATE IN GAMES.
SCOTT: SOMEONE IN THE FRONT
OFFICE HAS TO PUT TOGETHER OF
HIGH THE -- THE
HIGHLIGHT REEL OF ALL THE TIMES
THAT IT HELPS AND SAY, LOOK,
WATCH THIS.
KYLE TUCKER HAS BEEN ON BASE IN
FIVE OF HIS LAST SIX AT-BATS.
HE IS SMOKING HOT NOW.
CHRIS: BACK TO CORREA.
THREE OF HIS HITS OVER 100.
THAT ONE THERE WAS 99. AND SOME
CHANGE.
SCOTT: THE FIRST THREE TIMES UP,
YOU'RE SAYING.
OH, 99.
CHRIS: LET'S GIVE HIM FOUR WALLS
AT 100 MILES AN HOUR.
SCOTT: TWO WERE OUTS.
TWO OF THEM WERE SINGLES.
TWO STRIKES ON KYLE TUCKER.
SINCE COMING OFF THE COVID I.L.
13 GAMES UP UNTIL TODAY AND THEN
THE NUMBERS  LOOK MORE
VIDEOGAME-ISH.
2-2, DOUBLE, TRIPLE, WALK.
AND IN THE LAST TWO WEEKS, THIS
IS THE GUY YOU WANT UP IF YOU
ARE HOUSTON.
CHRIS: A LOT OF SITUATIONS WHEN
YOU COME OFF THE I.L, AND YOU
PUT UP NUMBERS LIKE THAT IT IS
LIKE A HUGE TRADE ACQUISITION
LATE IN THE SEASON.
SCOTT: HIM AND BREGMAN COMING
BACK AROUND THE SAME TIME.
GONE FISHING.
CHRIS: THAT SLIDER IS NASTY.
HE SEES THAT BALL AS THE SAME
SINKER AND HE ATTACKS IT LIKE IT
IS A SINKER.
BUT THEN, GOT TO GUESS, PICKING
AND CHOOSING.
HE GUESSED SINKER AND HE WAS
WRONG.
SCOTT: JAKE MEYERS IS HITLESS IN
THREE TRIPS TODAY.
LOOK AT THAT LINE FOR THE
ROOKIE.
ABOUT A MONTH OF BASEBALL, OVER
.300 WITH THE BATTING AVERAGE
FOR THE CENTER FIELDER.
CHRIS: WHAT I LIKE ABOUT
CASTILLO.
HE'S STAYING DOWN IN THE ZONE,
TRYING AWAY --  TRYING TO STAY
AWAY FROM DAMAGE PITCHERS.
DOESN'T TAKE MUCH TO GET IT OUT
OF THERE.
SO, HE'S STAYING DOWN, DOWN AND
DOWN.
TRY TO GET HIS GROUNDBALL, TRY
TO GET A DOUBLE PLAY.
SCOTT: DOWN FOR A SWING AND
MISS.
CHRIS: THAT IS ONE OF THOSE
PITCHES ON TV.
THAT PITCH THERE IS PAINTED ON
THE CORNER DOWN AND AWAY.
THERE IS NO CHANCE IN A 1-0
COUNT THE YOU ARE ABLE TO DRIVE
THAT BALL.
THAT'S A PITCH YOU HAVE TWO
STRIKES ON YOU AND YOU CHOKE
DOWN AND PEPPER IT THE OTHER
WAY.
SCOTT: CASTILLO IS JUST RECENTLY
BACK FROM THE INJURED LIST.
RIGHT SHOULDER INFLAMMATION.
HE DID APPEAR YESTERDAY IN THE
EIGHTH INNING, SCORELESS INNING.
TOOK HIM 20 PITCHES.
CHRIS: HIS VELO'S DOWN A LITTLE
BIT.
HE'S AVERAGING 94.
LAST YEAR AVERAGING 96.
SCOTT: A STRIKE.
CHRIS: HE GETS THAT STRIKE CALL
BECAUSE HE IS SO CLOSE TO THE
ZONE ON EVERY SINGLE PITCH.
WHERE THE UMPIRE IS, HE'S GUES
SING.
THEY ALL LOOK LIKE STRIKES.
I'M TRYING TO, AND IT IS SO HARD
TO GAUGE THAT.
SCOTT: IT WAS IN THE ZONE 90% OF
THE WAY ENTAILED OFF AT THE END.
MEYERS WITH AN UNDERWATER SWING
AND HE GOES DOWN.
CHRIS: THAT WAS AN IMPRESSIVE
SEQUENCE, WORKING THAT SLIDER
DOWN AND AWAY.
SINKER DOWN AND IN.
ALL AROUND THE PLATE THE ENTIRE
TIME.
AND ABLE TO EXPAND LATE WITH TWO
STRIKES.
THAT WAS BEAUTIFUL.
I HONESTLY ANYBODY WOULD'VE
STRUCK OUT WITH THAT SEQUENCE.
SCOTT: THAT WAS A SPECIAL
SEQUENCE PUT TOGETHER BY DIEGO
CASTILLO.
FOOLING THE ROOKIE MEYERS.
NOW DEALING WITH THE VETERAN
MARWIN GONZALEZ, WHO HOMERED IN
THE SECOND.
SIMILAR SWING THERE THAT WE SAW
FROM MYERS.
CHRIS: THESE GUYS ARE SO
UNCOMFORTABLE AND THEY ARE NOT
ABLE TO PICK UP THAT SPIN.
THEY SEE IT POPPING OUT OF HIS
HAND AND THEY ARE LITERALLY
GUESSING, IS THIS A SINKER OR
SLIDER?
SCOTT: ALEX BREGMAN IS GOING, I
WOULD NOT HAVE SWUNG AT THAT.
DID YOU SEE ME YESTERDAY?
WE'LL SEE.
IF MARWIN CAN KEEP THIS INNING
GOING.
HAD SOME REALLY CLUTCH HITS IN
ASTROS FRANCHISE HISTORY.
HE'S RECEIVED BY FAR THE BEST
OVATION BEING HERE INSIDE THE
BALLPARK MULTIPLE TIMES, SEEING
THE CROWD GO NUTS FOR MARWIN
GONZALEZ.
HE TOOK THAT ONE, BUT IT IS IN
THE ZONE.
CHRIS: IT DRIVES OUT THROUGH THE
ZONE.
WHEN YOU SWING AT IT, IT DROPS.
THERE WAS A TIME WHERE YOU
HAD CASTILLO IN TAMPA, CASTILLO
AND ALVARADO IN THE SAME
BULLPEN.
SCOTT: MOVEMENT OFF THE CHARTS
FROM BOTH OF THEM.
PULLED FOUL BY GONZALEZ.
BACK IN THE SECOND INNING.
KYLE TUCKER ON.
MARWIN GONZALEZ.
TWO THE CRAWFORD BOXES.
AND BEYOND.
400 FEET.
THE FIRST HOME RUN BACK WITH THE
ASTROS.
HIS THIRD ON THE SEASON.
CHRIS: THIS PLACE HAS TO FEEL
LIKE HOME FOR HIM.
SCOTT: HE IS IN AN 0-2 HOLE.
HE DIDN'T GO.
TEMPTING.
DIEGO CASTILLO IS FEELING
HIMSELF RIGHT NOW.
CHRIS: THESE NEXT COUPLE OF
PITCHES HE WILL CONTINUE TO TRY
TO EXPAND THE ZONE.
I DO NOT SEE HIM GIVING MARWIN
ANYTHING TO HIT.
GO SLIDER, DOWN AND IN ON HIM.
HE CAN SNEAK THAT SINKER AWAY ON
HIM AS WELL.
BUT I HAVEN'T SEEN A PITCH
MIDDLE UP THIS ENTIRE INNING.
HE IS STAYING OUT OF TROUBLE,
STAYING DOWN IN THE ZONE.
ABOUT TO SEE THE SINKER RIGHT
HERE.
SINKER AWAY.
SCOTT: NICE JOB TO STAY ALIVE.
JUST WAITING FOR A MISTAKE THAT
HAS NO HAPPENED.
CHRIS: THAT WAS A GREAT PIECE OF
HITTING BY MARWIN.
THAT'S A FOUL BALL BUT THAT WINS
HIM ANOTHER PITCH.
THIS BALL TAKES OFF.
MARWIN'S ABLE TO COVER THAT BUT
THAT TELLS ME HE MAY HAVE
SOMEWHERE HE CAN EXPOSE HIM ON
THE INSIDE.
IF YOU CAN COVER THAT, NOW WE
ARE GOING TO GO IN AND SEE IF HE
CAN COVER BOTH SIDES.
SCOTT: OH, WOW.
WHAT AN INNING FROM DIEGO
CASTILLO..
CHRIS: CAN'T COVER BOTH.
SCOTT: AFTER THE CORREA SINGLE,
TUCKER, MYERS, GONZALEZ.
FOOLISH.
DIEGO CASTILLO BROUGHT HIS
A-PLUS STUFF INTO THE. EIGHTH
INNING
IT'S THE MARINERS TRYING IN THE
NINTH.
COMING UP.
♪
>> I'M
>> WE GO TO THE NINTH INNING,
TIED AT 4-4.
THE MARINERS HAVE NOT HIT A HOME
RUN, YOU MAY LOSE THIS BET IN
PERCENTAGE OF HOME RUN SPEARED
THE GIANTS LEAD EVERYBODY A 51%.
49% OF THE RUNS COME WITH THE
LONG BALL.
YOU CAN SEE WHY AND GAMES THEY
DO NOT HOMER 13-26.
WE WILL SEE IF THEY CAN CHANGE
THAT OR IF THEY ARE HEADED
TOWARDS EXTRA INNINGS AGAIN,
ANOTHER AREA THEY NORMALLY HAVE
GREAT SUCCESS WITH.
SCOTT: THANKS, BRETT.
I MEAN, YESTERDAY WE SAW EXTRAS
IN SEATTLE NOT COMING OUT ON
TOP.
BUT THE MARINERS IN CLOSE, LATE
SITUATIONS HAVE BEEN CLUTCH ALL
YEAR.
THEY'RE HOPING IT RIDES THEM I
NTO A POSTSEASON.
GOOD LUCK WITH RYAN PRESSLY, THE
ALL-STAR, WITH THE E.R.A. SOUTH
OF 2.0.
NINTH INNING ACTION.
TORO, TORRENS, KELENIC.
A STRIKE TO ABRAHAM TORO WHO IS
2-3 WITH A HOME RUN AND A DOUBLE
OFF THE ASTROS'  RELIEVER.
THAT HOMER-- CAME IN HIS JULY
27.
HE'S SWINGING THE BAT WELL.
CHRIS: A LOT OF SUCCESS.
A FASTBALL SLIDER CURVE MIX.
SCOTT: LOOK WHAT HAPPENED TO
RYAN PRESSLY LAST NIGHT.
♪
BRANTLEY FOULS THE BALL OFF OF
PRESLEY IN THE DUGOUT.
HE GOT DRILLED IN THE DUGOUT.
LIMPING.
CHRIS: DIDN'T LOOK LIKE HE WAS
TOO HAPPY ABOUT THAT.
SCOTT: HE PITCH IN THE NINTH,
TRAILING 3-2.
OH, WOW.
BURIES ONE IN THE DIRT.
TORO GOES AFTER IT AND STRIKE
OUT NUMBER ONE FOR PRESSLY IN
THE NINTH.
BUT, YESTERDAY, TORO GOT HIM FOR
A DOUBLE AND TORRENS BROUGHT
TORO HOME WITH AN R.B.I. SINGLE.
THIS TIME, GO FOR THAT.
TWO SECONDARY PITCHES THAT ARE
STANDUP.
CHRIS: YOU GO AHEAD AND TAKE A
GAMBLE, EXPAND THE ZONE, SPIKE
ONE.
HE WANTS TO MAKE SURE NOT TO
HANG THIS PITCH.
BURY IT IN THE DIRT.
SCOTT: IT IS TORRENS WHO GOT TO
HIM FOR THE R.B.I. HIT
YESTERDAY.
TODAY HE'S 0-3 WITH A WALK.
A LONG SWING.
CHRIS: A SLIDER ON THE CORNER.
SCOTT: THE DOMINANT PITCH FOR
RYAN PRESSLY.
ONE EXTRA-BASE HIT THIS YEAR.
HE CONNECTS, RIGHT CENTER FIELD.
LUIS TORRENS WITH A HIT IN
BACK-TO-BACK DAYS OFF OF RYAN
PRESSLY.
THIS GAME IS TIED AT 4-4 BECAUSE
JARRED KELENIC CONTRIBUTED A
DOUBLE THAT WENT A LONG WAY.
STATCAST POWERED BY GOOGLE
CLOUD.
387 FEET, A HOMER IN TWO
BALLPARKS.
SCORES TWO.
THE ROOKIE COMING THROUGH.
THE MARINERS IN YET ANOTHER
CLOSE GAME.
CHRIS: LOOKING TO COME THROUGH
IN ANOTHER CLUTCH SITUATION,
POTENTIALLY GETTING THE PLAYER
IN THE GAME.
IF HE CAN COME THROUGH ANDGET
THAT GO-AHEAD R.B.I.
SCOTT: DYLAN MOORE IS IN THE
GAME -- R.B.I.
GAME.
CHRIS: THE ONLY DISADVANTAGE,
YOU SEE CORREA PULL OVER TO THE
RIGHT SIGNED OF SECOND BASE.
THE ONLY DISADVANTAGE, IT IS
TOUGH TO GET THE DOUBLE PLAY
BALL THAT YOU NEED TO GET OUT OF
THE INNING.
THE TRADE-OFF IS, YOU COVER ON
THE RIGHT SIDE, BUT THE
DISADVANTAGE IS, YOU MAY HAVE TO
GET TWO GUYS TO GET OUT.
SCOTT: PRESSLY IS TRYING TO GET
RID OF THE RUNNER.
CHRIS: KEEPING HIM CLOSE.
SCOTT: HAS ONLY ALLOWED TWO
STOLEN BASES IN THE LAST COUPLE
OF SEASONS.
DUSTY'S GROUP GOING FOR A SWEEP
TODAY.
WHAT A GAME.
KELENIC TAKES IT DOWN.
CHRIS: 18-22 IN STOLEN BASES.
PRESSLY HAS GOOD REASONS TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT HIM.
YOU HAVE TO KEEP HIM CLOSE, TRY
TO KEEP THE DOUBLE PLAY IN ORDER
AS MUCH AS YOU CAN AND HOPE THEY
HAVE THE EARNED TWO HITS TO GET
THIS RUNNER TO SCORE.
THE QUICK SLIDE STEP, IT WILL BE
TOUGH FOR HIM TO GET THIS BACK
UP.
SCOTT: WITH MALDONADO BEHIND THE
DISH.
CHRIS: SOMETIMES WHAT WILL
HAPPEN WHEN YOU'RE FOCUSING ON
THAT RUN ON FIRST BASE, YOU
DON'T FOCUS ON THE HITTER AS
MUCH AS YOU NEED TO, YOU GET
BEHIND IN THE COUNT.
LEAVE THE BALL IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE PLATE.
KELENIC WAS FEELING GOOD TODAY.
SCOTT: SINGLE, DOUBLE.
BACK PICK TRY.
MOORE IS SAFE.
MALDONADO, SNEAKY.
CHRIS: YADI MOLINA
IMPERSONATION.
ABLE TO SCOOP THE BALL, MAKE A
PERFECT THROW TO FIRST BASE.
SOME CATCHERS WOULD GO DOWN TO A
KNEE, LOCK THE BALL SO IT DOES
NOT GET BY HIM.
SCOTT: ARE YOU SWINGING HERE,
3-0, IF IT IS A GOOD ONE?
CHRIS: NO.
SCOTT: SAME STORY FOR KELENIC.
TWO ON, ONE OUT IN THE NINTH.
CHRIS: WE TALKED ABOUT IT
EARLIER, WE HAVE TO KEEP THE
LINE MOVING.
DON'T HAVE TO BE THE HERO, DON'T
TRY TO DO TOO MUCH.
A LOT OF TIMES YOU WILL SEE
YOUNG GUYS TRY TO DO TOO MUCH.
KELENIC HAVING A GREAT DAY, ABLE
TO STAY WITHIN HIMSELF, TRIED TO
KEEP THE LINE MOVING.
SCOTT: THE CATCHER SPOT, KYLE
RALLY DUE UP.
-- CAL RALEIGH DUE UP.
WALKS ISSUED BY RYAN PRESSLY THE
SEASON.
NOW RALEIGH, WHO WAS CRUSHING
THE BASEBALL AT AAA TACOMA THIS
YEAR, .324 FROM THE CATCHER WITH
A .608 SLUGGING PERCENTAGE.
HAS BEEN QUIETER IN THE BIGS.
HE SAID HE IS NOT HANDLING SOME
PITCHES THAT HE DESTROYED IN THE
MINORS.
THIS WOULD BE A GOOD TIME TO
FIGURE IT ALL OUT.
CHRIS: A GOOD TIME TO PUT IT
ALTOGETHER.
THIS WAS A GAME THE MARINERS
NEED.
YOU HAD A BLOWOUT ON THE FIRST
GAME.
LAST NIGHT YOU HAD A VERY CLOSE
GAME THAT THE MARINERS WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO WALK AWAY
WITH.
NOW YOU SEE THE SAME SITUATION
ON YOUR GETAWAY DAY.
THE ONLY WAY TO CREATE A HAPPY
FLIGHT IS TO GET THIS WIN.
IF YOU COME TO HOUSTON AND GET
SWEPT, IT DOES PUT A DAMPER ON
YOUR FEELINGS FOR THIS PLAYOFF
PUSH.
GRANTED, YOU COULD PICK YOURSELF
UP EVEN IF YOU DON'T WIN THIS
GAME.
I THOUGHT LAST NIGHT FELT LIKE A
BIG GAME AS WELL.
SCOTT: I AGREE.
WE CAN SAY THAT IN MIDSUMMER
NUMBER.
SEATTLE IS THREE GAMES BACK.
PITCH GETS AWAY.
BOTH RUNNERS ARE MOVING UP.
IN THERE SAFELY.
MALDONADO WENT AFTER THE LEAD
RUNNER, MOORE.
HE GOT TO THIRD.
CHRIS: THAT IS TERRIFYING AS THE
BASE RUNNER.
YOU MAKE THE RIGHT CALL AND YOU
SEE IT RICOCHET OFF THE WALL.
THERE IS ABOUT TO BE A PLAY, I
HAVE TO GO.
LOOKS LIKE THERE WAS A MIXUP ON
PITCH SELECTION, WHICH IS WHY
THEY WILL HAVE A MEETING.
MALDONADO IS THINKING SLIDER.
PRESSLY IS THINKING HEATER.
SCOTT: VERY COSTLY BECAUSE A
DEEP ENOUGH FLY BALL COULD PUT
THE MARINERS BACK IN FRONT.
IT IS CALLED A WILD PITCH.
CHRIS: WITH ONE OUT HERE WITH
THE BASE OPEN, THE BENEFIT FOR
PRESSLY IS THAT YOU'RE STILL IN
THE BOTTOM OF THE LINEUP.
YOU WOULD IDEALLY LIKE TO GET
THE EIGHT WHOLE AND NINE-HOLE
HITTER OUT AS OPPOSED TO
ALLOWING HIM TO GET TO FIRST
BASE AND GIVE CRAWFORD ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY TO COME THROUGH IN A
BIG SITUATION LIKE YESTERDAY.
SCOTT: NOW YOU HAVE A FEW
CHANCES TO BURY THAT SIGNATURE
BALL.
CHRIS: TRUST YOUR CATCHER,
EXPAND THE ZONE, GIVE RALEIGH
SOMETHING TO CHASE.
TRUST THAT MALDONADO WILL
PREVENT THE BALL FROM GETTING TO
THE BACKSTOP.
SCOTT: 1-2.
CHRIS: THAT IS TRUST.
SCOTT: MALDONADO WITH WORK TO DO
THIS AFTERNOON.
CHRIS: PERFECT FORM, KEEPING THE
BALL IN THE MIDDLE OF HIS BODY,
TAKING IT OFF THE CHEST
PROTECTOR, KNOWING HE IS SAVING
THE RUN AND ACCEPTING THAT
PRESSURE.
HE IS TELLING THE CATCHER, TRUST
ME, I HAVE YOU.
SCOTT: DOES HE TRY AGAIN AT 2-2?
GOT HIM.
NO SWING FROM RALEIGH.
FROZEN FOR STRIKE THREE IN THE
SECOND PUNCH OUT OF THE DAY FOR
RYAN PRESSLY.
CHRIS: OUT OF HIS HAND HE IS
SEEING THE SLIDER SPIN.
HE IS ASSUMING THE BALL WILL
DROP THE SAME WAY THE PREVIOUS
PITCH DID, BUT THIS ALMOST HAD A
BACKUP SLIDER AFFECT TO WHERE IT
STAYED UP AND RODE THROUGH THE
ZONE AND HE KNEW IT WAS A
STRIKE.
BORDERLINE PITCHED TO MAKE IT
LOOK LIKE A STRIKE.
SCOTT: RYAN PRESSLY IS NOT A FUN
A.B.
NOW IT IS JOSE MARMOLEJOS.
MARTIN MALDONADO STEALING THE
SHOW, MAKING ANOTHER BIGS --
ANOTHER BIG STOP.
STRIKEOUTS BOOK ENDING A SINGLE
AND A WALK FOR THE MARINERS IN.
WILD PITCH MOVING BOTH RUNNERS
UP.
CHRIS: MARINERS HAVE STRANDED 12
RUNNERS TODAY.
SCOTT: MARMOLEJOS UP THE MIDDLE,
HE COMES THROUGH.
MARINERS GRABBED THE LEAD BACK
WITH ONE AND HERE IS ANOTHER.
DYLAN MOORE AND JARRED KELENIC
SCORE.
IT IS 6-4, SEATTLE.
CHRIS: HUGE HIT FOR MARMOLEJOS
TO COME THROUGH A CLUTCH
SITUATION.
DID HE TAKE ADVANTAGE AGAIN?
THAT IS A GROUND BALL RIGHT AT
THE SHORTSTOP, COVERS THAT PITCH
OFF THE PLATE, STAYS THROUGH
ITS.
RIGHT AT THE SHORTSTOP.
WHEN YOU ARE PRESSLY SITTING
THERE, THEY GIVE BOTH -- GIVETH
AND TAKETH AWAY.
SCOTT: THAT WILL DO IT FOR RYAN
PRESSLY.
BLAKE TAYLOR WILL TAKE OVER FOR
THE HOUSTON ASTROS, NOW DOWN BY
TWO.
STAY TUNED BECAUSE THE ASTROS
WERE DOWN BY TWO YESTERDAY AND
WE KNOW HOW THAT FINISHED UP.
>> SOMEONE SASSY.
IS THAT A CHEF, GOING ON A
CHIPOTLE RANT?
>> HANIGER?
DESCRIBING HIM AS SASSY?
I DON'T KNOW, HE WOULD BE SASSY
ABOUT PEOPLE BEING TERRIBLE
BURRITO WRAPPERS.
IS IT?
>> IS THIS FROM 2013?
10 YEARS AGO?
>> THAT IS SO MEAN.
HAVE A LITTLE COMPASSION.
SCOTT: IT IS THE MLB GAME OF THE
WEEK LIVE ON YOU TOBY -- YOUTUBE
PRESENTED BY YOUTUBE SHORTS.
TRY THE YOUTUBE SHORTS APP ON
YOUR PHONE.
ANOTHER DRAMATIC GAME ON YOUTUBE
THIS WEEK.
THE MARINERS GRAB THE LEAD BACK
IN THE NINTH FROM ALL-STAR
CLOSER RYAN PRESSLY, WHO PICKS
UP HIS THIRD BLOWN OF THE SEASON
IN 26 CHANCES AND IS NOW OUT OF
THE GAME, AS DUSTY BAKER SUMMONS
BLAKE TAYLOR, THE 26-YEAR-OLD
LEFT-HANDER IN THE NINTH, TRYING
TO PICK UP ONE MORE OUT AND GET
IT TO HIS ALL WORLD OFFENSE.
CHRIS: BLAKE TAYLOR, ANOTHER
FAST SLIDER GUY WITH EXTREME
SPLITS AGAINST LEFT-HANDED AND
RIGHT-HANDED HITTERS.
BATTING .123 OFF OF
LEFT-HANDERS.
RIGHT-HANDERS, .305 BATTING
AVERAGE.
SCOTT: HERE IS YOUR LEFTY
SWINGER, J.P. CRAWFORD.
HE DID NOT GO.
THAT IS BILL MILLER AT THIRD
BASE.
JOSE MARMOLEJOS PICTURED THERE
WITH A FEW STEPS OFF FIRST.
THE BIG MAN OF THE HOUR. TWO
STRIKES ON -- HOUR.
TWO STRIKES ON CRAWFORD.
SCORES TWO.
DYLAN MOORE AND JARRED KELENIC
MAKE IT A 6-4 CONTEST IN THE
NINTH.
YOUR NUMBER NINE HITTER AT THE
CLUTCH KNOCK.
HE HAD A BIG SEASON IN AAA.
CHRIS: COMING THROUGH CLUTCH IN
A BIG SITUATION.
IT DOES NOT MATTER IF SOMEONE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN PLAYING DEFENSE
THERE.
THAT WAS HUGE FOR SEATTLE.
FOR SEWALD, I AM ASSUMING HE IS
CLOSING THE GAME.
HE WILL HAVE HIS HANDS FULL.
MALDONADO IS SUPPOSED TO LEAD
OFF.
YOU WOULD ASSUME WE WOULD SEE
BREGMAN IN THIS SITUATION.
HE HAD HIS FEET UP IN THE FIRST
INNING, BUT I GUARANTEE HE IS
GETTING READY FOR THIS AT-BAT
AGAINST ALTUVE AND BRANTLEY.
SCOTT: ALL THE DRAMA THAT
UNFOLDED YESTERDAY.
I THINK HE SLEEPS WITH THAT BAT.
HE IS A BASEBALL JUNKIE.
SHOWS UP TO THE BALLPARK TO TAKE
SWINGS IN THE CAGE AT MIDNIGHT
FOR FUN., IF HE CAN'T SLEEP
CHRIS: IF SEWALD COMES IN, I AM
CURIOUS TO SEE HOW HE PITCHES
IN.
SCOTT: CRAWFORD DRAWS ONE TO
DEEP RIGHT FIELD.
TUCKER LOOKING BACK, AND FORGET
ABOUT IT!
IT IS GONE.
J.P. CRAWFORD FOR TWO TO MAKE IT
8-4, SEATTLE.
CHRIS: HUGE HIT, HANGING SLIDER.
HE SAYS, HE DOES NOT CARE ABOUT
THE SPLITS.
I DON'T CARE ABOUT THE LEFTY ON
LEFTY SPLITS, YOU SEE WHY?
IF HE HANGS IT, I BANG IT.
SCOTT: MUSCLE UP, MR. LEADOFF
MAN.
BIG EXTRA TWO FOR SEATTLE.
SEVENTH HOME RUN OF THE SEASON,
FOURTH HOME RUN IN HIS CAREER
OFF A LEFT-HANDED PITCHER.
CHRIS: THAT IS A HANGING SLIDER
HANGING OVER THE MIDDLE OF THE
FIELD.
AS SOON HE HITS, HE IS LOOKING
OVER THE DUGOUT.
SCOTT: HANIGER, HOT SHOT HANDLED
NICELY BY GONZALES.
WHAT A PICK BY GURRIEL AT FIRST.
J.P. CRAWFORD ADDS TWO  MORE FOR
THE M'S AFTER THE MARMOLEJOS TWO
RUN SINGLE.
A FOUR SPOT FOR SEATTLE SAYING,
DON'T SWEEP US, PLEASE, WE NEED
THIS GAME.
PAUL SEWALD AGAINST THE TEAM
THAT WON IT IN EXTRAS LAST
NIGHT, NEXT.
>> GORGEOUS EVENING FOR BASEBALL
IT MINIMIZE -- AT MINUTE MAID
PARK.
>> ASTROS HAVE LOST SEVEN IN A
ROW.
>> LOWEST SCORING TEAM IN MAJOR
LEAGUE BASEBALL.
>> 15-30 IS A BIG HILL TO
OVERCOME.
>> ASTROS WIN AGAIN.
>> THE ASTROS CLINCH THE
WILD-CARD.
>> THIS GAME TIED 6-6 IN THE
BOTTOM OF THE 18TH INNING.
>> LINING TO LEFT, IT IS GONE.
>> HOLY TOLEDO, WHAT A WAY TO
FINISH.
>> THIS CROWD IS READY TO ERUPT.
SEATTLE LEADS.
>> PUNJOL -- PJ -- PUJOLS GIVING
THE LEAD.
>> LET'S GET ON TO THE NEXT
GAME.
>> FLY BALL INTO RIGHT FIELD.
>> THE HOUSTON ASTROS ARE GOING
TO THE WORLD SERIES FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN FRANCHISE HISTORY.
♪
SCOTT: IT IS 8-4, SEATTLE.
THEY PUT UP FOUR AGAINST RYAN
PRESSLY AND BLAKE TAYLOR TO
BUILD AN ADVANTAGE GOING INTO
THE LAST OF THE NINTH.
FYI, THEY DID REVIEW THIS PLAY
TO END THE NINTH.
YULI GURRIEL DID KEEP THAT FOOT
ON THE BAG.
INNING OVER.
IT IS ALL GOOD.
IT IS ALL GREAT RIGHT NOW FOR
SCOTT SERVAIS AND THE SEATTLE
MARINERS UNTIL THEY LOOK UP AND
REALIZE THAT DUSTY BAKER GETS TO
REPLACE BREGMAN AS HIS PINCH
HITTER.
BREGMAN TO SAVE THE DAY FOR
HOUSTON IN THE NINTH YESTERDAY
AGAINST THE MAN ON THE MOUND
NOW.
PAUL SEWALD TRYING TO SHUT THE
DOOR FOR SEATTLE WITH A FOUR RUN
EDGE.
HE HAS BEEN AWESOME THIS YEAR.
HERE IS ANOTHER PITCHER THAT
COMPLETELY TRANSFORMS HIMSELF
FROM HIS DAYS WITH THE NEW YORK
METS.
SPEND A LOT OF TIME WITH THAT
ORGANIZATION, HE IS A REALLY
DIFFICULT LOOK.
LOW ARM ANGLE, 31 YEARS OLD.
HE IS HAVING A CAREER YEAR OUT
OF THE SEATTLE BULLPEN.
OVER 15 STRIKEOUTS PER NINE
INNINGS.
CHRIS: HE IS A GUY WHO DROPS AND
DRIVES THE FASTBALL, A FASTBALL
SLIDER GUY.
THE ONE HE GAVE UP TO BREGMAN
YESTERDAY WAS RARE FOR HIM,
FIRST HOMER HE HAS ALLOWED ALL
YEAR LONG.
SCOTT: A 93 MILE AN HOUR
FASTBALL YESTERDAY FROM SEWALD
THAT WAS PUT OVER THE WALL AND
THE FIRST HOME RUN FOR BREGMAN
SINCE JUNE 9.
CHRIS: THAT IS VERY COMMON FOR A
PITCHER.
IF I GIVE UP A HOME RUN TO YOU
ON A CERTAIN PITCH, THE NEXT
AT-BAT I WILL COME AT YOU WITH
THE SAME PITCH TO SHOW YOU I AM
NOT AFRAID TO THROW IT TO YOU.
THEY CAME WITH TWO FASTBALLS,
CHALLENGING BREGMAN.
BREGMAN IS PROBABLY THINKING
ABOUT THE SLIDER.
SUCH A MENTAL GAME WE PLAY ON
BOTH SIDES.
SCOTT: I LIKE JUST WATCHING.
BREGMAN STAYS ALIVE.
LAST NIGHT ASTROS DOWN TWO.
NOT ANYMORE.
CHRIS: BREGMAN WITH THE BIG TWO
RUN HOMER.
THE REASON HE GOT TO THAT
FASTBALL, SEWALD TIMED HIS
SLIDER EARLY IN THE COUNT.
BREGMAN SEEMS LIKE HE SEES HIM
PRETTY WELL, HAS HAD GOOD AT
BATS OFF OF SEWALD.
SCOTT: THEY MATCHED UP TWICE IN
THE PAST WEEK.
BREGMAN IS 2-2 AGAINST HIM,
HITTING .357 SINCE COMING BACK
FROM THE IL.
MISSED A COUPLE OF MONTHS.
YOU HAVE THAT GAUNTLET WAITING
AFTER BREGMAN GOES THE OTHER
WAY.
THAT IS GOING TO DROP IN THE
CORNER AS A FOUL BALL.
CHRIS: SOME HITTERS HAVE GUYS
THEY ARE ABLE TO SEE BETTER THAN
OTHERS.
SEWALD MAKES SO MANY PLAYERS
LOOK UNCOMFORTABLE.
YOU GET BREGMAN IN THE BOX, IT
SEEMS HE IS ABLE TO SEE
EVERYTHING HE IS THROWING.
SEWALD IS TRYING TO REESTABLISH
HIMSELF AT THE LAST GAME.
HE REALLY GOT IN TROUBLE WITH
THE BIG WALKED ALTUVE WHICH SET
UP THE HOMER.
HE SAID, I WILL ATTACK THE
STRIKE ZONE, GO AFTER BREGMAN,
MAKE THEM HIT THE BALL.
A FOUR RUN CUSHION CHANGES YOUR
MINDSET AS WELL.
SCOTT: BREGMAN HAS BEEN MOSTLY
PULLING THE BASEBALL LATELY.
HE DOES JUST THAT.
TO THE CRAWFORD BOXES, HE HAS
ANOTHER.
CHRIS: YOU HAVE YOUR GUYS.
THIS IS BECOMING A THING.
SCOTT: ALEX BREGMAN, GO LONG.
8-5, NO OUTS IN THE NINTH.
BACK-TO-BACK NIGHTS, BREGMAN OFF
OF SEWALD.
CHRIS: THAT CRAWFORD HOME RUN
MAY END UP BEING BIGGER THAN
INITIALLY SEEN.
THIS GAME IS FAR FROM OVER WITH
THIS ASTROS OFFENSE.
SCOTT: JOSE ALTUVE IN THE TOP OF
THE ORDER.
SEWALD STARTS HIM WITH A STRIKE.
IS THAT SECOND ROW, FIRST?
FIRST ROW, KNOCKED THE HAT OFF.
CHRIS: FAREWELL TO THE CRAWFORD
BOXES.
SCOTT: BREGMAN HAD THE DAY OFF
UP UNTIL THAT POINT.
PINCH-HIT HOMER.
NOW ALTUVE, WHO HOMERED IN THE
FIFTH.
BREGMAN AGAINST SEWALD TURNING
INTO CHRIS YOUNG AGAINST CHRIS
CARPENTER.
CHRIS: CHRIS CARPENTER WAS MY
GUY.
SCOTT: 11-13 FOR CY.
CHRIS: HE WAS A GREAT PITCHER,
GREAT GUY.
MADE EVERYONE UNCOMFORTABLE, BUT
FOR SOME REASON WHEN I GOT TO
THE BOX, I SAW THE BALL LIKE A
WATERMELON.
IT JUST HAPPENS FOR SOME GUYS.
SCOTT: KELENIC FADING IN.
THAT IS ONE.
CHRIS: THAT IS A BIG OUT FOR THE
MOMENTUM.
SOLO HOME RUNS NORMALLY DON'T
KILL YOU, BUT FOR THE NEXT
HITTER FOR ALTUVE, IT IS BIG.
IF HE WALKS ALTUVE, IT IS
SKETCHY.
FOR HIM TO GET THAT OUT ALLOWS
HIM TO SETTLE BACK IN AND GET
BACK TO WHAT HE DOES AND FINISH
THIS GAME OUT.
SCOTT: YOU GO BACK TO THE A.B.
FOR BREGMAN, SIX PITCHES, ALL OF
THEM WERE IN THE ZONE, EVEN
THOUGH IT WAS 0-2.
CHRIS: ALL IN THE ZONE AND IT
SEEMED LIKE REDMAN WAS OVER
EVERY PITCH, NO MATTER OF
FASTBALL OR SLIDER.
GRANTED IF HE PULLED IT FOUL, HE
WAS ON THE PITCHES AND ABLE TO
SEE THE BALL BIG OFF OF SEWALD.
SCOTT: NOT TRYING TO COAX HIM
INTO CHASING A PITCH.
EASIER SAID THAN DONE.
BRANTLEY TO CENTER GETS UNDER
IT.
CAL NICK WILL BACK UP A FEW
STEPS.
VERY SIMILAR SPOT.
--KELENIC WILL BACK UP A FEW
STEPS.
VERY SIMILAR SPOT.
THIS GIVES US SOME EXTRA OPTIONS
FOR TODAY'S YOUTUBE PLAYER OF
THE GAME.
ABRAHAM TORO, JARRED KELENIC,
WHO TIED THIS UP AT 4-4,
MARMOLEJOS WITH THE GO-AHEAD
KNOCK TO MAKE IT 6-4, J.P.
CRAWFORD WITH THE TWO RUN JOB.
THOSE ARE YOUR OPTIONS.
POLL OPENS NOW.
GURRIEL, WAVE AND A MISS.
CHRIS: I AM A BIG MARMOLEJOS
GUY, ESPECIALLY IF THE SCORE
STAYS WHERE IT IS IT IF YOU GET
THE GAME-WINNING R.B.I. AND A
COUPLE OF HITS, THAT HAS TO
PLAY.
SCOTT: I AM WITH YOU, PARTNER.
GURRIEL SKIES ONE.
HERE IS RALEIGH.
GAME OVER.
THE SEATTLE MARINERS TOP THE
HOUSTON ASTROS ON A WEDNESDAY
AFTERNOON BY A FINAL SCORE 8-5
AND THEY SALVAGE THE GAME AND
INCH CLOSER IN THE AMERICAN
LEAGUE WEST STANDINGS, 5.5 BACK
OF HOUSTON AND ALSO 2.5 GAMES
OUT OF A WILD-CARD SEED.
CHRIS: GREAT GAME BY THE
MARINERS ABLE TO COME THROUGH
ANOTHER CLOSE GAME, DOING WHAT
THEY DO.
NOT A ONE RUN GAME, BUT FELT
LIKE IT, WHEN ALL IS SAID AND
DONE.
ABLE TO COME IN LATE BULLPEN,
GREAT AT BATS BY MARMOLEJOS,
CRAWFORD, KELENIC, LATE IN THE
GAME, TO ESCAPE WITH THE WIN AND
HAVE A HAPPY FLIGHT.
SCOTT: THAT IS SEATTLE'S FORTE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT IT, RIGHT NOW.
THIS IS THE MLB GAME OF THE WEEK
LIVE ON YOUTUBE POSTGAME SHOW,
PRESENTED BY YOUTUBE SHORTS.
THE MARINERS HAVE A HAPPY COME
ALONG FLIGHT BACK AS THEY TAKE A
WIN OVER THE HOUSTON ASTROS.
SEATTLE IS OFF TOMORROW, AND
THEY START UP THE HOME STAND
WITH THREE AGAINST ARIZONA, AND
THREE AGAINST THE BOSTON RED
SOX, A TEAM THEY ARE CHASING,
FOR A WILD-CARD SEED.
THE SCHEDULE WE WILL GET TO IN A
FEW LOOKS FAVORABLE BASED ON THE
FACT SEATTLE EITHER IS TAKING ON
WEAKER OPPONENTS OR TEAMS THEY
ARE CHASING IN THE STANDINGS AND
THIS WAS A HUGE W AND AN
ABSOLUTE PLEASURE TO CALL.
SCOTT ALONG WITH CHRIS YOUNG.
THIS WAS TIGHT AS CAN BE, BACK
AND FORTH.
WE SAW BOTH TEAMS SHOW OFF THEIR
BEST STRENGTHS.
CHRIS: THEY NEEDED TO ESCAPE
WITH A WIN.
COMING OFF THOSE TWO LOSSES, IF
YOU'RE PLAYING THE ASTROS, IT IS
UNDERSTANDABLE IF YOU DON'T WIN
THE SERIES.
ESPECIALLY IF YOU'RE PLAYING
ARIZONA, THIS SETS UP THE HOME
STAND YOU HAVE COMING UP.
SCOTT: BRINGS MOMENTUM INTO THE
SIX-GAME HOME STAND FOR SEATTLE.
WHOEVER TAKES THAT IN THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE WILL GO ON A RUN
AT SOME POINT BECAUSE THERE ARE
QUITE A FEW THAT WERE HOT.
THEY WON FIVE IN A ROW.
THEY HAD THE LEAD THEY GAVE UP.
HOUSTON WAS UP BY TWO AND
SEATTLE BATTLES BACK.
WE WILL GET YOU ALL THE
HIGHLIGHTS IN A FEW.
WE HAVE OTHER BUSINESS FIRST,
INCLUDING THE YOUTUBE PLAYER OF
THE GAME, WHICH WE WILL DO IN A
COUPLE MOMENTS AND SOME POSTGAME
INTERVIEWS.
NICE FIRST GAME TO HAVE YOU.
THE NEXT 30 MINUTES ON YOUTUBE.
LET'S BRING IN THE BIG MAN, JOÉE
MARMOLEJOS.
COMES THROUGH WITH THE TWO
R.B.I. KNOCK AS THE SEATTLE
MARINERS TOOK THE LEAD OVER
SEATTLE IN THE NINTH INNING,
THANKS TO MARMOLEJOS AGAINST THE
ALL-STAR RYAN PRESSLY.
JOSE, CONGRATULATIONS ON THE W
AND THE BIG HITTING.
TAKE US THROUGH THAT AT-BAT
AGAINST ONE OF THE BETTER RELIEF
PITCHERS IN MAJOR LEAGUE WHAT
DID YOU SEE?
JOSE: THANK YOU, I APPRECIATE
IT.
I WAS LOOKING TO STAY, NOT GET
TOO LONG OF A SWING, JUST HAVE A
GOOD SWING FOR THE TEAM.
I JUST HAPPENED TO GET IT AND
PUT THE BAT TO THE BALL.
DID NOT TRY TO DO TOO MUCH AND
IT WORKED OUT.
A MAJOR BLESSING.
CHRIS: THAT WAS GREAT.
SEEING YOU IN THAT SITUATION BE
ABLE TO TAKE A BALL OFF THE
PLATE THROUGH THE MIDDLE OF THE
FIELD, IT DOES NOT MATTER ABOUT
THE SHIFT, YOU ARE ABLE TO PUT
THE BAT ON THE BALL AND MAKE
SOMETHING HAPPEN FOR YOUR TEAM.
WITH THE LOSS YESTERDAY, HOW BIG
WAS IT TO COME THROUGH IN THAT
SITUATION?
JOSE: IT IS ALWAYS GRATIFYING TO
BE ABLE TO DO SOMETHING TO HELP
YOUR TEAM WIN.
I AM TRULY THANKFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY.
SO THANKFUL WITH THIS TEAM.
IT IS AWESOME TO HAVE THIS AND
BRING IT BACK TO MY HOME STAND.
SCOTT: ARE YOU ALSO FULL FOR THE
SHIFT?
SOMETIMES IT BURNS HITTERS IN
THE BIG LEAGUES.
IT WENT TO A SPOT CARLOS CORREA
MIGHT USUALLY BE.
WHAT DID YOU THINK ABOUT THE
PLACEMENT OF THE BASEBALL.
JOSE: IT IS ALL ABOUT THE
PLACEMENT AND IT WORKED OUT.
YOU KNOW IT WORKED OUT AND I WAS
SO THANKFUL.
SCOTT: BECAUSE OF THAT HIT, THE
FANS ABOUT YOU AS THE YOUTUBE
PLAYER OF THE GAME.
I KNOW YOU ARE A BIG, STRONG
DUDE.
HOW DOES THAT FEEL?
JOSE: THAT FEELS AMAZING.
IT IS REALLY NICE.
SCOTT: IT HAS SOME WEIGHT, IT
WILL HAVE YOUR NAME ON IT,
ENGRAVED FOR YOU.
A SPECIAL DAY WITH THE MARINERS
WATCHED WORLDWIDE ON YOUTUBE AND
PICKING UP A HUGE WIN.
DID HAVE A PLAYOFF FEEL IN TERMS
OF INTENSITY?
WE SAW A TON OF PITCHERS.
YOU HAD BULLPENS THAT WERE SAVED
UP, OFF DAYS FOR BOTH TEAMS.
WHAT WAS THE FEELING IN THE
DUGOUT ABOUT HOW THIS WAS
PLAYING OUT FROM A STRATEGIC
STANDPOINT?
JOSE: IF THE ADRENALINE WAS
THERE, WE WANTED TO GET OUT
THERE AND PLAY BASEBALL AND WIN,
PITCH AFTER PITCH.
WE WERE LOCKED IN.
THE TEAM NEVER GAVE UP.
WE WERE GRINDING.
THIS TEAM WAS AMAZING.
EVERYBODY WANTS TO BE THERE, GET
IT DONE.
IT IS A BLESSING.
WE GET THIS WIN AND KEEP IT
GOING.
CHRIS: HAPPY FLIGHT.
TO BE ABLE TO COME IN, THE BIG
DOUBLE OFF THE WALL, THE BASE
HIT TO TAKE THE LEAD, HOW WILL
YOUR TEAM CARRY THIS MOMENTUM TO
ARIZONA WHEN YOU GET HOME?
JOSE: THE WORK ETHIC IS AMAZING.
THIS IS A TEAM THAT WILL NOT
GIVE UP.
JUST WITH THE WORK ETHIC, THIS
IS A SPECIAL TEAM.
A REALLY GOOD TEAM.
SCOTT: YOU HAD A SPECIAL TEAM,
YOU WERE CRUSHING THE BASEBALL,
AMONG THE AAA WEST LEADERS THIS
SEASON.
HOW DID YOU FEEL YOUR SEASON
WENT IN AAA.
HOW DO YOU CARRY THAT MOMENTUM
INTO THE BIG LEAGUES?
ARE THERE ASPECTS OF YOUR GAME
YOU ARE CONTINUING FOR THIS
STRETCH?
JOSE: I MAJOR BLESSING.
I WANT TO KEEP WORKING EVERY DAY
ON THE WORK ETHIC, DON'T GET
AHEAD OF MYSELF, TRUSTING THE
EVERYDAY PROCESS, DON'T TRY TO
GET AHEAD OR THINK ABOUT THE
PAST.
JUST LIVE IN THE MOMENT AND
TRUSTING THE WORK ETHIC EVERY
DAY AND MY COACHES AND
TEAMMATES.
CHRIS: I LOVE THE ENERGY, THE
MINDSET.
WHERE WILL YOU PUT THAT TROPHY
IN YOUR HOUSE?
JOSE: THIS WILL BE NEXT TO THE
TV SO I CAN SEE IT EVERY TIME I
SIT DOWN.
SCOTT: MAKES SENSE, YOU STREAM
YOUTUBE ONTO YOUR TV.
WE WILL SEND YOU ONE WITH YOUR
NAME ON IT.
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR VICTORY,
ON WINNING YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE
GAME.
HAVE A HAPPY FLIGHT AND ENJOY
THIS FIGHT FOR A POSTSEASON SPOT
FOR SEATTLE.
JOSE: I TRULY APPRECIATE IT.
HAVE A GOOD ONE.
SCOTT: JOSE MARMOLEJOS IS YOUR
YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME.
THIS IS ONE OF THE TIGHTER RACES
THIS YEAR.
MARINERS FANS AND EVERYONE
WATCHING ON YOUTUBE SAY JOSE
MARMOLEJOS IS THE PLAYER OF THE
GAME, 31% OF THE PIE, BUT
EVERYONE WAS AT 20% PLUS.
IT WAS A TEAM CONTRIBUTION FOR
THIS VICTORY.
THAT HELPS TELL THE STORY AND WE
HAVE MUCH MORE IN A MOMENTS.
>> HE JUST SMOKES IT.
>> FORGET ABOUT IT.
>> MY GOODNESS.
GREAT BASEBALL RIGHT THERE.
>> THAT BALL WAS CRUSHED.
>> THIS IS GOING TO DO IT.
>> OH MY.
>> STRIKE THREE.
THAT IS A GREAT PLAY.
>> TALKED ABOUT HIS FIELDING
SKILLS.
THAT WAS REMARKABLE.
>> SOMETHING LIKE THIS IS WHAT
THEY CAME FOR.
SCOTT: WHAT A SERIES, WHAT A
FINISH TO THIS ONE.
ASTROS TOOK THE FIRST TWO AND
THE MARINERS TAKE THE LAST
MEETING IN 2021 IN THE REGULAR
SEASON BETWEEN SEATTLE AND
HOUSTON HERE AT MINUTE MAID
PARK.
SCOTT BRAUN AND CHRIS YOUNG
WATCHING THE HIGHLIGHTS.
IF YOU MISSED ANYTHING, IT LOOKS
LIKE THIS.
ABRAHAM TORO DIGS IN WITH BASES
LOADED.
RIPS ONE TO RIGHT FIELD, PLENTY
OF OPEN SPACE.
HE IS IN BUSINESS.
SEAGER WILL SCORE AS WELL, A TWO
R.B.I. TWO BAGGER FOR ABRAHAM
TORO.
HE CONTINUES TO PUNISH HIS
FORMER SQUAD.
CORREA, MR. WALKOFF MAN FROM
YESTERDAY.
HE RIPS THAT ONE INTO THE CLUB
AT THE HOT CORNER OF KYLE
SEAGER.
THAT IS ROCKET RETRIEVAL.
CHRIS: THAT IS WHEN YOU GO INTO
THE DUGOUT AND EVERYBODY SAYS,
NICE SWING.
THAT SHOULD HAVE TAKEN HIS GLOVE
OFF OF HIS HAND.
>> ONE OUT FOR TALKER.
SCOTT: TUCKER INTO LEFT CENTER.
IT IS GOING TO HOP UP AGAINST
THE WALL.
ALVAREZ HEADING FOR THIRD.
HE IS BEING WAVED HOME.
THE THROW IS NOT IN TIME.
THE ASTROS ARE ON THE BOARD.
AN R.B.I. DOUBLE FOR KYLE TUCKER
MAKING IT 2-1.
MARWIN GONZALEZ, PLAYED WITH THE
ASTROS FROM 2012 TO 2018.
HEADS TO THE CRAWFORD BOXES.
ASTROS GRAB THE LEAD, 3-2, OFF A
SHOT FROM MARWIN GONZALEZ.
WELCOME BACK TO HOUSTON, MARWIN.
>> TWO OUTS.
, MARINERS DOWN 3-2.
>> AN OFFSPEED PITCH TO THE LEFT
SIDE.
ON A SLIDE GONZALES THROWS OUT
TO -- THROWS OUT TORRENS.
AT MINUTE MAID PARK THE ASTROS
LEAD IT 3-2.
SCOTT: ABRAHAM TORO HITS THE
OTHER WAY, LEFT CENTER FIELD.
MEYERS CHASING IT AND HE HAS THE
BASEBALL.
NOW HEADING BACK TO FIRST AND
THERE SAFELY IS KYLE SEAGER.
JAKE MEYERS WITH THE CLOSING
SPEED.
CHRIS: WHAT A GREAT PLAY.
SCOTT: ALTUVE HOMERED YESTERDAY.
2-1.
LEFT FIELD.
DOES HE HAVE IT ON BACK-TO-BACK
DAYS?
HE DOES.
JOSE ALTUVE DID NOT HOMER FOR A
MONTH.
GOES LONG YESTERDAY AND DOUBLES
UP THIS AFTERNOON.
NUMBER 27 ON THE SEASON.
MAKE IT 4-2, HOUSTON.
WE KEEP ROLLING IN THE SEVENTH.
1-3, TWO OUTS.
PHIL MATON IN THE GAME.
JUST ONE PITCH FOR KELENIC TO
LIKE IT.
IT SCORES TWO AND TIES THE GAME
AT 4-4.
THAT IS WHEN THINGS REALLY
TURNED UP AND SEATTLE NEW AT
THIS POINT WE HAVE OUR CLUTCH
KNOCK FROM A ROOKIE, NOW WE NEED
TO PUT THIS GAME AWAY.
2-3, TWO OUTS.
TY FRANCE IS THE BETTER.
HE HAS COME UP CLUTCH SO OFTEN
FOR SEATTLE.
THIS TIME MARWIN GONZALES IS
ABLE TO PUT HIM AWAY AND
PRESERVE THIS 4-4 GAME.
THAT COMES TO CARLOS CORREA.
CASTILLO WAS LIKE, OH MAN.
WE WERE LOOKING AT HIM LIKE,
WHAT IS HE UPSET ABOUT?
CHRIS: CASTILLO HAD HIS STUFF
WORKING TODAY, THE SINKER-SLIDER
COMBO EXPANDING, HAD THE ASTROS
ON THEIR HEELS.
SCOTT: HE STRUCK OUT THE SIDE
AFTER THAT.
IN THE NINTH, JOSE MARMOLEJOS,
MR. YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME.
HE IS PUTTING THE TROPHY NEXT TO
THE TV AT HOME.
CHRIS: THE IDEAL.
HE HAD BIG AT-BATS, A DOUBLE
EARLY IN THE GAME.
CRAWFORD COMES UP TO PUT A
LITTLE CUSHION ON IT.
GIVES SEWALD CUSHION TO FINISH
THE GAME AND CLOSE IT OUT.
SCOTT: IT HAPPENS ON
BACK-TO-BACK DAYS.
THEY HAD A FOUR-RUN LEAD, WHICH
REALLY HELPED.
THEN IT WAS GURRIEL IN FOUL
GROUND.
THE MARINERS SECURING AN 8-5 W
OVER THE ASTROS.
81-58 ON THE SEASON.
SEATTLE IS 76-64 ON THE YEAR.
THE ASTROS 5.5 UP IN THE A.L.
WEST.
THE MARINERS 2.5 GAMES SHY OF
THE WILD-CARD.
LET'S GET MORE, AND ANOTHER
INTERVIEW.
BRETT DOLAN, TAKE IT AWAY.
BRETT: THEY SEATTLE MARINERS WON
FOR THE FIFTH TEEN -- 15TH TIME.
THEY NEEDED LATE INNING HITS
WHICH THEY WERE ABLE TO GET IN
THE 10TH INNING.
YOU ALSO NEED CONTRIBUTIONS FROM
BIG-TIME PLAYERS EARLIER IN
GAMES, EVEN SOME OF THE GUYS WHO
STARTED THE YEAR AS HOUSTON
ASTROS, LIKE ABRAHAM TORO.
HAD A CHANCE TO CATCH UP WITH
HIM A FEW MOMENTS AGO.
AFTER LAST NIGHT, HOW BIG WAS
THIS WIN FOR THE MARINERS?
ABRAHAM: FEELS GOOD TO BOUNCE
BACK.
WE GAVE THEM SOME ATTITUDE AND
GOOD AT BATS.
WE GOT THAT ROLLING.
BRETT: YOU HAD ONE OF THOSE GOOD
AT-BATS EARLY, 14 R.B.I.'S
AGAINST YOUR FORMER TEAM.
WHAT IS IT ABOUT FOCUS IN THESE
HEAD-TO-HEAD AT-BATS?
ABRAHAM: THERE IS THAT
ADJUSTMENT.
I WAS ABLE TO DO MY HOMEWORK AND
IT PAID OFF.
BRETT: I AM THINKING ABOUT TWO
PLAYOFFS.
WHAT WOULD IT TAKE FOR SEATTLE
TO MAKE A RUN TO GET INTO THIS
POSTSEASON?
ABRAHAM: OUR PITCHERS HAVE BEEN
GOOD, A LOT OF LOW-SCORING
GAMES.
THE OFFENSE HAS STARTED TO
CLICK.
WE COULD MAKE A PUSH FOR THE
PLAYOFF.
BRETT: CONGRATULATIONS ON THE
WIN.
ONE THING STANDS OUT, SMILES.
WINNING IS SUPPOSED TO BE FUN.
THIS IS AN ORGANIZATION TRYING
TO BUILD, TO BE RELEVANT IN
SEPTEMBER.
THEY TRIED TO PICK UP KEY WINS.
ABLE TO SNEAK ONE AWAY FROM THE
HOUSTON ASTROS AND THEY ARE
ENJOYING THE RIDE FOR THE FINAL
GAME OF THE ROAD TRIP.
MARINERS WIN IN 10 INNINGS OVER
THE HOUSTON ASTROS.
WE WILL RETURN TO MINUTE MADE
PARK AFTER THIS.
>> DESPITE ALL OF US GOING TO
THE SAME PLACE, WE ALL COME FOR
DIFFERENT REASONS.
SOME COME FOR THE SIGHTS, SOME
FOR THE SOUNDS.
SOME COME FOR THE BONDS.
SOME FOR THE BONDS.
SOME COME FOR PASSION.
SOME COME FOR THE PLAYS.
WE ALL COME TO BE PART OF
SOMETHING BIGGER THAN OURSELVES.
REGARDLESS, THERE IS A TICKET
FOR YOU.
ASTROS SEASON TICKETS, FOR THE
H.
>> WAY BACK.
♪
>> IT IS OUT OF HERE.
>> YOU HAVE GOT TO BE KIDDING
ME.
>> UNBELIEVABLE.
>> SEE YA.
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE IT.
>> I DON'T BELIEVE IT.
>> WHAT A PITCH.
>> WHAT A WAY TO WIN.
SCOTT: WHAT A FINISH IN THIS ONE
AT MINUTE MAID PARK IN HOUSTON.
HOT DAY OUT THERE.
YOU LIVE RIGHT AROUND THE
CORNER.
THIS IS THE REGULAR WEATHER WE
HAVE BEEN DEALING WITH OVER THE
LAST MONTH PLUS, MID 90'S.
A BIT OF SWEAT.
CHRIS: SUMMERTIME IN HOUSTON, A
BIT OF HUMIDITY IN THE AIR.
I AM GRATEFUL THEY HAD THE ROOF
CLOSED TODAY, OR WE WOULD BE
FEELING THAT HEAT.
SCOTT: INSIDE AT MINUTE MAID
PARK, TEMPERATURE CONTROLLED.
ASTROS GRAB THE FIRST TWO IN
THIS SERIES, THEN FALL TO
SEATTLE.
8-5 IS YOUR FINAL SCORE FOR YOUR
YOUTUBE GAME OF THE WEEK.
SCOTT BRAUN WITH CHRIS.
CY WITH US THE FIRST TIME THIS
SEASON.
WE HAD HOUSTON A FEW TIMES THIS
YEAR.
WE GUSHED OVER THE STRENGTHS OF
THIS TEAM BECAUSE THERE ARE
MANY.
THERE IS A REASON WHY THEY ARE
LEADING THE AMERICAN LEAGUE WEST
AND LOOK LIKE ONE OF THE
JUGGERNAUTS OF MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL.
THERE ARE NOT MANY FLAWS.
IF THERE WAS ONE, IT WAS THE
BULLPEN.
THEY PICK UP FOUR PIECES AND IT
HAS MADE A BIG DIFFERENCE.
THE BULLPEN DID NOT HELP THINGS
OUT TODAY.
THEY DID GIVE THINGS UP WITH
RYAN PRESSLY AND THE BLOWN SAVE,
BUT YOU LOOK AT HOW THIS TEAM IS
LOADED UP FOR THE POSTSEASON, IT
IS A SPECIAL, TALENTED CLUB.
CHRIS: IN THE AMERICAN LEAGUE
YOU HAVE THE ASTROS AND THE
NATIONAL LEAGUE, THE DODGERS.
TWO COMPLETE TEAMS PRIMED AND
READY FOR PLAYOFFS.
YOU HAVE -- GRANTED, ASTROS
DON'T HAVE SUPERSTAR NAMES, BUT
THEY HAVE SIX QUALITY STARTERS
THAT CAN GIVE YOU A GOOD SEVEN
INNINGS IN THE PLAYOFFS.
ON TOP OF THAT, YOU HAVE A
DOMINANT OFFENSE.
NO MATTER IF YOU ARE TOP OF OR
DOWN TO THE EIGHT HOLE,
ESPECIALLY WITH BREGMAN IN THE
LINEUP, YOU DON'T HAVE ANY
HOLES.
YOU HAVE MALDONADO AT THE BOTTOM
CATCHING A GREAT GAME, RUNNING
THE PITCHING STAFF PERFECTLY.
SCOTT: YOU HAVE THE A.L., ASTROS
OVER THE RAYS, IF YOU HAD TO
GUESS NOW, ARE THEY MORE
COMPLETE THAN TAMPA BAY?
CHRIS: WHEN I AM WATCHING AS THE
FAN, I WOULD FAVOR THE ASTROS.
I UNDERSTAND THE NUMBERS MAY GO
AGAINST THAT.
I UNDERSTAND WHAT THE RAYS HAVE
DONE THIS SEASON.
AS A FAN, WHEN I WATCH THESE
TEAMS PLAY, THE ASTROS ARE
PRIMED.
I FEEL IF THEY GET TO THE
PLAYOFFS, THEY WILL BE A
HANDFUL.
SCOTT: IF IT IS ASTROS-DODGERS
IN THE WORLD SERIES, HAVEN'T WE
SEEN THAT IN THE RECENT PAST?
TO THOSE TEAMS LIKE EACH OTHER?
CHRIS: NOT MUCH.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THE FANS FEEL
ABOUT EACH OTHER, EITHER.
IT WILL BE FUN.
I WOULD BE FINE WITH ANOTHER
ASTROS-DODGERS WORLD SERIES.
SCOTT: THE WORLD WOULD BE FINE
WITH THE DRAMA.
WE LIKED CAL RALEIGH WITH THE
MIC.
THANK YOU AND WE WANT TO HEAR
THE BEST FROM CAL TODAY.
KEEP IN MIND HE CAUGHT THE FINAL
OUT.
HOW DID HE SOUND ON THE
MICROPHONE?
>> ARE YOU MIC'D UP?
OF ALL THE PEOPLE TO MIC UP.
>> I SAID THE SAME THING, YOU
WANT ME TO DO IT?
>> THE GUY THAT CAN'T EVEN
COMMUNICATE, YOU WILL MIC HIM UP
?
>> IT IS NOT MY -- WHAT IS THE
WORD I'M LOOKING FOR?
IT IS NOT MY FORTE.
MY UNCLE HAS THE BIGGEST WORLD
SERIES RING EVER MADE.
FLORIDA MARLINS FURTHER 2003 OR
2002.
HE DID NOT KNOW HIS RING SIZE SO
HE WENT TO THE STORE -- I TOLD
THE STORY THE OTHER DAY.
HE WENT TO THE JEWELER TO GET
SIZED.
THEY DID NOT HAVE ANYTHING THAT
FIT HIM.
IT WAS A 17.5.
DO THEY DO HAVES -- HALVES?
HE HAS SAUSAGE FINGERS.
I WENT ON A KICK IN HIGH SCHOOL
WHERE I REALLY WANTED A PAIR OF
CONVERSE SHOES, I DON'T KNOW
WHY.
THE HIGHTOPS LIKE LARRY BIRD,
BLACK, SAM LONG AND ALL THAT.
I WENT ON A KICK AND WANTED A
BLACK-AND-WHITE PAIR.
I DON'T REALLY HAVE THE BODY TO
ROCK THEM, THOUGH.
I THINK YOU HAVE TO BE A SKATER
BOY TO ROCK THOSE.
>> YOU WEREN'T A SKATER BOY?
>> YOU HAVE TO ROCK TIGHT PANTS.
YOU CAN'T WEAR THEM WITH SHORTS
BECAUSE THEY ARE HIGHTOPS.
IT IS JUST NOT MY STYLE, IT IS
WHAT IT IS.
I THINK IT IS COOL, YOU CAN ROCK
THEM.
SOMEBODY ASKED ME THAT ONE TIME.
THEY SAID, SO YOU ARE A SWITCH
HITTER, RIGHT?
THAT MEANS YOU ARE AMPHIBIOUS.
I WAS LIKE, WHAT?
YOU ARE AMPHIBIOUS, YOU HIT BOTH
WAYS.
NOT EXACTLY.
THIS IS MY CHANCE.
I HAVE AN AUDIENCE NOW.
IF CODY JAYNES HEARS THIS, I AM
GOING TO YOUR CONCERT THIS
OFF-SEASON.
♪ ALWAYS FOUND ME ♪
NOT LIKE HE IS MY WALK UP SONG
OR ANYTHING.
SCOTT: I HAVE TO MAKE SURE I
REACH OUT TO CODY JAYNES AND WE
HOOK UP CAL RALEIGH, ESPECIALLY
FOR BEING ON YOUTUBE WITH US.
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
CONNECTION HAPPENS.
IT WILL BE ON MAY BE THE LAST
YOUTUBE GAME OF THE WEEK THAT WE
DO.
OR MAYBE NEXT WEEK, EVEN.
WE WILL BE CLOSE TO HOLLYWOOD.
CHRIS: WE HAVE TO MAKE SOMETHING
HAPPEN FOR HIM.
SCOTT: I WILL WORK ON THAT, CAL.
YOU WORK ON GETTING THIS TEAM TO
THE POSTSEASON FOR THE FIRST
TIME SINCE 2001.
IT MAY NOT LOOK FAVORABLE AND
THE A.L., BUT THE WILD-CARD
CONTINUES TO GET TIGHTER.
BLUE JAYS TWO BACK, MARINERS 2.5
AWAY.
OAKLAND HAS SPUTTERED, LOST FOUR
IN A ROW.
THE YANKEES AND RED SOX KEEP
COMING DOWN THE EARTH -- DOWN TO
EARTH AND MAKING US THINK IS
THIS THE YEAR THE SEATTLE
MARINERS SNAPPED THE LONGEST
PLAYOFF DROUGHT AMONG THE MAJOR
PRO SPORTS?
CHRIS: THIS IS A POSITION THEY
PUT THEMSELVES INTO.
IF YOU GO TO THEM AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE SEASON AND TELL
THEM THEY WILL BE A COUPLE GAMES
OUT, 2.5 GAMES OUT OF THE
WILD-CARD, WOULD YOU TAKE THAT
POSITION, I THINK THEY WILL.
WITH THE YANKEES IN BOSTON, I
FEEL ONE IF NOT BOTH HAVE TO
GIVE.
I THINK BOSTON COULD POTENTIALLY
FALL OUT.
THE BLUE JAYS HAVE BEEN PLAYING
WELL.
THEY HAVE BEEN A TEAM I PICKED
TO CLICK ALL YEAR LONG.
THEY HAVE A GREAT TEAM AND
ANOTHER GREAT OFFENSE IN THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE.
SCOTT: EVENTUALLY THEY WOULD
LIKE TO GET INTO THE WORLD
SERIES BECAUSE IT HAS NOT
HAPPENED FOR THEM.
IT IS THE LONGEST ACTIVE PENNANT
DRAFT -- DROUGHT.
EVEN IF IT DOES NOT HAPPEN THIS
YEAR, WE ARE LOOKING AT A
BALLCLUB THAT HAS, ACCORDING TO
MLB.COM, THE NUMBER ONE RANKED
ARM SYSTEM.
KELENIC IS NOT ON THAT LIST
ANYMORE, HE IS NOT A PROSPECT.
THEY STILL HAVE FOUR PLAYERS IN
THE TOP 40 ACCORDING TO MLB
PIPELINE.
THERE IS A CORE STARTING TO
BUILD AND A TON OF TALENT FOR A
SEATTLE TEAM THINKING ABOUT
MAKING IT TO THE POSTSEASON.
THEY ARE TRYING TO BUILD A
WINNER WITH SUSTAINED SUCCESS TO
HAVE PROSPECTS CAPITAL, WHICH
HELPS YOU FOR YOUR BIG-LEAGUE
ALL CLUB, BUT ALSO WITH TRADES.
THERE IS A LOT OF HOPE.
SUDDENLY THE RAIN IS STARTING TO
SETTLE AREA CHRIS: -- SETTLE.
CHRIS: THE MARINERS COULD BE A
REALLY GOOD BALLCLUB.
IF YOU ARE OWNERSHIP, YOU DON'T
WANT TO SPEND TOO MUCH MONEY TOO
EARLY IF YOUR TEAM IS NOT READY.
I THINK THEY ARE IN A GREAT
POSITION.
KYLE LEWIS WILL BE COMING BACK
IN CENTER.
YOU HAVE RODRIGUEZ, A HUGE
PROSPECT, WHO JUST PLAYED IN THE
FUTURES GAME.
SCOTT: JULIO RODRIGUEZ, NUMBER
TWO RANKED IN ALL OF BASEBALL.
CHRIS: THAT BEING SAID, YOU HAVE
THREE GUYS OUT THERE YOU ARE NOT
PAYING A LOT OF MONEY.
YOU HAVE A LOT OF CAP ROOM,
MONEY TO SPEND.
THE MARINERS ARE NOT A
SMALL-MARKET TEAM.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ASSUME THEY ARE
A SMALL-MARKET TEAM.
THEY CAN MAKE A FEW KEY
ADDITIONS AND BE A REALLY GOOD
BALLCLUB.
SCOTT: SOME PITCHERS, AN
INFIELDER OR TWO.
THERE ARE A TON OF SHORTSTOPS.
J.P. CRAWFORD HAS BEEN GREAT.
HE COULD POTENTIALLY MOVE TO
ANOTHER SPOT.
THERE IS A LOT HE COULD DO.
LET'S TAKE YOU BACK TO JAKE
MEYERS COVERING A TON OF GROUND.
10% CATCH PROBABILITY MEANS THAT
WAS A REALLY TOUGH PLAY TO MAKE.
I AM SITTING NEXT TO A CENTER
FIELDER AND YOU KNOW DESPITE HIM
NOT DIVING -- HE WENT ALL OUT,
JUST IN A DIFFERENT WAY.
THAT IS DIFFICULT TO PULL UP.
SECRET BASE, OUR CREATOR
SPOTLIGHT, WANTS TO SAY, I THINK
I PULLED SOMETHING WATCHING JAKE
MAKE THAT PLAY.
CHRIS: THAT IS A PLAY -- YOU SEE
THIS 10% PROBABILITY.
THAT IS A PLAY NORMALLY ONLY THE
HOME FIELD TEAM WILL MAKE
BECAUSE JAKE KNOWS THIS
OUTFIELD.
DUSTY BAKER TOLD US HE WAS
COMFORTABLE WITH MEYERS IN
CENTER FIELD.
THAT BALL IS FIVE FEET TO THE
LEFT OF THAT WALL JUTTING OUT.
THAT COULD HAVE BEEN A VERY
DANGEROUS PLAY, BUT WITH GREAT
COMMUNICATION FROM LEFT FIELD
AND JAKE BEING COMFORTABLE WITH
MINUTE MAID PARK, HE IS ABLE TO
GET THE BALL IN.
SCOTT: HE LOOKS LIKE HE HAS BEEN
DOING IT FOR YEARS.
ASTROS FALL TO THE MARINERS, TWO
MORE GAMES TO GO.
NEXT WEEK ON FRIDAY A NIGHT GAME
BETWEEN THE A'S FIGHTING FOR A
PLAYOFF SPOT.
SHOHEI OHTANI AND THE ANGELS.
CARDINALS-BREWERS.
BREWERS IN CONTROL OF THE
CENTRAL.
WE HAVE TWO GOOD ONES ON THE
DOCKET FOR THE REST OF THE WAY.
THIS WAS AWESOME.
DID YOU ENJOY IT?
CHRIS: IT IS GREAT TO DO THIS IN
MY HOME FIELD, GREAT TO BE HERE
WITH YOU.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO MAN
THE BOOTH WITH YOU.
SCOTT: MLB GAME OF THE WEEK
YOUTUBE SWINGS BACK FRIDAY.
A'S AND ANGELS, SHOHEI OHTANI
TIME.
IT IS A FRIDAY NIGHT GAME.
OUR POSTGAME STARTS AT 9:00
EASTERN.
FOR OUR FRIENDS AND ENTIRE CREW,
I AM SCOTT BRAUN LOGGING OUT FOR
NOW.
SEE YOU NEXT WEEK ON FRIDAY
NIGHT.
[CAPTIONING PERFORMED BY THE
NATIONAL CAPTIONING INSTITUTE,
WHICH IS RESPONSIBLE FOR ITS
CAPTION CONTENT AND ACCURACY.
VISIT NCICAP.ORG]